COMMITTEE NUMBER TWO WILL COME
TO ORDER GOOD MORNING MISS
REQUIRE AND GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE IN RESPONSE TO THE
COVER NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC LEGISLATORS
EMPLOYEES YOU MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MAKE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES. IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WE'RE GOING THERE ARE
COMMITTEE HEARS AT THE CAPITAL
WITH SOME MEMBERS PURCHASING
REMOTELY CENTER STERN WILL BE
JOINING US AT EIGHT TWENTY-
TODAY THREE MEMBERS ARE
EXPECTED IN THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
HEARING ONE SENATOR REMOTELY WE
ARE PROVIDING WHEN CENTER STERN
COMES I WILL RECOGNIZE HIM AND
IF HE HAS ANY STAFF WITH HIM
HE'LL HAVE TO IDENTIFY THEM
PURSUANT TO OUR RULES THIS
WRITING TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE WILL ALSO BE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FOR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MOVE
YOUR PHONE. OR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN EIGHTEEN
ANTI BECAUSE HE COULD BE BACK I
ASKED EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO BE
RECOGNIZED THAT USED TO RAISE
YOUR HAND FEATURE ON THE
PROGRAM EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING YOU.
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO A TO A NEW
PLEASE SELECT ON YOU BEFORE YOU
BEGAN TO SPEAK R. I. T.
PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU BACK ON
MUTE WHEN YOU'RE DONE ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE THAT YOU CAN BE SEEN ON
THE SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME. AND
THEN YOU ARE READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO
HEARING ROOM CITY EXCEPT TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS
ALLOW AND WILL BE USING THE
TELE. CONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO IS TO
TESTIFY TODAY FOR INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT TO PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON THE
SCREEN AND I WILL NOW SIT NOW
THESE PARTICIPATE NUMBER IS
844-291-6364 AND X. SIX CODE IS
FOURTEEN SEVENTEEN SIX OH NINE.
FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON
HOW THE TELECONFERENCES TO
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE IN OR COMMITTEE.
WEBSITES PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO. I HEAR YOU
CLEARLY O AVOID. FREE YOU MUST
MEET YOU DEVICE ALL- FUTURE
WATCHING THE HEARING. TO K.
TEST. OVER THE PHONE. IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING. AS
IS CUSTOMARY AN INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVD
FROM THE REMOTE- MEETING
SERVICE AND HAVE. THEIR
CONNECTION MUTED PUBLIC COMMENT
WILL BE HEARD. AFTER ALL
DISCUSSION ITEMS HAVE BEEN
PRESENTED THAT'S AT THE END OF
THE HEARING. I EXPECT TO START
PUBLIC HEARING AT TEN FORTY
FIVE. WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS
BEEN MADE TO STREAMLINE THE
HEARING PROCESS TO GET BACK
HEARING. IN THIS CLOSE THE SAME
MANNER AS- IS CUSTOMARY- THERE
MAY BE SOME LAG TIMES. FOR
PARTICIPANTS WERE ADJUSTING TO
NEW USE OF ONLINE TOOLS OR
TECHNOLOGIES PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL OF PATIENTS. SO ARE-
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE HEARD
LAST WEEK FOR EVERYONE.
PHYSICALLY PRESENT HERE TODAY
PLEASE KEEP YOUR MASCOT.
COVERING YOUR NOSE AND MOUTH AT
ALL TIMES BEFORE WE BEGIN. I
DID LOWER THE PASSCODE. MISTER
MCGUIRE IF HE HAS ANY OPENING
COMMENTS. THIS IS YOUR THE FOR
TO WORK WITH YOU KNOW THIS IS
SUCH A CRITICAL YEAR ESPECIALLY
WHEN IT COMES A WILDFIRE
PREVENTION RESPONSE AFTER THE
FOUR MILLION ACRES THAT BURNED
LAST YEAR. IN APPRECIATE YOUR
LEADERSHIP SIR IN THE FOURTH OR
WORK TOGETHER. EXCELLENT CENTER
DOLLY CENTER STERN COME WILL
ESTABLISH A QUORUM WITH APPLES
WILL PROCEED TO SUBCOMMITTEE.
OUR FIRST- WE HAVE FIVE ITEMS
FOR DISCUSSION- I DON'T NUMBER
EIGHT HAS BEEN REMOVED FROM
THE- VOTE ONLY CALENDAR AND
WILL BE HEARD. AT A DIFFERENT
TIME WILL HAVE TO SEPARATE
CALENDARS ON VOTE ONLY- AT THE
END OF A- ARE HEARING. ALL
RGHT LET'S START WITH AYE
NUMBER SIXTEEN THIS. IS THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ARE YOU
HERE TO PRESENT. THIS IS.
THANKS. BARTALI SEVERE IN FIVE
MINUTES THIS IS NUMBER SIXTEEN
WHERE YOU GOT. ALFA A LONG WAYS
AWAY FOR A LONG WAYS AWAY FROM
ME. CENTER VALLEY THERE'S ANY
COMMENTS YOU'D LIKE TO SEE
BEFORE WE'RE JUST READY TO THIS
THE START ON- ISSUE SIXTEEN
THIS IS OUR TRADITIONAL TIME
ONE OF THE FIRST HEARING OF
THE- TWO YEAR SESSION. WHAT I
WOULD LIKE TO SAY I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
GUYS WE GOT A LOT OF FUN. NO
CHALLENGES WITH FIRE AND- AND
FOUR MILLION ACRES BURNED UP
LAST YEAR AND SO- I LOOK
FORWARD TO GETTING SOME MONEY
TO. IN THE RIGHT PLACES TO
CORRECT THOSE ISSUES OKAY WILL
WE HAVE THE PARKS AND
RECREATION- UP WE HAVE A
BOATING. BOATING PROGRAMS TALK
ABOUT RAISING OUR FEES FROM
TWENTY DOLLARS TO SEVENTY
DOLLARS MOTHER LONG TERM.
CHANGES LET'S GO AHEAD.
ACCORDING TO GERMAN MURDERS
MINES WILL SHOP SMALL ON THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE SERVICES WITH
STATE PARKS. SO THIS PROPOSAL
IS TO PROVIDE FISCAL STABILITY
FOR THE HARBORS WATER PRACTICAL
AND FUN. AT SIX TO PROVIDE
SHORT SERVICE SHORT TERM
SUSTAINABILITY THIS FUND WHICH
PROVIDES RESOURCES FOR BOATING
RELATED PROGRAMS AT THE
DIVISION OF BOATING AND
WATERWAYS STATE PARK IN ITS-
AND OTHER DEPARTMENTS TO FOR
INVASIVE SPECIES AND RELATED
EXPENDITURES- ASSOCIATE- THAT
THEY COLLECTED BASIS SPECIES
PREVENTION. THE PROPOSAL BEFORE
YOUR FLEXIBLE A BALANCED
APPROACH THAT REDUCES
APPROPRIATIONS SUSPENSE CERTAIN
TRANSFERS AND INCREASES THE
VESSEL REGISTRATION FEE FROM
TWENTY DOLLARS TO SEVENTY
DOLLARS ON A BIANNUAL BASIS.
THE REGISTRATION STARTED ON
EVEN HERE WITH GROUPS FROM TEN
TO THIRTY FIVE DOLLARS. SO THE
L. L. POINTS OUT THIS IS AN
INTERN WITH ROACH INTENDED TO
PROVIDE SHORT TERM SHORT TERM
SOLVENCY THE FUND WHILE LONGER
TERM SUSTAINABLE MEASURES ARE
EXPLORED. THE SPECIFICALLY THE
DEPARTMENT WILL CONSIDER MOVING
TO A TIERED BUSTLE REGISTRATION
FEE WILL BE BASED ON BUSTLING.
THIS WILL PROVIDE A MORE
EQUITABLE APPROACH FIFTY
RAISING. DISCUSSIONS ALSO
INCLUDE THE POSSIBILITY OF
MOVING SOME FEE COLLECTION
RESPONSIBILITIES THE NBA TO DB
W. REDUCE COST NOT A
FLEXIBILITY TO BE STRUCTURING.
EXPLORING FEES FOR NON
MOTORIZED VESSELS EXPANDING THE
QUALITIES HE REFUSED TO MORE
BROADLY COVER COSTS ASSOCIATE
WITH A. I. S. PROGRAM. BUT
AGAIN THE V. PROPOSAL BEFORE
YOU TODAY IS A FEW REYES FROM
TWENTY TO SEVENTY DOLLARS ON A
BIANNUAL BASIS. SO A LITTLE BIT
OF BACKGROUND BEFORE WE JUMP
INTO THE SPECIFICS OF THE
PROPOSAL. OVER THE PAST TEN
YEARS EXPENDITURES OF RESUME
YOU PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN FUNDED
AND SOME REVENUES FOR THE
HARBORS WATER PROPER BOND FUND
HAVE DECLINED. SPECIFICALLY R.
S. PROGRAM WHICH TREATS WATER
HYACINTH AND DOWNS THAT.
EXPENDITURES HAVE GROWN IN THAT
PROGRAM FROM SIX AND A HALF
MILLION. TWO THOUSAND EIGHT TO
FOUR POINT SIX MILLION IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THREE TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN. BUT IT ACTS
INITIATIVE DAVIS DAHLE
TRANSFERS AT AT THE COST OF TEN
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY. THESE
TRANSFERS FUND DEBT REPAYMENT
AND PROGRAMS FOR THE STATE
WATER PROJECT FACILITIES ARE SO
SHOULD WITH BOATING
RECREATIONAL ACTIVITIES- AS
WITH ALL STATE DEPARTMENTS DB
W. HAS- INCURRED AFFAIRS FAIR
AMOUNT OF RISING PLAY
COMPENSATION COSTS THE FUND
HIGHER WAGES RETIREMENT
BENEFITS AND HEALTH CARE COSTS.
IN TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN THERE
WAS A CLARIFICATION TO THE WAY
THE SCO TRANSFERS FUEL TAXES.
WHICH RESULTED IN A FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLAR ANNUAL REVENUE
LOSSES SO SHE WOULD. VOTING
FUEL TAXES TO HARVEST WATER
PRACTICAL IMPACT. ALSO IN TWO
THOUSAND FOUR PUBLIC BEACH
RESTORATION FUNDRAISERS WERE
INITIATED WHICH FUND FUTURE
OCEAN AND PHYSICAL BARRIER
PROTECTION FOR- ELIGIBLE
MUNICIPALITIES. THIS PROPOSAL
THE FARMERS MARKET AFTER
FALLING FENESTRATION FIFTY TWO
MILLION DOLLAR ANNUAL THAT
DEFICIT ON. AND WILL NOT HAVE
SUFFICIENT RESOURCES TO
CONTINUE A CURRENT SERVICE
LEVELS AGAIN WE SEEK A BALANCED
APPROACH TO SOLVING THAT
DEFICIT BY RAISING TWENTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS IN FEES REDUCE
APPROPRIATIONS BY APPROXIMATELY
FORTY MILLION. AND SEEKING
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
THUNDERBIRD TWO YEAR PERIOD.
WOULD ALSO SUSPEND SIX MILLION
DOLLARS IN ANNUAL PUBLICATION
RESTORATION FUNDRAISERS. WE
BELIEVE THIS IS A PERFECT
PRACTICAL MEASURE TO TAKE A
SHORT TERM THAT PRIORITIZES
KEEPING BUSTLE REGISTRATION
FEES LOW MAINTAINING SERVICE
LEVELS. AND LIMITING THE AMOUNT
OF GENERAL FUND REQUESTED. SO
SPECIFICALLY ON THE REDUCTIONS.
WERE PROPOSING FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN ELLERY-
APPROPRIATION REDUCTION THAT
PRIORITIZES OPERATIONS OF THE
HIGHEST NEEDS. AND RECOGNIZES
THE STORK LEVELS OF EXPENDITURE
INTERSTATE OPERATIONS LOCAL
SYSTEMS PROGRAMS. AND STATE
OPERATIONS WERE LOOKING AT A
TWO AND A HALF MILLION DOLLAR
REDUCTION IN THE CURRENT YEAR
AND IT TWO MILLION DOLLAR
REDUCTION IN THE BUDGET YEAR
FOR STATE OPERATIONS. THE
CURRENT YEAR- THAT TWO POINT
FOUR MILLION DOLLAR REDUCTION
WILL BE BALANCED THE
PROPORTIONAL DIVISION BUT IN
WATER WATERBODIES PROGRAMS AS
WELL. AS OTHER PROGRAMS FUNDED
BY HARBOR'S WATERFRONT PEOPLE
SPENT THE MAJORITY OF THE
CURRENT YEAR REDUCTION WOULD BE
BORNE BY. THE QUALICUM BASIS
SPECIES PROGRAM. THIS IS IN
LINE WITH PERCENT- IN THE
REDUCTION AT ALL STATE
DEPARTMENTS WILL TAKE BEGINNING
THE TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. IN
BUDGET YEAR. WE WILL DO A ONE
POINT NINE MILLION DOLLAR
REDUCTION TO AQUATIC INVASIVE
SPECIES PROGRAM. WELL THIS
PRODUCTION IT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT PROGRAM FOR
CALIFORNIANS WE DO BELIEVE THAT
THE MATERIAL IMPACT OF THIS
REDUCTION WILL BE SMALL- THIS
REDUCTION RECOGNIZES ORACLE
SAVINGS IN THIS PROGRAM AND
ALLOWS US TO PRIORITIZE
TREATMENT AREAS WITHIN THE
DELTA- WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT WE
CAN RECOGNIZE ADDITIONAL
REIMBURSEMENT FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER. RESOURCES
TO CONTINUE- TREATMENT LEVELS
ACROSS THE DELTA. THE MOBILE
SYSTEMS WERE LOOKING AT A
TWELVE MILLION DOLLAR
REDUCTION. TO THREE PROGRAMS
WITH THEM- THE DIVISION OF
BOATING AND WATERWAYS. FIVE AND
A HALF MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE MARINA
PROGRAM. THE REASON WE LOOKED
AT THIS PROGRAM AS IT'S BEEN
UNDER PRESCRIBE FOR SEVERAL
YEARS WE HAVE AN APPROPRIATION
OF ABOUT FIVE AND A HALF
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY FOR
THIS PROGRAM. YEAH IN THE PAST
COUPLE YEARS WE'VE- DONE VERY
MINIMAL ON THE LOAN WENT
INSIDE- WE'RE GOING TO EXPLORE
HOW MUCH DEMAND FOR THIS
PROGRAM EXISTS GOING FORWARD. I
WOULD BE REALIZE THAT IT'S A
VIBRANT SOURCE OF REVENUE FOR
THE FUND- CONSIDERING WE'RE
GOING TO GET YOU KNOW INTEREST
RATE REPAYMENT AS ALL AND ALSO
THE PRINCIPAL REPAID TO THE
FACT- WE'RE LOOKING AT A FIVE.
POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLAR
REDUCTION TO OUR BOAT LAUNCH
FACILITY GRANTS PROGRAM- THESE
GRANTS MADE TO QUALIFYING
PUBLICATIONS USED TO FIND
FACILITIES SUCH AS BUT ONE
TRANSPORTING FLOATS. UP PARKING
AREAS RESTROOMS. AND LYFT FOR
MOTORIZED AND NON MOTORIZED
BOATS. IN THIS PRODUCTION
REPRESENTS THE TRUE AVERAGE
SPEND OF THIS PROGRAM OVER THE
LAST FIVE YEARS WE THINK WE CAN
REDUCE THIS PROGRAM AND NOT SEE
MATERIAL IMPACT ON THE AMOUNT
OF GRANTS THAT WERE ACTUALLY
PROVIDING FOR THIS PROGRAM- AND
THEN FINALLY WE'RE LOOKING AT A
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLAR REDUCTION TO. THE
QUALITY ZERO MUSSEL INFESTATION
GRANT PROGRAMS. WHICH PROVIDE
SUPPORT WHICH PROVIDES
PREVENTATIVE PLANS AND SUPPORT.
FOR A CALIFORNIA'S RESERVOIRS
AGAINST MUSSEL INFESTATION-
AGAIN THIS THIS IS A TRUE UP
WITH OUR- HISTORICAL CENTER
LEVEL SO WE'RE REDUCING
APPROPRIATIONS TO MATCH. ALL
KNOW THAT THIS THIS PROPOSAL
DOES NOT IMPACT THE FINANCIAL
AID PROGRAM THIS IS A PROGRAM
THAT PROVIDES GRANTS TO LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT. BUT IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT PERSONNEL SEARCH
AND RESCUE OPERATIONS AND OTHER
MARINE PATROL PROGRAMS- WE'RE
LOOKING AT TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE THAT WOULD CAP THIS
PROGRAM AT THE CURRENT AMOUNT.
STEP TWO CURRENTLY REQUIRES
THAT HALF OF THE REVENUE
RECEIVED BY HER IS MORE
PRACTICAL THAN BE SPENT ON THE
FINANCIAL AID PROGRAM. SO
ABSENT THE CHANGED THEIR ANY
FEAR RACISM ROAD BY ADDITIONAL
AMOUNT THAT HAS TO GO OUT
FINANCIALLY PROGRAM. CONTINUING
ON THE REDUCTION SIDE OF THE
LEDGER- WE'RE LOOKING AT A
SUSPENSION OF PUBLIC BEACH
RESTORATION FUND FOR ANSWERS.
THESE TRANSFERS WERE INITIATED
IN TWO THOUSAND FOUR AND FUN
BEACH REPLENISHMENT GRAPHS AS
WELL AS PHYSICAL BARRIERS SUCH
AS SEAWALLS. ON AVERAGE WE
TRANSFER ABOUT FORTY SEVEN
MILLION TO THE BOAT BEACH
RESTORATION FINANCIALLY. WE ARE
PROPOSING SUSPENDING THIS
TRANSFERENCE ON ALTERNATIVE
FUNDS WHICH CAN BE A THAT
IDENTIFIED. WELL WE THINK
THERE'S A BIG SENSE IS
APPROPRIATE FOR THE PERSON
WATER PROPERTY BOND FUND IN OUR
VIEW IT DOES NOT CONVERT DIRECT
BENEFIT UPON VOTERS SOME OF THE
OTHER PROGRAMS THAT WE PROPOSE
FOR. A RETENTION. AND THEN
FINALLY THE FEE INCREASE. WE'RE
LOOKING AT- A TWENTY FIVE
DOLLAR PER YEAR OR FIFTY DOLLAR
BI ANNUAL RENEWAL INCREASE FOR
VESSEL REGISTRATION. THE
CURRENT FEE ON A BIANNUAL BASIS
IS TWENTY DOLLARS THIS PROPOSAL
WOULD MAKE IT SEVENTY DOLLARS.
ALL NOTE THAT THE LAST INCREASE
WE HAVE FOR OUR VESSEL
REGISTRATION FEE WAS IN TWO
THOUSAND FIVE ONLY INCREASED
FROM TEN TO TWENTY ON A
BIANNUAL BASIS. CURRENTLY
CALIFORNIA'S VESSEL
REGISTRATION FEE IS THE LOWEST
IN THE NATION. WITH THIS
PROPOSAL WE WOULD BE SIX LOS IN
THE NATION SO IT'S STILL AN
EXTREMELY- AFFORDABLE FEE- THE
DM B. IN ORDER TO DISAPPEAR
THERE'S A THREE POINT TWO FIVE
MILLION DOLLAR COST TO THE DMV
FOR SYSTEM UPGRADES. WE EXPECT
TO HAVE- THE SYSTEM UPGRADES IN
PLACE TO BE RENEWALS BY
DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. AND WITH THAT I
WILL OPEN UP FOR QUESTIONS.
BEFORE WE HEAR TO. HEAR FROM
THE L. A. O. WHO- GENERALLY
AGREES WITH THE GOVERNMENT'S OF
PACKAGE THEY DO DISAGREE ON THE
BEACH RESTORATION PROGRAM
BECAUSE OF THE NEXUS THEY THINK
THAT. BEACH GOERS AND LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND HOMEOWNERS
WOULD BE A BETTER SOURCE TO PAY
FOR THAT THAT SOURCE OF THAT
FEE RATHER THAN THE BOATERS
AND- YOUR DEPARTMENT. SEEMS TO
THINK DIFFERENTLY AND PARKS
WISE THAT. WE ACTUALLY DID AN
ANALYSIS A FEW YEARS AGO FOR A
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT THAT WAS
PROVIDED TO ALEJO. WE DID FIND
THAT THERE WAS A NEXUS ALBEIT
NOT OF SUPER STRONG NEXUS BUT-
THERE IS A CORRELATION BETWEEN
MARINA BOTH ACTIVITIES AND BE A
GENERATION OF FANS IN THOSE
ARENAS- MOST OF THESE PROGRAMS
THAT COME BACK EVERY PLACE TO
STAND SO. THERE IS AN ENTIRE
BECAUSE BY VOTERS- IN MARINAS
OUT THE THIS PROGRAM SEEKS TO.
MITIGATE THOSE IMPACTS AND THEN
REPLENISH THE SPEECHES SO
THAT'S THAT'S THE NEXUS THAT WE
DRAW THERE'S MORE INFORMATION
AVAILABLE. THE SUPPLEMENTAL
REPORT WHICH WE CAN. CERTAINLY
SURE THAT MANY. MICEX WHAT
YOU'RE WHAT THE- GOOD MORNING.
EARLY MORNING MEMBERS NICE TO
SEE YOU OUT- YES RETAILERS WITH
THE L. A. O. SO OVERALL WE
THINK THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
APPROACH HAS A LOT ABOUT IT
THAT'S REASONABLE IT ADDRESSES
THIS PROBLEM THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED IN THIS YEAR AND LESS
YOU WANT TO HAVE MAJOR
PROGRAMMATIC IMPACTS IT'S
BALANCED IT HAS RAM REVENUE
INCREASES AND EXPENDITURE
REDUCTIONS WE THINK RAISING
FEES IS REASONABLE BECAUSE THEY
HAVEN'T BEEN RAISED IN SO LONG
AND THE EXPENDITURE REDUCTIONS
ARE PRETTY WELL TARGETED TO
REALLY MINIMIZE PROGRAMMATIC
IMPACTS. I THINK THE MAIN ISSUE
IS THAT IT'S NOT PERMANENT IT
RELIES ON SHORT TERM GENERAL
FUND AND- THEN THEY WILL. HAVE
TO COME BACK BEFORE YOU IN A
FEW YEARS LOOKING AT ADDITIONAL
CHANGES PROBABLY INVOLVING
ADDITIONAL FEE INCREASES SO
THAT COULD BE DIFFICULT FOR
STAKEHOLDERS AND FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO REVISIT FEES
AGAIN IN JUST A COUPLE OF YEARS
SO I THINK ONE OF OUR
SUGGESTIONS TO YOU IS TO
CONSIDER WHETHER YOU MIGHT WANT
TO PURSUE A MORE PERMANENT
SOLUTION THIS YEAR SO OBVIOUSLY
THE MOST PERMANENT SOLUTION
WOULD BE TO REALLY ADOPT. A
PACKAGE OF- GOING PERMANENT
EXPENDITURE REDUCTIONS AND FEE
INCREASES THAT- WOULD BE
SUSTAINABLE BUT IT IS
COMPLICATED- AS MR SHOPS MEANT
NOTED AND ESPECIALLY IF YOU
WANT TO LOOK AT RESTRUCTURING
THE FEES AND WHO'S PAYING IF
NON MOTORIZED BOTH PAIRS ME-
BEGIN TO BE CHARGED AS WELL SO
TO THE DEGREE THAT THAT IS TOO
DIFFICULT TO DEVELOP THAT KIND
OF SOPHISTICATED PACKAGE OVER
THE NEXT FEW MONTHS ANOTHER
OPTION YOU COULD CONSIDER IS
ADOPTING THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL BUT ALSO ADOPTING A
PACKAGE OF TRIGGER- INCREASES
AND POTENTIALLY EXPENDITURE
REDUCTIONS AS WELL. THAT WOULD
TAKE A FACT IN TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR WHEN THE IN MINISTRATION
IS M. ESTIMATING THAT THE THEIR
THEIR SOLUTION WOULD KIND OF
RUN OUT AND THEN FIND WOULD
EXPERIENCE A SHORTFALL AGAIN
AND NOW WE TO HAVE KIND OF A
BACKSTOP YOU WOULD KNOW THAT
YOU HAD A PERMANENT SOLUTION IN
PLACE. BUT IT WOULD ALSO GIVE
SOME IN TIME FOR THE ADMIN. OF
STATE CALLED TO WORK OVER THE
COUPLE OF YEARS DEVELOP AN
ALTERNATIVE PERMANENT SOLUTION-
THAT MAYBE THEY COULD BRING
BEFORE YOU AND- MADE MAYBE MORE
SATISFACTORY TO ALL PARTIES AND
THEN YOU COULD ADOPT THAT BUT
AT LEAST YOU WOULD HAVE SOME
CONFIDENCE. THAT YOU HAD A
PERMANENT SOLUTION IN PLACE TO
THE DEGREE- THAT THAT THAT
OTHER TYPE OF SOLUTION WOULDN'T
DEVELOP AND YOU WOULDN'T BE
KIND OF BACK IN THE EXACT SAME
PLACE YOU ARE NOW IN A FEW
YEARS. WHAT WOULD YOU SAY TO
PEOPLE THAT MAKE THE
OBSERVATION THAT. ALL BOATS ARE
NOT CREATED EQUAL. YOU KNOW
THEY HAVE IT WITH A CAR YEAH I
GOT A BEAUTIFUL TWO THOUSAND
THREE CHRYSLER TOWN AND
COUNTRY. I DON'T PAY A FEE THAT
A BRAND NEW TESLA WOULD PAY
WHAT WHAT WHAT IS WRONG IN THE
WORLD THE VOTING OF HAVING SOME
SORT OF. ATTENTION TO THE VALUE
OF THE OF THE BOAT. WHEN YOU
WERE IF WE'RE GOING TO. GIVE
DMB THREE POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS TO CHANGE YOUR SYSTEM
WHY WOULD WE NOT. REALLY CHANGE
THE SYSTEM GET SOME MONEY OUT
OF THAT. YEAH I AM SURE THE
DEPARTMENT'S GOT MORE
INFORMATION ON ON THIS IS A BET
I THINK ONE OF THE
POSSIBILITIES AS MISTER CHAPMAN
NOTED THAT THEY'RE CONSIDERING
I THINK IS LOOKING AT THAT
LENGTH OF THE BOAT. AS KIND OF
A PROXY FOR THE VALUE- SO I
THINK I THINK YOU DO HAVE
OPTIONS TO LOOK AT MADAME MORE
TIERED STRUCTURE BUT I'LL DEFER
TO MISTER LAST MONTH. RIGHT SO
WE ARE LOOKING AT A VESSEL.
BEARD BASED- REGISTRATION
SYSTEM. UNFORTUNATELY GETTING
THE SYSTEM. OF THAT TYPE IN
PLACE- ON THE SAME TIMELINE
THAT THIS FUND IS GOING TO NEED
ADDITIONAL REVENUES IT IS NOT
FEASIBLE AT THIS TIME BUT IT IS
SOMETHING WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON
IT. I'M LOOKING AT. PARKING TO
DMB ABOUT THE SYSTEM CHANGES
THAT WOULD BE REQUIRED. AS I'M
SURE YOU'RE FAMILIAR TìM BE
USED SYSTEM IS- IN THE PROCESS
OF BEING UPGRADED AND- AND
RECONFIGURED SO WE'D LIKE TO
FIT IN WITH THOSE TIME LINES
ON. ON TV SYSTEM RE
CONFIGURATIONS AND THEN
HOPEFULLY SHOULD- FOR A FUTURE
CHANGE THAT SYSTEM THAT WOULD
ACCOMMODATE- VESSELS OF A
DIFFERENT WAY. IT JUST SEEMS TO
ME THERE'S YOU KNOW THERE'S
LOTS OF STATE CINNAMON.
MINNESOTA THEY BOAST THAT THEY
HAVE TEN THOUSAND LAKES AND
THEN YOU GOT. MASSACHUSETTS
STEVE GODDARD S. AND RHODE
ISLAND THEY HAVE BIG BUILDING-
COMMUNITIES THERE MUST BE
SOMETHING. OFF THE SHELF THAT
WERE PEOPLE HAVE. HAVE LOOKED
AT THIS. WE HAVE. QUESTIONS
SENATE MCGUIRE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH RESEARCH- YOU KNOW THAT WE
HAVE TIME CONSTRAINTS OF THE
VERY QUICK- ON THE QUESTIONS-
DO YOU WANT TO SAY THINK YOU.
TO- MISFIT THAT WILL FOR HIS
PRESENTATION HERE TODAY A
COUPLE THINGS NUMBER ONE ON THE
BOAT FEE INCREASES 2210050%
INCREASE. IN FIRST IN MANY
YEARS ONE I WOULD LIKE TO BE TO
GET YOUR THOUGHTS ON INDEXING
SO WE'RE NOT HERE HAVING TO BE
ABLE TO ADVANCE SUCH A LARGE
POTENTIAL INCREASE. SECOND
PIECES WHERE THE CHAIR WAS
GOING NOW THIS IS SOMETHING YOU
CAN BE LOOKING AT LONGER TRM
BUT AT LOOKING AT WHAT THE
CHAIR SAID IN A VERY JEALOUS IS
TWO THOUSAND THREE CHRYSLER-
BUT- BY TAKING A LOOK AT- VLF
MODEL SO. THOSE WHO ARE
RECREATIONAL BOATERS OUT
FISHING IN A SMALL BOAT AREN'T
PAYING NEARLY AS MUCH AS THOSE-
SO. IF YOU WANNA TALK ABOUT
BOTH THE 22% INCREASE POTENTIAL
INDEXING. AND HOW FAR AWAY DO
YOU THINK YOU REALLY ARE.
RELATED TO IMPLEMENTING SOME
TYPE OF. VLF MODEL FOR VOTE- SO
ALTERED THE INDEXING PERSON I
THINK THAT'S- A LAUDABLE
APPROACH TO SOLVING THE ISSUE
BUT I THINK. IT DOES LIMIT US
IN THE NUMBER OF OPTIONS WE
COULD COME BACK TO THIS
COMMITTEE WITH. IF GIVEN SOME
TIME TO ENGAGE OUR STAKEHOLDERS
AND REALLY GET THEIR FEEDBACK.
ON WHAT SYSTEM WORKS BEST FOR
THAT SO. IF WE END ACCESS MY
ASSUMPTION IS THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT ANOTHER INCREASE TO
THE VESSEL REGISTRATION B. AS
IS- IF WE CAN COME BACK WHICH I
UNDERSTAND IS NOT. THE BEST
APPROACH FOR A FEW REYES. IT
WOULD GIVE US SOME TIME TO GET
TO WORK WITH THE BOATING
COMMUNITY UNDERSTANDS. ON A
VESSEL TIERED REGISTRATION
SYSTEM WHAT MAKES SENSE FOR
THEM. WHAT MAKES SENSE FOR NON
MOTORIZED BOATERS WHAT MAKES
SENSE FOR CARDIGAN BASIS
SPECIES COSTS. WE CAN HAVE THAT
COMPREHENSIVE DISCUSSION AND
THEN I THINK COME BACK WITH A
MORE EQUITABLE SOLUTION FOR THE
LONG TERM- HOWEVER YOU KNOW
THERE IS THERE'S A BENEFIT TO
INDUCTION AS WELL I'M HAVING AN
AUTOMATIC TRIGGER INSTEAD SHE
TO DO THAT. BUT IT DOES
ALLEVIATE A LOT OF THIS THE
STRESS OF. HAVING TO POSE
ADDITIONAL FEES- ON THE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY PERCENT- YOU
KNOW. WHEN WE LOOK AT YOU KNOW
ON A PERCENTAGE BASIS THAT IS.
IT'S A HIGH NUMBER WE
UNDERSTAND THAT BUT I. THINK I
MENTIONED WHAT I- WHAT I NOTED
IN MY EARLIER TESTIMONY IS
THAT. EARLY CALIFORNIA'S LOS
NATION AT TEN DOLLARS. WE'RE
GOING TO THIRTY FIVE DOLLARS
AND THAT'S GONNA BE THE SIX LOS
IN THE NATION SO. THIRDLY WE
OFFER A LOT OF PROGRAMS OR
DIVISION OF LIVING WATER WAYS-
AND THAT FEE IS STILL.
EXTREMELY LOW- SO WE'VE GOT
SOME GENERAL FUND IN THIS
PACKAGE TO ALLEVIATE THE AMOUNT
OF THE FEE INCREASE WE'RE
LOOKING AT REDUCTIONS WERE
BOUNCING. PRIORITY FOR US IS TO
KEEP THAT BE AS LOW AS
POSSIBLE- HOWEVER. WITH ANY
TIME YOU SAW IN A STRUCTURAL
DEFICIENCY IN A FUNDS YOU'VE
YOU'VE ONLY GOT A LIMITED
NUMBER ABOUT COMES WITH WITH
THE MATH TO GET THERE SO- AND
THEN IF YOU CAN I THINK THERE
WAS A THIRD QUESTION BUT I'M-
BUT I'M NOT RECALLING WHAT.
WITHOUT WHAT'S I'M GOOD I KNOW
THAT WERE LIMITED IN TIME BUT I
APPRECIATE THAT MY LAST PIECE
IS TWENTY SECONDS IS. I
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU WANT TO BE
A CHECK ON THE BOATING
COMMUNITY AND ANYTIME WE SEE
THESE LARGE- INCREASES AT THE
CONSISTENCY IS GOING TO BE THE
BEST WAY TO APPROACH. WHEN IT
COMES THE FEES BUT I REALLY
APPRECIATE MISTRETTA IN THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION. A CENTER TOLLEY.
SO BUT. SO- I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT. I GUESS HOW DO WE KNOW
THAT THE BOATS ARE ACTUALLY
CAUSING THE EROSION AND WE'RE
NOT JUST HAVING OTHER TYPES OF
THE RELIGION THAT NOW WE'RE
GONNA SETTLE. A BOAT OWNERS
WITH. SO ON THE POLE BEACH
RESTORATION FUND TRANSFERS.
THIS PROPOSAL RECOMMENDS
SUSPENDING MOST TRANSFERS- I
THINK FOR SOME REASON HAS THAT
BEEN POINTED OUT TO DATE WHICH
IS. THAT NEXUS BETWEEN BEACH
EROSION. AND BOATERS IS NOT AS
STRONG WERE RELEVANT TO THE
PROGRAMS THAT VOTERS WANT AS
PUTTING THE NEW BOTH THE LAUNCH
FACILITY- AT A RESERVOIR SO.
WE'VE DONE THIS PROPOSAL WE
REALLY LOOKED AT WATER WHAT ARE
THE PROGRAMS THAT WE DELIVER
THROUGH TV W. TO HELP THE
STRONGEST CORRELATION WITH
VOTERS IF WE'RE GOING TO RAISE
THE FEE. LET'S MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE LOOKING AT ALL THE
PROGRAMS BALLISTICALLY. AND
RAISING FEES FOR THE PROGRAMS
THAT THAT THAT VOTERS REALLY
BENEFIT FROM SO. WALL THERE'S A-
THE NEXUS TO THE TO. GREENERY
AND VOTING- I BELIEVE NOT VOTE
RATE PLAN WITH INITIATED TO THE
FOUR. IT WAS. ABOUT FINDING A
PROGRAM WITHOUT NECESSARILY A
FUNDING SOURCE PERSONAL
WATERCRAFT WAS A FIND THAT
COULD DO. BUT THOSE REVENUE
TRANSFERS AND WAS DEEMED
APPROPRIATE- BUT BUT IN THIS
PROPOSAL WE DO ACTUALLY
RECOMMEND SUSPENDING. THE
TRANSFER STOOD UP FOR THOSE
REASONS. OKAY WE'LL TAKE WE'RE
GOING TO KEEP THE MATTER OPEN
AND WE'RE GONNA COME BACK THE
OTHER THING THAT THE STAFF
WOULD LIKE IS ON THE INVASIVE
SPECIES- PROGRAMS AND ALL THAT
IF WE CAN GET SOME INFORMATION
ON. THE CONTRIBUTION TO
COMMERCIAL. LICENSE VOTERS MAKE
THEM AND WE GET THIS IDEA THAT
THAT FOREIGN BOATS ARE COMING
IN- THEY'RE TALKING AND THEY'RE
BRINGING AN INVASIVE SPECIES
WHAT ARE THE FEES THAT THEY PAY
SO THIS THE COMMITTEE HAS A
BETTER. IDEA OF A- HOW TO.
DIVIDE THAT UP. AND WITH THAT
WE WILL HOLD THE MATTER THIS IS
SIXTEEN LET'S GO TO ISSUE
NUMBER SEVENTEEN THIS IS THE
DEPARTMENT OF FORESTRY. AND
FIRE PROTECTION WILL BE
EMPHASIZING THE DEPARTMENT OF
FORESTRY TODAY THESE ARE
CAPITAL OUTLAY- AND- LET'S HEAR
FROM. DIRECTOR PORTER GOOD
MORNING. GOOD MORNING HER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS AND THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY IN
FRONT OF YOU- TODAY AGAIN MY
NAME IS TOM PORTER I'M THE
STATE FORESTER FOR. THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND- THE DIRECTOR
OF DEPARTMENT OF. FORESTRY AND
FIRE PROTECTION AND I JUST
WANTED TO OPEN UP VERY QUICKLY
KNOWING THAT THEY'RE SHORT ON
TIME WE'RE SHORT ON TIME WITH
JUST KIND OF THAT- OVERVIEW
TWENTY TWENTY IT WAS A FIRE
YEAR- LIKE NO OTHER FOR US AND
WE TRULY HAVE BEEN SEEING AN
INCREASE OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
DECADES. TIME AFTER TIME OF
MORE AND MORE OF THESE TYPES OF
A LARGE AND DAMAGING- SEASONS
AND YEARS FOUR HUNDRED OR FOUR
MILLION TWO HUNDRED FOUR
MILLION TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
ACRES PLUS A BURNED. NINETY
THREE HUNDRED STRUCTURES
DESTROYED. AND THIRTY TWO
INDIVIDUALS LOST THEIR LIVES.
THREE OF THOSE- WERE A VERY
MERGING SEA RESPONDENTS AND SIX
OF THE TWENTY LARGEST FIRES IN
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY WE'RE ALL
BURNING- AT THE SAME TIME. WELL
LAST SEASON DURING THE SIEGE
THE AUGUST COMPLEX BEING A
MILLION ACRES IN AND OF ITSELF.
A AND COVERING- PARTS OF SIX
DIFFERENT COUNTIES AT THE SAME
TIME. AMAZING YEAR- AND AT
TIMES WE HAD UPWARDS OF
NINETEEN THOUSAND FIREFIGHTERS
ARE ON THE LINE OR ASSIGNS TO
FIRES AT ALL AT ONCE. THIS IS
TAKING A MAJOR TOLL ON OUR
RESOURCES OF THE FIREFIGHTERS
FOR SURE- BUT ALSO THE LANDS
THAT WE PROTECT AND THE- THE
FACILITIES AND OTHER OF
FIREFIGHTING APPARATUS THAT WE
USED TO FIGHT THESE FIRES. WELL
FIRE IS A NATURAL PART OF OUR
ENVIRONMENT AND WE NEED TO SEE
MORE PRESCRIBED FIRE ON THE
GROUND OF THESE FIRES ARE BEING
MULTIPLIED EXPONENTIALLY BY
CLIMATE CHANGE AND THE- EXTREME
WEATHER EVENTS WERE HAVING
WHETHER IT'S HEAT DOMES AND
DROUGHTS. OR ATMOSPHERIC RIVERS
OF THINGS ARE NOT LIKE THEY
WERE DECADES AGO AND WE NEED TO
CONTINUE OUR INVESTMENT AND
MOVING FORWARD. AS THE
GOVERNOR'S APPROACH OF
PROPOSING TO DO SO- JUST TO
HIGHLIGHT A COUPLE OF THINGS
THAT WERE BUILDING ON- IN THIS
PROPOSED BUDGET- IT IS OF GOING
TO FACILITATE MOVING FORWARD
WITH A SOME OF THE BIGGER
INVESTMENTS THAT WE'VE BEEN
MAKING OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS IN THE FORM OF- BLACKHAWK
STYLE A HELICOPTER REPLACEMENT
OF OUR OUR- TRIED AND TRUE IF
YOU EASE- WE HAVE TO THAT WORKS
IN THE- FIRES LAST YEAR- AND
WE'RE WORKING TOWARDS GETTING
THE REST OF THOSE SHIPS- IN
PLACE THIS YEAR AND MAX
REPORTER I GOT IT. EVIDENTLY
WE'RE NOT GETTING YOU ON THE
SCREEN CAN YOU CLICK ON THE
VIDEO ABSOLUTELY HIGHER WELL
THERE ARE THERE I AM SORRY
ABOUT THAT OKAY THAT'S EMIGRATE
AND I ALSO FORGOT TO NOTE ON
PAGE TWENTY ONE OF OUR STAFF
REPORT WE TALK OF BOTH PAYS YOU
GO IN BONDS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
WHEN TIME COMES TO FUND THE
PROJECTS NOT TO REJECT THAT'S A
TYPO JUST SO NOBODY THINKS OF
HER WE'RE WE'RE LOOKING AT
DIFFERENTLY BUT GO AHEAD.
THAT'S OUR STAFF REPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU AT THE END MUCH
APOLOGIES BOARD FOR- MISSING
THE CAMERA THERE- SO JUST JUST
A FINISHING UP WITH THIS- SEE
ONE THIRTIES ARE COMING BUT
IT'S GONNA TAKE ANOTHER COUPLE
OF YEARS TO DEPLOY THEM- WE DID
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
SUPPORTING THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL AND THE THIRTEEN NEW
YEAR ROUND ENGINES LAST YEAR WE
HAVE ALL OF THOSE IN PLACE- AND
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK TO
BALANCE THE RESOURCES NEEDED
FOR. TODAY AND THE FUTURE WITH
THIS- THE FIRST PIECE THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR TODAY IS-
RELATED TO CAPITAL OUTLAY
PROJECTS AND ON AT THIS TIME
I'M GOING TO PASS THE- MY AGE
TO AGE DEPUTY DIRECTOR TONY
FABBRO. AND HE WILL COVER THOSE
MORE SPACE THE- AND WILL OPEN
FOR QUESTIONS. YEAH DEPUTY FOR
YOU'VE ALL HEARD FROM THE L.
REPORT OF SOME HAVE BEING GIVEN
THE CAN. SOME IDEA OF
PRIORITIES AND HOW THIS MOSAIC
GOES TOGETHER WE'VE GOT SOME
NEW PROJECTS WE GET SMALL
PROJECTS BUT THE STORE THE
QUICK WITH. THE DECISIONS THAT
YOU GUYS MAY TRY TO GIVE US A
LITTLE- IDEA OF WHY WE'RE
CHOOSING THE REASON WHY THEY'RE
GETTING A PRIORITY AND I WILL
NOTE THAT CENTER STERN IS WITH
US CENTER STERN. FIFTY DO YOU
HAVE STAFF WITH YOU THAT YOU
CAN IF YOU DO CAN YOU HAVE THEM
IDENTIFY THEM OR CAN YOU
IDENTIFY THEM FOR US. IT'S JUST
ME. OKAY EXCELLENT THANK YOU
PLEASE GO AHEAD DEPUTY. THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS- YEAH TWENTY FAVORITE
W. DIRECTOR OF MANAGEMENT
SERVICES. THE PROPOSAL TODAY
THAT'S BEFORE YOU ENCOMPASSES
TWENTY. CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS
TOTALING APPROXIMATELY FIFTY
FIVE POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS.
IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO- CALPERS INVENTORY
OF OVER FIVE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
FACILITIES INCLUDES TWO HUNDRED
AND THIRTY FOUR FIRE STATIONS
TWELVE AIR ATTACK USES. TEN
HELLO TAX BASES THIRTY NINE
CONSERVATION CAMPS. THREE'S
CONSERVATION'S CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS- FIRE
CENTERS HUNDRED AND TWELVE
COMMUNICATION FACILITIES
SIXTEEN ADMINISTRATIVE
HEADQUARTERS TWENTY ONE UNIT
HEADQUARTERS EIGHT STATE
FORESTS A NURSERY TO TRAINING
CENTERS IN OVER A HUNDRED OTHER
MISCELLANEOUS DISABILITIES THAT
SUPPORT THE DEPARTMENT- OF
THESE FACILITIES 63%
APPROXIMATELY 63% WERE
CONSTRUCTED PRIOR TO NINETEEN
SIXTY. WITH 80% CONSTRUCTED
PRIOR TO NINETEEN SEVENTY IN
THE AVERAGE AGE OF CALIFORNIA
FACILITIES EXCEEDS FORTY EIGHT
YEARS. THE PROJECT BEFORE YOU
TODAY CONSIST OF A NUMBER OF
FACILITY RELOCATIONS.
PLACEMENTS AND INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENTS TO FIRE STATIONS
CONSERVATION CAMP TELETECH
BASES AIR ATTACK BASES IN UNIT
HEADQUARTERS- THESE PROJECTS
REFLECT THE TOP PRIORITIES OF
THE OF CALPERS FIVE YEAR
INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN. AND WE
WORK CLOSELY WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO BUILD A SOLID
FINANCIAL PLAN TO ENSURE THAT
IT WILL BE ABLE TO SEE THESE
PROJECTS THROUGH TO COMPLETION-
IT REATIVE TO PRIORITIES
PRIORITIZATION. OF THE
DEPARTMENT. WE WORK WITH- MIGHT
MY PROGRAMS WORK WITH THE-
REGIONS WHERE THESE FACILITIES
ARE PRIMARILY LOCATED. TO
IDENTIFY WHAT WHAT THEIR
PRIORITIES ARE IN AS WE BUILD
THE FIVE YEAR PLAN AND THAT'S A
PLAN THAT WE ARE LOOKING AT ON
AN ANNUAL BASIS AND UPDATING AS
WE NEED TO AS WE NEED TO- BUT
WORKING THROUGH- THAT THE
BACKLOG OF PROJECTS THAT WE
THAT WE HAVE. WE ESSENTIALLY
USE FOR- CATEGORIES WERE
PRIORITIZING PROJECTS- THE
FIRST CATEGORY IS. CONTINUATION
OF PROJECTS RELATED TO HIGHLY
STRATEGIC EMERGENCY SERVICES
INCLUDING- THE CONTINUATION OR
COMPLETION OF PREVIOUSLY
AUTHORIZED PROJECTS SUCH AS AIR
TECH BASIS TELETECH BASES AN
EMERGENCY COMMAND CENTERS.
CATEGORY TWO FOCUSES ON LEASE
TERMINATION WHERE PROJECTS I AM
IN THAT CATEGORY INCLUDE
ACQUISITION A RELOCATION OF
EXISTING EMERGENCY RESPONSE
FACILITIES WITH A HIGH RISK OF
LEASE TERMINATION OR LOSS OF
SERVICE TO THE STATE. OUR THIRD
CATEGORY FOCUSES ON EMERGENCY
SERVICES AND EMERGENCY RESPONSE
FACILITIES- IN THIS CATEGORY
PROJECTS INCLUDE HIGHLY
STRATEGIC INFRASTRUCTURE SUCH
AS NEW AIR ATTACK BASES
TELETECH BASES OR EMERGENCY
COMMAND CENTER PROJECTS. OR THE
CONTINUATION- INDOOR COMPLETION
OF PREVIOUSLY AUTHORIZED FIRE
STATION PROJECTS IN AND AS WELL
AS NEW FIRE STATION PROJECTS.
AND THEN OUR FOURTH CATEGORY
FOCUSES ON OPERATIONAL
READINESS SO THE PROJECTS IN
THIS CATEGORY INCLUDE
ADMINISTRATIVE AND TRAINING
FACILITIES. AUTOMOTIVE SHOPS
AND OTHER- OTHER ACQUISITIONS
ARE PROJECTS OF THAT NATURE SO-
WE ARE FOCUSED PRIMARILY ON ON
TRYING TO- INSURE THAT OUR
EMERGENCY RESPONSE FACILITIES
ARE. ABLE TO YOU KNOW PROVIDE
THE APPROPRIATE SETTING FOR OUR
OUR STAFF TO RESPOND AND
WORKING EFFICIENTLY AND THAT
AND THAT WAY SO THAT'S A LITTLE
BIT ON OUR PRIORITY PRIORITIES-
I'M HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS
THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE ON SPECIFIC
PROJECTS AND I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. DELEO FROM. THE
MISTER BROWN. YOUR COMMENTS YES
GOOD MORNING MEDICARE MEMBERS
BRIAN BROWN WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
SO YES WE AS ANY NOTED MISTER
CHAIR WE DID RECOMMEND THAT YOU
ENGAGE WITH THE ADMINISTRATION
ON THE THIS PACKAGE OF
PROPOSALS- OUR CONCERN IS NOT
SO MUCH WITH ANY OF THE
INDIVIDUAL PROPOSALS AND IN
FACT WE THOUGHT THEY ALL EACH
ONE OF THE SPECIFIC CAPITAL
OUTLAY PROPOSALS ARE ONES THAT
ARE REASONABLE GIVEN THE AGE OF
THE FACILITIES MOST OF THEM ARE
SIXTY OR MORE YEARS OLD- AND
HAVE OTHER OPERATIONAL
CHALLENGES- DIDN'T THE REASON
FOR OUR- CON IT WAS REALLY
BECAUSE OF THE- LONGER TERM
COST- THE- THE OUT YOUR COST OF
THESE PROJECTS WHILE THE-
PROPOSAL- INCLUDED TOTAL FIFTY
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS. FROM THE
GENERAL FUND IN THE BUDGET YEAR
THAT'S MOSTLY FOR PLANNING AN
ACQUISITION AND OF COURSE- THE
CONSTRUCTION PHASE OF EACH OF
THESE PROJECTS IS THE MORE
EXPENSIVE COMPONENT AND THOSE
WILL BE IN OUT YEARS AND
CURRENT ESTIMATES ARE THAT
TOTAL. COSTS FOR THESE PROJECTS
IS GONNA BE OVER HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS SIX HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR
MILLION. ON AT LEAST ON CURRENT
ESTIMATES AND- NORMALLY WE
WOULD THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
AND WE DO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO. MAINTAIN AND REPLACE OLDER
FACILITIES BUT THE CHALLENGE
THAT YOU FACE IS BOTH OUR
OFFICE AND DEPARTMENT FINANCES
ARE. PROJECTING OUT YOUR BUDGET
DEFICITS IN THE GENERAL FUND
AND SO WE THINK IT'S SIMPLY
IMPORTANT THAT WITH- MAGNITUDE.
OF MAGNITUDE OF IMPORTANT
ENSURE THAT THE OUT YOUR COST
FOR ONE TO STAY IN YOUR LONGER
TERM GENERAL FUND PLAN. SEE MR
FAVREAU I'M I KNOW THE PART OF
THE- AFTER THE CONSTRUCTION A
LOT OF THESE PROJECTS INCLUDE
DEMOLITION AND I KNOW THEY DID
THE EVE YOU'VE GIVEN US ARE
THREE CATEGORIES ON ON THIS
STRATEGIC FIREFIGHTING BUT I
WANT TO FLIP OVER TO THE
FORESTRY SIDE ANY IDEA THAT
THAT. WE'RE LOOKING TO GET MORE
FORSTER'S UP ENOUGH UP IN THE
AREA ARE ANY OF THESE
FACILITIES POSSIBLE TO BE
RETROFITTED OR PROVIDE SOME
SORT OF SERVICES THAT THE THAT
THE FORESTERS WOULD BE EITHER
NOT FOR OUR EMERGENCY
FACILITIES FOR YOU KNOW A
HELIPAD AND ALL THAT THE KISS
OTHER STRUCTURES BECAUSE WE'VE
LOOKED AT THE YOU'VE GOT SOME
PROJECTS WHERE WE HAVE. THE
FORMER INCARCERATED WE'RE GOING
TO CONVERT IT TO A USE IN THE
CCC'S GOT SOME OTHERS THERE'S
JUST A MULTI USE FOR STATE. FOR
THIS- THAT. THE I GUESS THE-
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT PORTION
OF YOUR WORK. SO WE WOULD
OBVIOUSLY IF THERE'S A
POSSIBILITY OF THE ARE YOU
TALKING ABOUT LIKE READ
REPURPOSE SAYING A DISABILITY
THAT WE WOULD CORRECTIVE LEAVE-
YEAH I MEAN I BELIEVE WE COULD
LOOK AT THOSE THOSE FACILITIES
IF WE ARE LEAVING A- THAT-
WHETHER THAT FACILITY MIGHT
WORK- IT IT DOES DEPEND ON A
NUMBER OF FACTORS AS FAR AS
WHAT LOCATION WHERE THE
FACILITY IS IN RELATION TO. TO
THE S. R. A. WHERE WE WOULD BE
DOING THE WORK- THERE ARE SOME
EXAMPLES OF FACILITIES IN IN
THIS- LOWS A WE'RE WE'RE
LOOKING AT RELOCATION- IN IN
LARGE PART BECAUSE THOSE
FACILITIES ARE NOW IN THE
MIDDLE OF A- OF AN URBAN AREA-
WHERE. FORTY FIFTY SIXTY YEARS
AGO THEY WEREN'T THEY WERE THEY
WERE MORE REALLY- ADJACENT TO
THE S. R. A. AND SO WERE. WERE
OPERATIONALLY EFFICIENT WHERE
THEY WERE LOCATED AND NOW WE
ARE WE ARE FINDING THAT SOME OF
THE STATIONS ARE NOW MORE IN AN
URBAN AREA WHERE WHERE ACCESS
IS MORE DIFFICULT AND- SO I
GUESS MY ANSWER IS IT WOULD BE
IT WOULD DEPEND ON THE SPECIFIC
FACILITY BUT I THINK WE WOULD-
WE WOULD CERTAINLY LOOK AT. AT-
AND THAT IS A POSSIBILITY IF IT
WERE A- WE CAN DO THAT. ALL
RIGHT I'M WILL BE IN CONTACT
CENTRE DOLLY. THANK YOU A
RESERVE A COMMENT MAINLY I I'LL
I GREW UP A MILE AND HALF FROM
THE INTERMOUNTAIN CAMP WHICH IS
ONE THAT YOU'RE GOING TO-
REPURPOSE AND WE JUST
DESPERATELY NEED. THESE
PROJECTS TO GO FORWARD IN A
MORE TIMELY MANNER IN MY MIND
WE HAVE THE INITIAL TACK THAT
WE NEED TO DO. WHICH IS
SOMETHING THAT WITH THE OTHER
STILL THE THIS SET UP RIGHT TO
DO THAT YOU CAN. GET THERE
QUICKER SO NUMBER ONE I THINK
IS THIS TO PULL WE DO WE NEED
TO DO IT CENTER Y. COSCO'S
TALKING ABOUT ON VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT BUT FIRST WE NEED TO
GET BE ABLE TO GET RESPOND TO
THESE LIGHTNING STRIKES IN
MOSTLY JURIES. IT'S GONNA BE
LIGHTNING THAT'S CAUSING THESE.
FIRES AT LEAST IN MY DISTRICT
SO THE INITIAL ATTACK IS
CRITICAL BECAUSE THE AMOUNT FOR
THE TAXPAYER DINNER THE DAY THE
QUICKER YOU PUT OUT A FIRE ON
WITH INITIAL TAX- THE MORE
MONEY YOU CAN SAVE IN THE LONG
RUN. IS WHEN WE HAVE THESE MEGA
FIRES IT'S COSTING US BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS SO THE THIS THIS IS
PEANUTS COMPARED TO WHAT THE
AMOUNT THEY'RE GOING TO SAVE
THE TAXPAYER BY BEING ABLE TO
GET ON THE INITIAL TAX SO FOR
ME. THERE'S NO BRAINER I THINK
THE QUICKER THE BETTER I THINK
WE SHOULD FRONT LOAD THIS AND
GET THESE PROJECTS COMPLETED.
NOT NOT JUST TO GET TO THE
PLANNING STAGE AND BUILD- I
KNOW FOR EXAMPLE THE HELLA TAK
IN BEAVER WERE I GET MY MAIL IT
ONLY CAN FLY IN THE HELICOPTER
CAN ONLY COME IN ONE WAY
BECAUSE- IT'S TOO CLOSE TO
SCHOOL SO IT ONLY HAS ONE PATH
IN AND OUT WHEN YOU HAVE WIND
PROBLEMS IT'S- IT ISSUE FOR
THAT HELICOPTER TO GET IN AND
OUT OF THERE. AND WE NEED THAT
FOR REFUELING AND ABLE TO
ATTACK THE STARS AND THE WIND
USUALLY BLOWING WE HAVE EVENTS
SO FOR ME I THINK WITH THE
QUICKER THE BETTER AND THEN
WE'LL TALK ABOUT THE-
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT AND
HOPEFULLY ANOTHER. PART OF THIS
THE- HEARING. YEAH I WAS
THINKING FOR K. IMPROVE- I
DON'T SEE CENTER STERN STAND UP
pREQUIRE- THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
WILL BE IN CONTACT. WITH YOU
LET'S MOVE ON TO. ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTEEN TO GET A HOLD THAT
MATTER OPEN- LET'S LOOK AT- DR
WOODS AB THIRTY EIGHT
DEFENSIBLE SPACE- N. O. CENTERS
EASTERN I'M SORRY. I'M SORRY I
MISSED IT I MISSED I CONNOR THE
BUTTON OKAY. IT IS I JUST
DIDN'T GET IT I DIDN'T GET A
CLEAR ANSWER TO YOUR QUESTION.
ABOUT OVERALL STRATEGY ACT I
WASI WAS STILL LOOKING FOR
THAT BASED ON THE ALEJO'S.
ANALYSIS APPORTIONING. DOLLARS
THINK ABOUT LONG TERM GOALS
HERE I STILL HAVEN'T I STILL
DIDN'T QUITE HEAR THAT. HOPING
WE CAN MAYBE DRILL DOWN THERE
COULD BE ENOUGH NEXT ITEM BUT-
THE THOUGHT THAT WAS A RELEVANT
QUESTION. YEAH DEFINITELY
FAVREAU- THERE'S QUITE A FEW
BRAND NEW- PROJECTS THAT HAVE
BEEN ADDED HI- I GUESS PUT ON
THE TAB OVER THE YEARS THAT
WE'VE BEEN HERE VERSUS THE ONE
SAID WE'RE THAT ARE CONTINUING
PROJECTS AND THIS IS THE TIME
TO BUILD THEM CAN YOU SHINE
SOME LIGHT ON. THE PRIORITIES
THAT YOU HAVE GIVEN TO THOSE-
IT THIS IS PHASE AS I
UNDERSTAND IT THESE PROJECTS
WERE- ALL PROJECTS THAT WE HAD
IN THE BUDGET. LAST YEAR- WE'RE
NOT ABLE TO- TO GO FORWARD WITH
BECAUSE OF THE FISCAL
UNCERTAINTY LAST FISCAL YEAR-
AS FAR AS SPECIFIC. PARTIES
WITHIN THIS. GROUP OF PROJECTS
IS THAT I GUESS I MEAN MAYBE
IT'S BETTER FOR ISSUE TWENTY
SECOND ACTUALLY RESERVED THIS
DISCUSSION FOR THEN BUT JUST TO
BE A BETTER SENSE OF HOW YOU'RE
BALANCING PRIORITIES BETWEEN
CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS
SUPPRESSION RESOURCES
PREVENTION RESOURCES YOU KNOW.
THERE'S A LOT IN ONE. A LOT IN
THIS ARENA RIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS OVERALL JUST JUST A
SENSE OF THAT THE SYSTEM MAYBE
IT'S WITH FROM CHIEF PORTER BUT
I JUST. I'M TRYING TO GET A
SENSE OF EMPHASIS HERE AND IT
SORT OF. WHAT DO WE SEE FOR
INSTANCE THE OVERALL
LIABILITIES ON THE SUPPRESSION
BUDGET LOOKING LIKE OVER TIME-
IS THAT CAN INCREASE HOW SHORT
OUR WEEK MEANS IT CENTER
DOLLARS POINT. LIKE YOU WHAT
EACH. ALL THOSE FOLKS WANT
EVERYTHING RIGHT NOW AND IT'S
STILL NOT GONNA BE ENOUGH WELL
HOW MUCH IS ENOUGH. YOU KNOW
JUST STARTING TO GIVE US A
SENSE OF. WHAT THE OVERALL SORT
OF SUPPRESSION LIABILITY IS AND
ALSO. TO THAT POINT LIKE WHAT
YOU THINK PREVENTION WILL SAVE
US. ON THAT ON THAT END OF
THINGS- BUT I CAN RESERVE THAT
FOR TWENTY TWO THAT'S IT. MORE
OF A STRATEGIC CONVERSATION. GO
INTO YOUR SATURDAY PORTER. YES
THEY THANK YOU- CHAIR WORK AS
HE- SENATOR STIR LET ME JUST-
BE VERY BRIEF- WE HAVE LOOKED
AT THE- PORTFOLIO OF
INVESTMENTS THAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT THIS YEAR. AS OF PARTLY OF
BUDGET CONSTRAINED- KIND OF
POINT OF VIEW. TARGETING THE
RIGHT DOLLARS FOR THE RIGHT
TYPE OF EFFORTS THAT WILL GET
US- FURTHEST INTO THE FUTURE-
TO HOPEFULLY BETTER TIMES- WITH
BUDGETS AND I KNOW BILLION
DOLLARS IS A HUGE BUDGET- AND
THESE ITEMS THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT NOW OR ABOVE AND BEYOND
THAT SO. SO I CAN'T THANK THE
GOVERNOR ENOUGH OF A WERE ALL
OF YOU FOR CONSIDERING THESE
INVESTMENTS. THEY ARE VERY MUCH
STRATEGICALLY- KIND OF SPREAD
IN ORDER TO BUILD ALL PARTS OF
THE DEPARTMENT- AND THE NEEDS
FOR FOREST AND WILDLAND
MANAGEMENT- STRUCTURE HARDENING
ALL OF THOSE THINGS THAT WILL
TALK ABOUT LATER. ALL OF THEM
ARE KIND OF PUT TOGETHER IN A
IN A PUZZLE A SET OF PUZZLE
PIECES CHU SH YEAH SHE HAD THE
FULL PICTURE A AND I AM
COMFORTABLE THAT WE ARE DOING.
THAT WITH THIS- THIS BUDGET ASK.
OKAY YEAH I THINK THE MORE
WE'LL GET A HOLD THIS I THINK
ONE OF THE OTHER WAYS THAT WE
MIGHT WANT TO LOOK AT THIS IS
SAID LET'S JUST SAY WE FOUND.
EIGHT OR TEN BILLION DOLLARS
KICKING AROUND IN THE BUDGET
AND WE SAID INSTEAD OF SPENDING
FIFTY FIVE MILLION WE WANT TO
SPEND THREE HUNDRED MILLION SO
WHAT WOULD YOU COME BACK TO US
AND YOUR PRIORITIES AND SAYING.
IF WE GO TO GO TO CONSTRUCTION
THIS IS WHAT WE WANT OR IF THIS
IN SORT OF IN THAT VEIN IS
WE'RE WE'RE IS THE BIGGEST NEED
GIVEN THE NEW NORMTHAT WE HAVE
BUT- WILL HOLD THE MATTER. THE
DISCUSSIONS WILL CONTINUE AND-
I REALIZE THAT WE'RE ALL HERE
SO. S. ROY FIVE ONE TO CALL THE
ROLL AND LET'S ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. WIECKOWSKI HERE MY
CASKEY HERE DOLLY DOLLY HERE
MCGUIRE YOUR REQUIRE HERE STERN.
STERN HERE STERN HERE. HI WE
HAVE A QUORUM IS BEEN
ESTABLISHED SINCE THAT'S GREAT
LET'S MOVE ON TO DEFENSIBLE
SPACE LET'S MOVE ON TO- FUNDING
A PROGRAM SO PEOPLE CAN SELL
THEIR HOUSES IN THEIR IN THE
WILL BE AND WHERE THE SOURCE OF
THAT MONEY'S GONNA COME FROM-
THAT. LET'S SIR I GUESS WE HAVE
THE FIRE MARSHAL- MARSHALL
RICHWINE A RICH ONE. THE
MORNING YOU ACTUALLY HAVE-
ASSISTANT STATE FIRE MARSHAL
WENDY COLLINS- THANK YOU AND
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MICHAEL OF YOUR TIME I OPENING
STATEMENTS WILL BE FREE-
ALLOWING US TO GET TO ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE-
WE'RE HERE TODAY TO DISCUSS THE
REQUEST OF A POINT THREE
MILLION GENERAL FUND AND TWENTY
SIX POSITIONS. STARTING IN
TWENTY ONE FUNNY TEAR. APPLE BE
NECESSARY TO CONDUCT OVER QUOTA
SO SEATED FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF AB THIRTY
EIGHTH. AND THE SUBSEQUENT
TRAINING AND STAFFING TWENTY
ONE NEW FORESTRY TECHNICIAN
POSITIONS. THOSE FOLKS WILL BE
TASKED WITH EVALUATION AND
CERTIFICATION OF STRUCTURE
HEARTENING MEASURES AND THE
PROPERTIES DEFENSIBLE SPACE
COMPLIANCE TO THE BUYERS OF
HOME HIGH OR VERY HIGH FIRE
SEVERITY SOME. AS WE WORK
THROUGH THIS PROPOSAL IT WAS
IMPORTANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT THE
PROGRAM IS DIFFERENT FROM THE
D. SPACE PROGRAM. HE SPACES
STOP WAS SEASONAL FORESTRY AIDS
THIS PROGRAM IS STOCKED WITH
PERMANENT FORESTRY TECHNICIANS.
THE SERVICE SEVERAL SERVICE
CLASSIFICATION REQUIRES A
DIFFERENT LEVEL OF TRAINING AND
IS THE ENTRY LEVEL POSITION
LEADING TO PROMOTIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES FORESTRY
ASSISTANT ONE AND TWO POSITIONS.
THE SPACE PROGRAM IS FOCUSED ON
MEETING THE CAL FIRE GOAL OF
COMPLETING THAT TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND. IT'S A BOLD
FACE INSPECTIONS ANNUALLY. THIS
PROGRAM AND THE TWENTY ONE
FORESTRY TECHNICIANS WILL BE
FOCUSED ON THE EVALUATION OF
STRUCTURES AND ANY HOME
HARDENING MEASURES THAT HAVE
BEEN ACHIEVED. IN CERTIFYING
THAT THAT INFORMATION AS PART
OF THE HOME SALE IN HIGH OR
VERY HIGH FIRE SEVERITY ZONES
IN THE US ALL RIGHT. AGAIN THIS
IS AN ENTRY LEVEL POSITION WITH
UPWARD MOBILITY POTENTIAL SO IT
SHOULD NOT BE ANTICIPATED THAT
THE ADDITIONAL STOP WITH READ
ONLY A ONE TIME ADDITIONAL
WORKLOAD. BUT THAT MOTIVATED
STAFF WILL BE USING THIS AS AN
ENTRY LEVEL POSITION AS A
STEPPING STONE TO MEET THEIR
CAREER GOALS AND HOPEFULLY
SUPPORT DEPARTMENT AS FORESTRY
ASSISTANCE. MAKING TURN OVER.
REALITY THAT WE MUST BE
PREPARED FOR. WITHOUT THE
DECISION STAFFING AND EQUIPMENT
REFER FOR THE TRAINING CENTER.
AND DAVIS PUBLIC BUT MEANT TO
SUPPORT THE INITIAL HIRES AND
THEIR SUBSEQUENT REPLACEMENT IS
NECESSARY TO BETWEEN TRAIN AND
WHAT WE GET BUT WORK FOR- I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND WE'LL BE HAPPY TO
ANSWERING QUESTIONS WHICH-
WE'LL GET TO THE- THE WHOLE NEW
PROGRAMS WE HAVE. THIS ALLEY-
POINTS OUT THAT. YOU'RE NOT
AUTHORIZED TO SIT TO- LEVY A
FEE FOR THE SERVICES THAT WE
PROVIDE IT TO THE HOMEOWNERS.
ESPECIALLY I WILL NOTE THAT
THIS IS WHEN PEOPLE ARE SELLING
THEIR HOUSES I MEAN THERE'S AN
ESCROW SOME BUYERS PUT DOWN
SOME MONEY THEY'RE DOING THAT.
WHY ARE YOU NOT ASKING US FOR
AUTHORITY TO JUST YOU KNOW A
SIMPLE MAJORITY VOTE TO SAY
WHAT YOUR SERVICES THAT YOU'RE
PROVIDING. THAT HOMEOWNERS
COULD PAY FOR IT IN THE
280-002-4000. EIGHT HUNDRED
TWENTY HOMES THAT WERE SOLD IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. I'M I
THINK THAT IT IS IMPORTANT TO
RECALL THAT THAT WE'VE TRIED A
FEE BEFORE- AND WHAT REALLY
ENDED UP HAPPENING WAS IT IT IT
IT DAMAGED OUR OUR OUR
REPUTATION AND OUR ABILITY TO
WORK WITH WITH THE PEOPLE THESE
HOMEOWNERS IN THESE WHAT WE
AREAS IT'S JUST SO IMPORTANT TO
HAVE THAT REALLY GOOD WORKING
RELATIONSHIP SO THAT THEY ARE
ABLE TO HEAR OUR MESSAGE ABOUT-
BARGAINING AND PROTECTING- THE
AREA. HELLO BUT THIS DON'T YOU
THINK THIS IS REALLY A
DIFFERENCE FOR ALL THE PEOPLE
LIVE IN THE WILL IT'S ONE THING
FOR ME TO GO ON TO YOUR
PROPERTY DO AN INSPECTION SAY
GET RID OF THIS TREE THIS TREE
BY ABOUT THAT AND HERE'S YOU'LL
BE A HUNDRED FIFTY BUCKS IT'S
ANOTHER I'M SOMEONE I'M MOVING
TO AUSTIN TEXAS WHEREVER PEOPLE
GO ON THE WYOMING AND YOU SAY
OKAY YOU WANT TO SELL THIS
HOUSE THIS IS FOR THE NEW BUYER
AND THIS IS WHAT THE FEE IS AND
IF YOU DON'T HAVE THE CASH PUT
IT INTO THE ESCROW WHICH IS
THIS IS THERE'S A TRANSACTION
THAT'S HAPPENING. I DON'T WANT
TO GET ARGUMENTATIVE BECAUSE I
JUST I JUST WANT TO PUT THAT
OUT WE'RE GOING TO HOLD THIS
ITEM I'M. VERY INTERESTED IN
THE ALLEY OWES. IDEA ON THIS
THIS THIS. OF IT THIS THE
PORSCHE OF PEOPLE SELLING THEIR
HOUSES THIRD LEAVING. BELIAU
WHO'S- THIS IS MR BROWN AGAIN.
YES GOOD MORNING PRIME BROWN
WITH L. A. L. AGAIN- SO FIRST
OF ALL IN TERMS OF THE BUDGET
REQUEST WE THINK THAT- MOST OF
THEREQUEST IS. A WARRANTED
CONSISTENT WITH THE
REQUIREMENTS OF AB THIRTY EIGHT
SO I ANY ADDITIONAL FACTORS AND
THE ASSOCIATED WITH THE MAKE
SENSE WE DID HAVE TWO
TECHNICAL- RECOMMENDATIONS I
JUST MEANT THAT WE WOULD
RECOMMEND. ALLUDED TO BY MS
COLLINS- WHEN ONE OF THEM IS
THAT- THERE'S ONGOING POSITION
REQUESTED TO DO TRAINING OF NEW
INSPECTORS AND ALSO PROCUREMENT
OF THEIR VEHICLES. WE SUGGESTED
THAT BE ONE TIME IN NATURE THAT
DEFINITELY WILL BE A
REPLACEMENT PROCESS- NOT
NECESSARY OVER THE LONGER TERM
BY THE BOOK OF THE WORKLOAD
WILL BE KIND OF FRONT LOAD IT.
IN IN THE SECOND TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENT IS- THAT THERE'S A
ONE TIME REQUEST FOR FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
PURCHASE A NEW FIRE ENGINE FOR
USE AT THE SOUTHERN TRAINING
FACILITY- WE RECOMMEND
REJECTING THAT PORTION OF THIS
REQUESTED THAT'S NOT REALLY
DIRECTLY RELATED AB THIRTY
EIGHT IMPLEMENTATION- TO YOUR
HERE. POINT MISTER CHAIR- YEAH
WE DID RAISE THIS QUESTION
CURRENTLY THE ADMINISTRATION OR
THE DEPARTMENT OF NOT HAVE
AUTHORITY TO CHARGE A FEE FOR-
FOR THESE ACTIVITIES AND WE DID
RAISE THE QUESTION WHETHER THAT
WOULD BE SOMETHING WORTH. THE
LEGISLATURE ADMINISTRATION
ENGAGING IN CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
IT YOU POINT OUT I THINK IN OUR
VIEW THIS IS MORE OF A- DIRECT
SERVICE IN IN RESPONSE TO A
REQUEST FROM A HOMEOWNER
PROPERTY OWNER UPON SALE. ON IN
IN THE OTHER ADVANTAGE OF-
CONCERNING THE CREATION OF A
FEE OF FORTY FOR THIS ACTIVITY
WOULD BE THAT ULTIMATELY THAT
REVENUE THEN WOULD OFFSET THE
NECESSITY FOR USING GENERAL
FUND ON AN ONGOING BASIS. FOR
THIS PROGRAM. AND IF I COULD WE
JUST HAD ONE OTHER SNOW
RECOMMENDATION WHICH IS TO
ADOPT A REPORTING LANGUAGE FOR
THIS PROGRAM ON AN ONGOING
BASIS AND- THIS IS REALLY JUST
THAT REFLECT THE FACT THAT THIS
IS A BRAND NEW WORKLOAD FOR THE
DEPARTMENT AND SO. WE THOUGHT
THEY TOOK A REASONABLE APPROACH
TO ESTIMATING WHAT THE ONGOING
WORKLOAD WOULD BE- BUT THERE'S
A LEVEL OF UNCERTAINTY BY
VIRTUE OF IT BEING MALE AND THE.
THE REASON WE THINK THIS IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT IN- TWO
WEEKS. THAT COULD BE HIGHER
THAN INTO. IN THE BUDGET
REQUEST. THERE IS A POSSIBILITY
THEN THAT THE DEPARTMENT MIGHT
HAVE TO DIVERT RESOURCES FROM
OTHER. PROGRAMS TO ENSURE THAT
THEY MEET THE STATUTORILY
REQUIRED- WORKLOAD AND SHOW- TO
CAN WE HAVE SOME REPORTING ON
ON WORKLOAD GOING FORWARD THAT
COULD INFORM FUTURE.
ADJUSTMENTS WE MIGHT NEED TO
MAKE TO FUND THE PROGRAM
APPROPRIATELY. FILLETING GAUGE
WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION MISTER
BENSON MISS MORE AT FINANCE.
YOUR RECOGNIZED MISTER BENSON.
MORNING MR THANK YOU STEVEN
BENSON APARTMENT FINANCES JUST
VERY BRIEFLY AS FAR TO SAY LIKE
WE COMPLETELY OPEN TO THE
CONVERSATION- I THINK MILAN'S
OF THE ADMINISTRATION PART OF
THE REASON WHY WE DIDN'T WE
DON'T HAVE THE AUTHORITY WE
DIDN'T PROPOSE THE AUTHORITY
FOR HE IS LOOKING OUT FOR ME IN
A BIG BENEFIT PERSPECTIVE-
THERE'S ABSOLUTELY A BENEFIT TO
THE HOME SELLER AND HOMEBUYER.
AND THIS TRANSACTIONS YOU'RE
RIGHT THERE'S NO ARGUMENT THERE
I THINK THERE'S ALSO A LARGER
PUBLIC BENEFIT TO THE MEANT TO
BE SPENT THE WEEK IN
CENTRALIZING MOTIVATE PEOPLE TO
CREATE A MENTAL SPACE AND THE
SAFETY THAT IT CREATES ROUND
COMMUNITIES AND HOMES SO I
THINK PART OF IT WAS THAT WAS
OUR VIEW AND JENNIFER WAS
APPROPRIATE BECAUSE THE GENERAL
BENEFIT BUT AGAIN CERTAINLY UP
IN THE CONVERSATION I THINK
IT'S A GOOD ONE TO HAVE. A LOOK
FORWARD TO HAVING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS RECOGNIZE SENATOR
STERN- HAS HIS. HEAD UP AND
THEN I'LL GO TO SENATE MCGUIRE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- IT GOES
BACK TO THE SAME THING THAT WE
TRY TO GET ON THE MY FIRST
QUESTION JUST IN TERMS F HOW
THIS FITS INTO THE BROADER
STRATEGY SO AND JUST AND JUST
TO BE CLEAR ABOUT THE MY LAST
POINT IT WAS NOT- THAT WE MAY
BE OVERSHOOTING THE BUDGET HERE
I DON'T WANT TO BE MISTAKEN IN
THAT REGARD I. AGREE WITH CHIEF
PORTER BILLION DOLLARS SOUNDS
BIG- BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
FIRE LIABILITIES STATE IT'S
ACTUALLY. IT'S A DROP IN THE
BUCKET- SO I DIDN'T MEAN TO
IMPLY THAT WE MAY BE
OVERSHOOTING IT I'M JUST TRYING
TO GET A SENSE OF HOW THE
PUZZLE PIECES FIT TOGETHER AND
IN FACT I THINK A PROPER NEEDS
ASSESSMENT WOULD REVEAL THAT WE
ARE UNDER SHOOTING THE BUDGET
HERE. AND I DON'T KNOW EXACTLY
WHERE BUT I'D LIKE TO HAVE THAT
ASSESSMENT REALLY DRIVES AND
NOT JUST ABOUT AVOIDED ACREAGE
BURNED BUT ABOUT STRUCTURAL
DEFENSE AND TO THAT END NO MY
QUESTION ON THIS ONE IS IT
LOOKS IT LOOKS SORT OF ORIENTED
ON COMPLIANCE DOCUMENTATION AND
TRANSACTION BASED. ON THE DATA
HERE SAYS THAT THAT SAY ABOUT
TWENTY FOUR THOUSAND HOME SOTHE NECESSARY. TERRITORY IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUT- BUT BETTER
SEVEN OR THIRTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
ACTUALLY LIVE THERE BUT- THIS
ISN'T ABOUT THE COMMUNITIES
THAT ACTUALLY. LIVE IN THE WILL
WE THIS ISN'T MORE ABOUT THE
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO SELL THEIR-
HOMES AND LEAVE THE WILL EAT AT
IS THAT IS THAT RIGHT. THAT'S
THE TARGET HERE. WHAT WE NEED
TO ALSO PICK THEM TO GO BACK TO
OUR ORIGINAL ROUTE- AND THAT IS
TO PROTECT THE WILDLAND FROM
THE HOME HAS AN EXISTING
NATIONS. SO BANTER ABOUT BE A
BENEFIT FOR THE ENTIRE THING-
KEEPING DURING THOSE
INSPECTIONS MAKING SURE THAT
THE NEW HOMEOWNER OR THAT THE
OLD HOMEOWNER- HAS HAS
APPROPRIATELY FOR THE TECH TO
THAT- FACILITY. FROM CREATING A
FIRE HAZARD- THE- WHICH- GOES
BACK TO SENATOR DOLLIES
COMMENTS ABOUT MAKING YOU KNOW
THOSE INITIAL ATTACKS AND THIS
WOULD BE EFFECTIVELY AN INITIAL
ATTACK BEFORE THE FIRE- WHICH
PROVIDES A BENEFIT FOR THE
INTENTION I UNDERSTAND TRYING
TO GET. MY SPIDER VERY SPECIFIC
QUESTION. WHO'S THE TARGET
AUDIENCE HERE IS THE BACK
TRANSACTIONS OF PEOPLE TRYING
TO LEAVE THE COMMUNITY NOT
EXISTING STRUCTURES OF PEOPLE
ARE STATE CORRECT. CORRECT OKAY
SO HOW MANY HOW MANY HOW HOW
MANY TRANSACTIONS YOU WANT TO
TRY TO GET TO WITH THE SIX
MILLION DOLLARS THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE. AB THIRTY
EIGHT IN ORDER FOR US TO BE
COMPLIANT SAYS ALL OF THEM. ALL
OF THEM IN THE I'M SORRY. IN
THE HIGH AND VERY HIGH FIRE
SEVERITY ONCE. SHAPE SO YOU.
THE GOAL IS TO COVER EVERY
SINGLE TRANSACTION IN THOSE
AREAS. IN THE UP COMING FISCAL
YEAR WITH THIS MONEY. YES. IT'S
LIKE IF YOU'RE BASING THAT OFF
THANK SAID THE TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND A YEAR SO IN THEORY
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
HOMES. OKAY UNDERSTOOD SO YES.
MY QUESTIONS ABOUT JUST WHAT
WHAT ABOUT EVERYBODY ELSE. I
DON'T NEED TO BE I DON'T NEED
TO BE CONVINCED OF THE EFFICACY
OF. DOING DEFENSIBLE SPACE
INSPECTIONS OF MOVE LEGISLATION
ON THIS AT THE LEGISLATION
VETOED WE'VE HAD LEGISLATION
NOT FUNDED. YEAR AFTER YEAR
AFTER YEAR SO THANK YOU
ACTUALLY FOR FINALLY FINDING
SOME DEFENSIBLE SPACE IT'S
TAKEN US. THREE YEARS TO GET
HERE SINCE AB THIRTY EIGHT PASS
AND IT KEEPS FALLING OFF THE
TABLE WHAT WE FIND EVERYTHING
ELSE SO. DEFINITELY DON'T NEED
TO BE CONVINCED THE EFFICACY I
JUST WORRY WERE COMPLETELY
UNDER SHOOTING IT WE WERE JUST
TALKING AT SIX HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS. OUR TIME AT
SIX MILLION DOLLARS. AND WE'RE
QUIBBLING OVER ARE WE GOING TO
COVER ENOUGH TRANSACTIONS. WHAT
ABOUT THE ALMOST MILLION PEOPLE
WHO ARE GONNA BE LEFT BEHIND BY
THIS. HOUR THOSE HOMES GOING TO
BE INSPECTED AND WHAT WE DO
WITH. ALL THE INSURANCE FALL
OUT THEY WERE ABOUT TO FACE IN
THIS COMMUNITY SO. IT'S MORE OF
A COMMENT THE TECHNICAL ABOUT
FOR UPCOMING DISCUSSIONS BUT-
IT DOESN'T FEEL LIKE. WE'RE
ADDRESSING THE ROOT OF THE
PROBLEM WHICH IS EVERYONE
LIVING IN THIS RISK WHO IS
STAYING. NOT TRANSACTING IN
LEAVING. AND HOW DO WE ACTUALLY
MAKE THOSE COMMUNITIES HART-
THIS DOESN'T SEEM TO ADDRESS
THAT SO MAYBE IN THAT ISSUE
TWENTY WE- WRESTLE. A LITTLE
BIT WITH THE LINKAGE BETWEEN.
THIS RETRO THE SORT OF TRY.
SPACE AND THEN EVERYBODY ELSE
SO. THANK YOU ALL ON DAILY
NOTED WE WILL- CONTINUE WITH
THIS CONVERSATION CENTER
MCGUIRE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
RESEARCHER- IN. THANK YOU
SYSTEM FOR MARSHALL AND I THINK
IT'S IN THE STERN FOR THE
COMMENTS AS WELL LOOK I THINK
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THIS FOR ME
ALL SEASON COMMENTS IN JUST.
SOME QUICK A QUICK QUESTION.
WHILE WE CONTINUE TO MAKE
PROGRESS YEAR AFTER YEAR. IT'S
UNDERWHELMING AND WE NEED A
MODERN A PERMANENT FUNDING
SOURCE FOR VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT IN HOME HARDENING IN
WHY WE ARE HERE. ALMOST THIRTY
SIX MONTHS LATER TO THE DAY
WHEN THIS LEGISLATURE PASSED-
AB THIRTY EIGHT. AND IT'S NOT
BEEN FUNDED. AND CONTINUES TO
STRIP THE FUNDING- JUST MY MIND
IS BLOWN. AT IN THE TO BE
HONEST THE AB THIRTY EIGHT HAD
FUNDING ATTACHED. IT WAS
STRIPPED OUT. SO ON THE S. R.
AMFI I AM 110% AGAINST THE S.
R. AMFI WE'VE HAD CONVERSATIONS
HERE ABOUT ON FAIRLY. TAXING
RURAL RESIDENTS WHEN THEY
DIDN'T EVEN RECEIVE THE
SERVICES CAL FIRE BUT WHERE
THE- CHAIR WAS SAYING IS THAT
IF THIS IS- A FEE ATTACHED TO A
HOME WHO NEEDS THE SERVICE TO
BE ABLE TO SELL AND THAT'S JUST
BE CANDID AT THE NUMBER ONE
MISTAKE FOR CALIFORNIANS IS
THEIR HOME. SO THIS IS A
POTENTIAL EQUITABLE APPROACH.
NOT JUST BASED ON AND A
GEOGRAPHY OF WHERE AN
INDIVIDUAL LIVES WHICH I THINK
OF CHOOSING MORE EQUITY SO I A
LOT OF COMMENTS HERE AND I
WOULD JUST SAY I WOULD HOPE
MISTER CHAIR. THAT WE COULD
HAVE FURTHER CONVERSATION ON
THIS AND CANDIDLY I JUST DON'T
THINK THE ERLY ACTION THAT IS
BEING PROPOSED IN THIS BUDGET
IS AT ALL ADEQUATE. FOR WHERE
WE NEED TO GO FOR FIRE
PREVENTION AS WELL AS FIRE
THE DISCUSSION IN THE WEEKS TO
COME. WE'LL GET TO THAT AN ITEM.
TWENTY I DO HAVE CENTER DOLLARS.
TO LOOK THERE WAS A COMMENT
MADE ABOUT THE S. R. A. T. THAT
DID NOT REALLY GO TO ANYBODY IN
ONE OF THE GENERAL FUND WAS
SPENT ON ALL KINDS OF OTHER
THINGS OTHER THAN S. R. AREA.
AND FOR MY DISTRICT THERE'S A
LOT OF PEOPLE IN HISTORY I HAVE
A QUESTION THAT I- I KNOW
YOU'RE NOT GONNA BE ABLE ANSWER
TODAY BUT LIKE SOME FOLLOW UP
ON I'D LIKE TO KNOW HOW MANY-
HOMES BURKE AT WAR. IN SRH
CALIFORNIA. I THINK THAT'S
ANOTHER ISSUE WE ARE TALK ABOUT
AND WE WE'VE BEEN BEGGING FOR.
SOMEBODY IN THE DEPARTMENT.
WHETHER IT'S- A LOCAL FIRE
DEPARTMENT WHETHER IT'S A- CAL
FIRE SOMEBODY TO BE ABLE TO GO
OUT INSPECT AND HELP PEOPLE
UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY NEED TO
MAKE THEIR- PROPERTY SAFE
WHETHER YOU'RE SELLING OR NOT.
THERE WERE ONLY TALKING ABOUT
PEOPLE ARE SELLING HOMES HERE
WHAT ABOUT THE- PEOPLE WHO LIKE
ME I NEVER WANT TO LEAVE THEIR-
SO. THERE'S GOT TO BE SOME
NEXUS TO EVERYBODY THAT LIVES
IN S. RA SOME RESOURCE OR SOME
ABILITY BE ABLE TO ACCESS
SOMEBODY COME OUT AND TELL THEM
HOW TO KEEP THEIR HOME SAFE.
AND THAT'S A GOOD SEGUE FOR OUR
NEXT ISSUE NUMBER NINETEEN
THANK YOU EVERYBODY WE WILL
OBVIOUSLY HAVE STAFF TO GET
BACK TO YOU ONE. OF THE THINGS
THAT WE TOUCHED ON AN ISSUE
NUMBER EIGHTEEN WE'RE GOING TO
HOLD. ISSUE NUMBER EIGHTEEN
LET'S TALK ABOUT THOSE HAND
CREWS AND THE CCC AND THE-
FOUR. FORESTRY DEPARTMENT- THE
STATE DIRECTOR PORTER I THINK
A- YEAR ON. ANIMAL HAVE-
DIRECTOR SZETO FROM CCC. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR AGAIN AND- I
AM JUST GOING TO STAND ON THE
COMMENTS THAT I MADE PREVIOUSLY
AS AN OPENER. AND PASSED TO-
DEPUTY DIRECTOR- TYLER WHO WILL
TALK ABOUT THE SPECIFICS OF THE
CRUISE AND- AND THEN I WILL
ALSO- DEFER TO. A DIRECTOR
SAIDO- IF THERE ARE SPECIFIC.
ISSUES RELATED TO US THE CDC.
THE BILL DIRECTOR TYLER THANK
YOU THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR WHERE CASCADING GOOD
MORNING FELLOW SENATORS ON THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JOE TYLER
AND THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR FIRE
PROTECTION. I IN THIS PROPOSAL
CAUGHT FIRE IN THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS REQUESTING A
HUNDRED FORTY THREE MILLION TWO
HUNDRED AND SIXTY SIX. THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND. FOR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR MILLION
FOUR HUNDRED NINETY THREE
THOUSAND AND GENERAL FUND
PHASED IN OVER FIVE YEARS- AND
AN ADDITIONAL SIX HUNDRED
SEVENTEEN POSITIONS ON GOING TO
HAVE THIRTY ADDITIONAL HAND
CREWS. TO PROVIDE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT HAZARDOUS FUEL
REDUCTION PROJECT WORK AND
WILDLAND FIRE SUPPRESSION. THIS
PROPOSAL WILL STAFF SIXTEEN
FIREFIGHTER HAND CREWS AT SEVEN
OF THE DE. CONSERVATION CAMP
FACILITIES STAFF EACH YEAR
ROUND SEE SEE SEE HAND CREWS
FOR CCC FACILITIES. STAFF SIX
ADDITIONAL I SEE SEE SEE WHO'S
OFFICIALS EXISTING FACILITIES
DURING. THE FIRE SEASON. AS A
FEBRUARY SEVEN TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY. CALIFORNIA HAVE THREE
HUNDRED WILDLAND FIRES BURNING
200-030-0404 ACRES. COMPARED TO
THE SAME TIME FRAME IN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY. CALIFORNIA SO
ONE HUNDRED FIFTY SEVEN
WILDLAND FIRES FOR ONE HUNDRED
TEN ACRES. THE FIVE YEAR
AVERAGE RIGHT NOW IS A HUNDRED
AND FORTY FIRES FOR SEVENTY ONE
ACRES. RELATED TO THE ACT
PROPOSAL HOW FIRE IS SEEN A
DECREASE IN THE NUMBER OF FIRE
CREWS AVAILABLE TO RESPOND TO
THESE EMERGENCIES. THIS
DECREASE IS A RESULT IN A FEWER
NUMBER CREWS AVAILABLE TO
PERFORM CRITICAL FUEL REDUCTION
WORK. AROUND OUR COMMUNITIES
AND VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
PROJECTS THAT HELP ENFORCE
HEALTH. HOW FAR HISTORICALLY
HAD A DESIGNED CAPACITY OF TWO
HUNDRED EIGHT. FIVE ONE ARE
FIGHTING HAND CREWS INCLUDING
ONE HUNDRED AND NINETY TWO FIRE
CREWS THROUGH COOPERATIVE
AGREEMENTS WITH THE- CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION. AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUVENILE JUSTICE
TWELVE HAND ROOSTER PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS AND AN
ADDITIONAL FOUR HAND CREWS OF
IT'S A JOINT EFFORT WITH
MULTIPLE AGENCIES AS PART OF A
TRAINING PROGRAM IN THE COUNTRY
TRAINING CENTER. OVER THE LAST
DECADE THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CAMP PROGRAM IS
EXPERIENCED A DECLINE IN THE
AMOUNT OF FIREFIGHTERS
AVAILABLE TO FULLY STAFF ITS
FAR TREES. WHICH HAS RESULTED
IN THE OPERATION OF FEWER HANG
INCREASE THE SUPPORT THE
OPERATIONS AND PLAY AS A
DISPUTE REDUCTION PROJECTS. IN
RECOGNITION OF THE TREND THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
REFLECTED A CONSOLIDATION OF
INMATE FIREFIGHTERS AND THE
POPULATION OF A CAMP
FACILITIES- BY CDC ARE. TODAY
ACCOUNT- CURRENTLY HAS AN
APPROVED DESIGN CAPACITY OF A
HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT HAND CREWS.
OUT WITH A HUNDRED AND FIFTY
TWO OF THEM COMING FROM CDC ARE
WELL FROM CCC AND FOR RELATED
TO THE VENTURA TRAINING CENTER
PROGRAM. OUT OF THIRTY
CONSERVATION CAMPS FOR FIRE
CENTERS IN ONE TRAINING CENTER.
UNFORTUNATELY DUE TO A VARIETY
OF FACTORS INCLUDING A CO
WRITTEN BY REMEMBER WE'RE ONLY
ABLE STAFF TODAY A TOTAL OF
FIFTY THREE OF THE ONE HUNDRED
SIXTY EIGHT FULLY TRAINED AND
QUALIFIED. ARE FIGHTING HAND
CREWS AS OF JANUARY TWENTY
SEVENTH R. WHICH WAS OUR LAST
CAN'T COUNT. ANOTHER TWENTY
ENTRIES ARE AVAILABLE IN THEIR
LOCAL AREAS BUT THEY HAVE TO
FEW CREW MEMBERS. ARE TO BE
TYPED AS A FULLY TRAINED AND
QUALIFIED HANGRY BY STATE
NATIONAL. STANDARDS BUT THEY
ARE AVAILABLE LOCALLY. FIRE
CREWS. ARE WANT THE MOST
VERSATILE SPECIAL RIES.
CALIFORNIA AFTER FIRE
SUPPRESSION WE'VE TALKED ABOUT
AVIATION ASSETS AND WE
APPRECIATE THE- SUPPORT BY THE
LEGISLATURE IN ADMINISTRATION.
BUT THESE HANGERS ARE ALSO A
VERY SPECIALIZED AND VERSATILE
RESOURCE THE CLEAR VEGETATION
AWAY FROM. THE ONCOMING FIRE
THEY WORK IN THE HEAD OF THE
FIRE THERE OFTEN REMOTE TEAM
WORK IN REMOTE AREAS.
INACCESSIBLE TERRAIN WHICH
BULLDOZERS AND OTHER APPARATUS
CANNOT WORK AND- IN WITHOUT AN
ADEQUATE NUMBER OF PANTRIES
FIRES. WILL LIKELY GROW LARGER
RESULTING IN INCREASED DAMAGE
TO WATERSHED WILDLIFE FISHERIES
AND AIR QUALITY IN CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE NOT RESPONDING TO
EMERGENCIES IT'S IMPORTANT TO
NOTE FIRE CREWS ENGAGE AND THAT
FUEL REDUCTION VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT. PRESCRIBED FIRES
AND FOREST HEALTH PROJECTS WE
RECENTLY REVIEWED- CALIFORNIA
CREW UTILIZATION AT SEVEN OF
EIGHTY CONSOLIDATED
CONSERVATION CAMPS THE SHOW ON
AVERAGE BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN AND NINETEEN. OF THE
CALIFORNIA CREWS IN THOSE SEVEN
FACILITY SPENT 25% MORE TIME.
RELATED CONSERVATION WORK.
BEING SPENT ON FIRE SCIENCE NOW
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY WAS A
DEVASTATING YEAR AND WE KNOW
THAT- THAT'S REASON- I HOPE
GOES IN ON AN ANOMALY I FEAR
THAT IT'S NOT BUT THE REASON WE
TOOK THE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
TO NINETEEN AVERAGE. GOVERNOR
ALSO UTILIZES CALIFORNIA
NATIONAL GUARD TROOPS TO
AUGMENT FIREFIGHTING RESOURCES.
DURING THE TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
FIRE SEASON THE ADMINISTRATION
ARGUMENT AND THE EMERGENCY
FUND. TO ADD AN ADDITIONAL
SEIZE ALL OF CCC CREWS AND A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY EIGHT
FIREFIGHTERS. TO ACTORS FIRE
CREW MEMBERS AS PART OF A SURGE
CAPACITY RELATED TO KOBE AND A
DECLINING POPULATIONS. AGAIN
CALIFORNIA HERE'S REQUESTING TO
STAFF A SIXTEEN FIREFIGHTER
CREWS WILL BE OPERATED ON THE
SEVEN CONSERVATION CAMPS THAT
WERE RECENTLY TO POPULATED.
THOSE INCLUDE DEVIL'S GARDEN-
CHAMBERLAIN CREEK. HIGH ROCK
CAN'T VALLEY VIEW. BASELINE
PILOT ROCK IN RAINBOW. IS FAR
BETTER CREWS WILL BE STAFFED
TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY SEVEN
DAYS A WEEK FOR NINE MONTHS A
YEAR FROM BETWEEN MARCH
FIFTEENTH. AND DECEMBER
FIFTEENTH OF EACH YEAR. THE
CREWS WILL BE STAFF WITH A FIRE
CAPTAIN FIRE AFTER ENGINE IN A
MIN OF THREE C. FIRE WEDNESDAY
LEAD TO PERFORM REDUCTION WORK
FIRE PREVENTION WORK. WHEN
THEY'RE NOT ASSIGNED TO
EMERGENCY INCIDENTS. THIS MODEL
WILL PROVIDE ACTUALLY THIRTY
ONE ADDITIONAL CREW DAYS OR TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS A EAR WITH
NINE MONTHS. OF FIREFIGHTER
CREWS THAT ARE TRADITIONAL HAND
THROUGH MODEL. DUE TO- WEEKENDS
VISITATION AND OTHERWISE THAT
PROVIDE AN AVERAGE OF TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY NINE DAYS. A
YEAR OF WORK- FIREFIGHTERS DO
RIGHT NOW WORKING OUT AT WORK A
SEVENTY TWO HOUR SHIFT- AND
WITH SEVEN DAY WEEK COVERAGE
CAL FIRE. CAN UTILIZE OFF DUTY
PERSONNEL THE BACKFILL BEHIND
TRUE ONCE IT'S COMMITTED. TO AN
EMERGENCY INCIDENT THAT'S WHAT
WE TYPICALLY CALL AT A STAFFING
PATTERN. THE SURGE TRUE CAN BE
UTILIZED FOR COVERAGE BEHIND
THE FIRE CREW COMMITTED TO AN
EMERGENCY INCIDENT. OR FOR
EMERGENCY RESPONSE THE NEW
FIRES STAFFING OF SIXTEEN
FIREFIGHTER CREWS STATEWIDE
WILL PROVIDE CALIFORNIA WITH
THE ABILITY POTENTIALLY TO
SURGE TO THIRTY TWO FIRE CREWS
JUST OUT OF THE SIXTEENS. I
HAVEN'T FOLKS ON BOTH ENDS OF
THE WEEK AND TIMES OF CRITICAL
FIRE NEED. IN ADDITION THE
FIREFIGHTER CREWS WILL BE
STAFFED. TWENTY FOUR HOURS A
DAY SEVEN DAYS A WEEK. AS IT
RELATES TO OUR RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS CALIFORNIANS
C. C. C. HAS. A TWELVE YEAR
ROUND BURKE THREE STAFF
STATEWIDE THROUGH OURSTRONG
RELATIONSHIP THAT'S EVER
BUILDING. A CAMPFIRE IN THE
CCC- REQUESTING THE STAFF. THE
TRANSITION SIX EXISTING
REIMBURSEMENT CCC CREWS AND A
TYPE ONE WELL WE TRAINED AND
QUALIFIED FIRE CREWS WHICH
CRUISE IN TAHOE TWO AND A
STOCKTON DELTA- AND- TWO IN THE
UKIAH WILLITS AREA. AND THEN
ADDITIONALLY THE PROPOSAL ADDS
TO EXPANSION CREWS TO THE LOS
PINOS FACILITY- IN THE
RIVERSIDE AREA. THE REQUEST
INCLUDES AN ASSET OF ONE POINT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS IN YEAR
ONE AND TWO POINT SEVEN MILLION
STARTING YEAR TWO FROM THE
COLLEGE DUBLIN REIMBURSEMENT
COUNT. REFLECTED THE SIX
EXISTING REIMBURSEMENT CRUCIAL
TRANSITION. TO BE FULLY FUNDED
BY THE GENERAL FUND. THE
PROPOSAL ALSO INCLUDES FUNDING
TO STAFF SIX CCC CREWS
SEASONALLY DIS TO BOLSTER
EMERGENCY RESPONSE CAPACITY.
DURING THE PEAK FIRE SEASON
ACTIVITIES ALSO PERFORM
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT HAZARDOUS
FUEL REDUCTION PROJECTS WHEN
THEY'RE NOT ASSIGNED TO
EMERGENCIES. FINALLY IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT THE
POSITIONS AND EQUIPMENT
CONTAINED WITHIN THIS PROPOSAL
ARE REALLY A COMBINATION OF
REALLOCATED POSITIONS EQUIPMENT
FROM THE EIGHT TO DE POPULATE
CONSERVATION CAMPS AROUND THE
BUDGET ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY. AS WELL AS ADDITIONAL
NEW POSITIONS TO MEET THE
OPERATIONAL NEEDS FOR THE FOR
THE HAND CRUZ. AGAIN ARE STRONG
WORKING RELATIONSHIP FORM
BETWEEN CALPERS CCC AND CDCR TO
PROVIDE HAND CREWS TO CONDUCT
FIRE SUPPRESSION FUEL REDUCTION
OF VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
RELATED WORK RELATED WORK. I
HAS BEEN OUTSTANDING IN
CONTINUES TO GROW. SENATORS WE
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
TO PRESENT THIS PROPOSAL TODAY
WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE BUT I
LIKE TO- DEFERRED TO DIRECTOR
SIDE- IF HE HAS ANY COMMENTS
YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE. DIRECTOR
GOT PROCEED. THANK YOU CHAIR
AND OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND- I THANK YOU- A
DEPUTY. DEPUTY CHIEF TYLER NO
OF ALL THAT- DEPUTY CHIEF
TYLER- DESCRIBED IS COMPLETELY
1100% ACCURATE- BUT IT'S
BECAUSE WE GOT OFF. A LONG
STANDING- OR WELL COORDINATED
WORKING RELATIONSHIP WITH CAL
FIRE WE LOOK FORWARD TO.
IMPLEMENTING THIS PROPOSAL- IN
THE COMING MONTHS. X. LET'S
HEAR FROM THE OUR WE HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS- I'M GONNA HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS ON THE MIX BETWEEN
THAT CAL FIRE SIDE IN THE CCC
BUT LET'S HEAR FROM THE ALEJO-
MISTER. BROWN YES A GOOD
MORNING AGAIN BRAND BROWN WITH
L. A. L. SO OVERALL- WITH
RESPECT TO THE FIRE CREW
PROPOSAL WE THINK THERE'S A LOT
OF MERIT IN CONSIDERING THIS
PROPOSAL- IS G. TYLER NOTED
THERE BEEN A SIGNIFICANT
DECLINE IN THE- IN MAY
CONSERVATION CAMP UP
POPULATION. IT DROPPED BY OVER
A THOUSAND ROUGHLY A THOUSAND
EVEN BEFORE KOBE ED CHAU- AND
THAT'S BECAUSE OF- SEVENTEEN
CHANGES THAT HAVE BEEN AND NOT
GET OVER THE YEAR AND THE FIRE
CREWS THAT SERVE AN IMPORTANT
ROLE IN OUR OVERALL FIRE
RESPONDED WELL AS- HAS FUELED
MITIGATION WORK- IF. BUT EVEN
THOSE AMERICAN MIND WE DID HAVE
A COUPLE OF COMMENTS- THE FIRST
IS IT WE THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR THE COMMITTEE TO THINK
ABOUT THIS PROPOSAL IN LIGHT OF
THE ONGOING GENERAL FUND.
CONDITION THIS IS A NOTABLE ON
GOING. GENERAL FUND
AUGMENTATION OVER A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS ON AN ANNUAL
BASIS- THEY HAD GOING. ON ON AN
ONGOING BASIS AND AS I NOTED
EARLIER OUR OFFICE AND
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE PROJECT
OUT YOUR GENERAL FUND SHORTFALL
SO YOU'LL JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT IF YOU DO APPROVED. THIS
PROPOSAL OR OR- OR OF EVEN A
PART OF IT THAT THAT IS THAT
ONGOING GENERAL FUND PRIORITY-
THE SECOND COMMENT IS- WE THINK
THAT THERE'S CERTAINLY VALUE IN
EXPLORING THIS OPTION A MINUTE
THE CREATING THE NEW HAND
CRUISING CALIFORNIA LITTLE BIT
OF A NEW ACTIVITY THAT HAD
MAKING THE FROM AN ONGOING HAND
CREWS- WITH FIREFIGHTER ONES.
THAT CREATE THE IS THE- WORK
OPTION AGAIN BUT WE KNOW DID
THE EXPENSIVE WAY TO CREATE
CREWS RELATIVE TO OTHER THAT WE
USE IN THE PAST WHETHER THAT
UTILIZING. THE CONSERVATION
CORPS- THE PROLIA TRAINING
CENTER THAT YOU KILEY MENTIONED
ADVENTURE- WE'VE ALSO
CONTRACTED WITH THE NATIONAL
GUARD. AND SO WE THINK IT MAY
BE WORTHWHILE USING THE SPRING
PROCESS TO EXPLORE WHETHER
THERE MIGHT BE OTHER WAYS. TO
EXPAND THE HAN CREW- CAPACITY.
FOR THE STATE WHETHER THAT'S
EXPANDING ON SOME OF THESE
OTHER OPTIONS THAT WE'VE USED
IN THE PAST- OR WHETHER LOOKING
FOR ADDITIONAL OPTION FOR
EXAMPLE WORKING WITH LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS- LASTLY THIS IS
REALLY MORE OF A MINOR
TECHNICAL ISSUE BUT- WHEN I
MAKE SURE THAT CAN BE THE WHERE
THERE IS A SMALL VERY SMALL
PART OF. THIS PROPOSAL ABOUT A
HALF A MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
FOR CALIFORNIA TO WORK WITH CAL
HR. UNDERTAKE A STUDY TO
DETERMINE IF THERE SHOULD BE A
NEW CLASSIFICATION CREATED FOR
THE CALIFORNIA- HAND CREWS SO
RATHER THAN USING FIREFIGHTER
ONES IN THE FUTURE. WOULD THERE
BE A NEW CLASSIFICATION THAT
MIGHT MAKE SENSE TO YOU GIVEN
THAT THERE WOULD BE SOME
DIFFERENT RESPONSIBILITIES
WORKING ON THE HAN CREW
RELATIVE TO. HOW YOU NORMALLY
USE FIREFIGHTER ONES- WE THINK
UNDERTAKEN THAT KIND OF
EVALUATION MAKE. SENSE IF YOU
PROCEED WITH THIS. THE PROPOSAL
FROM THE MID- WE JUST HAVE KIND
OF TECHNICAL. ABOUT WHAT THE
RIGHT- AMOUNT OF FUNDING TO
PROVIDE FOR THAT WORKLOAD IS
WE'RE STILL AWAITING SOME
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION- WE- ARE
UNDERSTANDING THAT TYPICALLY
THIS WOULD BE WORKLOAD. THAT
CALLIE TARGET UNDERTAKE WITH
EXISTING RESOURCES SO THAT'S
SOMETHING. YOU MAY WANT TO ASK
THE DEPARTMENT ABOUT OR WE CAN
FOLLOW UP WITH COMEDIANS WE
LEARN MORE. YEAH THAT WAS GOOD
POINT WE WANT WE WANT TO GET TO
THAT I GUESS I'D LIKE TO START
OFF. WE KNOW THAT WE'VE GOT TO
THEIR PRISON POPULATIONS BEEN
RELOCATED A LOT OF THOSE PEOPLE
ARE IN COUNTY. A LOT OF THOSE
PEOPLE. HAVE WORKED EIGHT
SEASONS IN THE FIRE CREW THEY
DIDN'T JUST. DROP OFF THE FACE
OF THE EARTH HAVE WE DONE ANY
EFFORT HAS THERE BEEN ANY
EFFORT THIS TO REAL THOSE
PEOPLE AND TO CREATE THE- HAN
CREW. FOR PURPOSES OF THIS
DISCUSSION FORMERLY
INCARCERATED PEOPLE RIGHT THAT
WE CAN WORK NINE NINE MONTHS SO
THAT'S SORT OF THE- THE FIRST.
BIT THEN THE SECOND IS HAVE WE
CONTACTED COUNTIES WE CONTACTED
THE COUNTIES AND THAT ARE NOW
HOLDING PEOPLE FOR TWO THREE
YEARS. AND IT'S A LITTLE BIT
MORE WORK WITH THAT COUNTY.
JAILER BUT HOW HAVE E
EXHAUSTED DEAD OF GETTING THAT
POPULATION IN. MY THIRD TRYING
TO OF PEOPLE A- COLLEGE
STUDENTS YOU KNOW IN. A NINE
MONTH. PER GIG WITH THE WITH
WITH THE CCC'S WITH THE FIRE
SERVICE MAYBE SOMETHING THAT
THAT YOUNG PEOPLE WANT TO DO
THAT ONE AT TAT. YEAH THERE WE
READ ABOUT HOW MUCH THEY CARE
ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE AND THEY
WANT TO DO SOMETHING AND
THERE'S A THERE'S NOTHING LIKE
IT NINE. NINE MONTHS AND THE
FIRE CREW TO SAY WE'RE GOING TO
BE. A PART OF THAT SO I GUESS.
BECAUSE. THE DEPUTY. TYLER E.
INDICATED THAT THERE WERE
TWENTY EIGHT HAND CREWS THAT
ARE. NOT COMPLETELY A CERTIFIED
BECAUSE SOME PEOPLE HAVE
DROPPED OUT AND THEY'RE NOT
THERE HOW IS IT THAT WE CAN
MAKE THOSE FALL FOR THAT. POST
CODE BUT WE CAN GET THERE THE
NUMBERS UP BUT HOW ABOUT IT'S A
CHEAPER AND IT YOU KNOW IT'S A
HEN CORRODED IT MAY BE MORE
EQUALLY AS EFFECTIVE AND GIVE
SOME YOUNG PEOPLE AN
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU SENATOR
REID CASKEY HAS SPECIFICALLY
TO- THE TWENTY EIGHT HAND CREWS
ARE NOT FULLY STAFFED TWENTY
SEVEN OF THE TWENTY EIGHT HAND
CREWS. ARE STAFFED BY ADULT
MALE INMATES- SO- IT IS REALLY
GOING TO DEPEND ON THE-
PIPELINE- ELIGIBLE ADULT MALE
INMATES FIREFIGHTERS TO BE ABLE
TO BOLSTER THOSE CREWS OUR ONLY
OTHER OPTION IS TO BEGIN
FURTHER CONSOLIDATION OF THOSE
CREWS. TO BRING THEM UP ABOVE A
MINIMUM STANDARD OF TWELVE
MEMBERS ON THAT GROUP. TO MAKE
IT YPE ONE TRUE TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE THEM FULLY FUNCTIONAL. BUT
AT THIS POINT HAVING ONLY FIFTY
THREE FIVE ONE TREES ACROSS THE
STATE WERE TRYING TO HOLD ON TO
THE TWENTY EIGHT KEEP THE LOCAL
FOR LOCAL RESPONSE SO THE
OPTIONS YOU MIX THEM WITH.
OTHER TYPES OF THREE MEMBERS IS
NOT AN OPTION IN- THE
INSTITUTIONAL. CORRECTIONAL
ENVIRONMENT AS IT RELATES TO
OTHER POORLY PROGRAM THAT WE
TALKED ABOUT- THE VENTURA
TRAINING CENTER IS- A PROGRAMS
DESIGNED. TO ALLOW THE FOR
LEASE- COMPETITIVE-
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ENTRY LEVEL
JOBS AND FIRE SERVICE AND
CERTAINLY- THEY HAVE BEEN
COMPETITIVE AND THOUGH I DO NOT
HAVE STATS IN FRONT OF ME- THEY
HAVE APPLIED FOR SOME HAVE
APPLIED FOR AND RECEIVED
SEASONAL FOR BETTER JOBS WITH
CAL FIRE WHICH IS ONE OF THE
GOALS OF THE PROGRAM- TO BE
ABLE TO EXPAND THAT PROGRAM
WERE. CONTINUING TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH OUR-
PARTNERS. IN THAT ARENA BUT I.
HAVE NOT DEVELOPED THAT FURTHER.
SPECIFICALLY IT COULD ABOUT TO.
HIST SEA FAR WAS A- SHORT
SEASON AND EVEN MYSELF IN THE
EARLY NINETIES OF- BEING ABLE
TO GO TO SCHOOL DURING THE
WINTER AND FIGHT FIRE DURING
THE SUMMER- TO GAIN MY
EDUCATION THAT WERE ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA NOW WE'RE THE FIRE
SEASON ISN'T THAT TYPICAL- JUNE
TO OCTOBER- BUT RATHER WE'RE
WE'RE GOING INTO DECEMBER MUCH
OF WHERE THE COLLEGE STUDENTS.
I WILL NEED TO RETURN TO SCHOOL
IN THEIR BY DOWN STAFF WHOSE-
BUT CERTAINLY- IT HAS BEEN A
STRONG PART OF OUR SEASON. OKAY
I JUST I KNOW THAT THE PAROLE.
FOUR DON'T TALK TO THE
PROBATION PEOPLE BECAUSE ONCE
THAN A FELONY ONE TENDS TO
MISTER METER AND WE SORT OF
MERGE THEM TOGETHER AND I'M NOT
EXPECTING KALIFORNIA CCC'S TO
FIGURE OUT THAT BUT IT'S A IT'S
AN ARTTHERE THERE IS THE
POPULATION IS STILL HERE IN THE
CITY CALIFORNIA WE JUST DON'T
KNOW WHERE THEREAFTER IT'S NOT
CONVENIENTLY SITTING AT ONE
PENAL INSTITUTION AND IT SEEMS
AS THOUGH THESE PEOPLE HAVE
DONE A SERVICE TO CALIFORNIA.
EVERYBODY WANTS TO GIVE PEOPLE
A SECOND CHANCE IN THIS JUST
SOMEHOW IF I WERE GONNA SPEND
MONEY WITH HR WITH FIND OUT
WHERE THESE PEOPLE ARE SOME OF
THESE PEOPLE I WOULD IMAGINE
THE BEEN ON THESE CRUISE FOR
SEVEN YEARS AND NOW THEY'VE
BEEN RELEASED AND THEY'RE STILL
A VALUABLE ASSET TO US. WHO WHO
TO CENTER MCGUIRE HERE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU SO MUCH
RICHER UNDERSTANDING THAT WE
ARE TALKING PERSONNEL ALL FOCUS
TO COMMENT. ON ISSUE NINETEEN.
IN AND WANT TO SAY FIRST AND
FOREMOST THANK YOU- TO CHIEF
PORTER IN THE ENTIRE CALFIRE
TEAM FOR PAINTING THIS ALONG
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION. LOOK
AT ALL THIS WEEK SOME QUICK
COMMENTS IN AND LOOK FOR A
RESPONSE FROM COUNT FOR. THAT
SINCE GOVERNOR'S MISTAKEN
OFFICE- IN THE NINETIES TEN
YEAR. HIS FOCUS ON WILDFIRE
PREVENTION AND RESPONSE HE'S
SHOWN UP AND BEEN ACTIVE IN
ENGAGING THE COMMUNITIES THAT
HAVE BEEN HIT BY WILDFIRE. AND
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THE STATE IS
FACING UNPARALLELED CHALLENGES
RELATED TO WILDFIRES IN
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS. HAVE
THEIR LIVELIHOODS AT RISK. AND
WHILE CALIFORNIA IS THE GOLD
STANDARD FOR FIRE FIGHTING
FORCES IN THE UNITED STATES AND
ACROSS THE WORLD. THEY'RE
UNDERSTAFFED. AND THEY CONTINUE
TO BE UNDERSTAFFED. AND I
BELIEVE THAT THIS PROPOSAL.
THAT'S IN FRONT OF US NEEDS
ENHANCEMENT. AND HE FUNDING FOR
PERSONNEL. HAND CREWS IN
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT CREWS IN
FULL TIME FIREFIGHTERS ALONG
WITH TRAINING PROGRAMS. TO GET
FOLKS INTO AT THE VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT AND FIRE SERVICE I
ALSO BELIEVE IN ALL- FOCUS THIS
IN A BIT. THAT WE NEED A MODERN
DAY PERMANENT VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT PLAN BY THE WAY
CHAIR WHITE HOUSE SKI HAS BEEN
ADVOCATING FOR THIS FOR SEVERAL
YEARS ON HOW WE INVEST MORE IN
PREVENTIVE. HERE'S MY CONCERN.
INMATE CREWS. THERE'S
APPROXIMATELY. FOURTEEN HUNDRED
FOURTEEN HUNDRED TWENTY
REMAINING DOWN BY FIFTEEN
HUNDRED FROM JUST OVER A YEAR
AGO. WE'RE DOWN FORTY TWO
HUNDRED INMATES ACCORDING TO
CDC. WHO WERE ON ENEMY CREW
FROM OVER A DECADE AGO. THIS
YEAR AKAU FIGHTER THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING SIX
HUNDRED SEVENTEEN POSITIONS
SIXTEEN SEASON CAUGHT FIRE
CREWS SIX SEASONAL CCC CREWS IN
EIGHT YEAR ROUND CCC CREWS.
IT'S NOT ADEQUATE IN WHY WE
WOULD BE LOOKING AT JUST EIGHT
YEAR ROUND CCC CREWS WHEN THESE
CREWS CAN DO A LOT OF THE WORK
FOR MUCH LESS THAN THE PRICE I
I'M NOT QUITE SURE I'D LIKE TO
GET INTO THE FIREFIGHTING PEACE
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WE ASK
FOR THIRTY ONE CAL FIRE FIRE
ENGINES. ADMINISTRATION ONLY
WANTED TO DO THIRTEEN AND BRING
ON HUNDRED THIRTY ONE FULL TIME
POSITIONS. THOSE THIRTY ONE
FIRE ENGINES BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WOULD HAVE
ADVANCED BETWEEN THREE HUNDRED
THREE EARNED FIFTY FULL TIME
FIREFIGHTERS. LAST YEAR TWO
HUNDRED NINETY FOUR FULL TIME
FIREFIGHTERS THAT WERE BROUGHT
ON. BUT THE ADMINISTRATION
WANTED TO BE A LOOK IT OVER FOR
OUR EXITING OVER FIVE HUNDRED
WHY THE TWO HUNDRED SIXTY ONE.
AT THAT WERE PROPOSED AT FOR
LAST YEAR BUT WE LOOKING AT
YOUR TO YOUR FUNDING ISN'T
BEING BROUGHT FORWARD THIS YEAR
I'M NOT QUITE SURE BECAUSE THE
REASON FOR THE OVER FIVE
HUNDRED FULL TIME FIREFIGHTERS
ARE BEING. ASKED FOR LAST YEAR
WAS REDUCED FATIGUE BUT TO BE
ABLE TO REDUCE THE NEED FOR
OVERTIME AND I JUST DON'T KNOW
WHAT HAPPENED TO THAT POINT.
THE LAST THING I WANT TO SAY IS
WE SAY THAT WE'RE RELYING
NATIONAL GUARD. DAHLE NATIONAL
GUARD COMES IN AFTER ALL HELL'S
BROKEN LOOSE IN COMMUNITIES
HAVE BEEN BURNED DOWN. AND I
GOTTA TELL YOU I SEEN THIS
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN. I'M
TIRED. AND I'D LIKE TO BE A TO
SEE A BUDGET THAT IS ACTUALLY
GOING TO BE MODERN DAY AND BE
ABLE TO COMBAT BOTH THE FIRE
PREVENTION AS WELL AS A FIRE
PRESENT THAT RESPONSE IT IS
NEEDED FUTURE I WENT ON A
LITTLE LONG I APOLOGIZE- BUT
THOSE ARE MY CONCERNS ON WHY I
BELIEVE WE NEED ENHANCE BUDGET
THIS YEAR. FOR PREVENTION
RESPONSE VERY QUICKLY CENTER
DOLLY I JUST WANT TO ADD TO
COMMONSENSE AND REQUIRE. LOOK
WE HAVE TO FOCUS ON PUTTING
FIRES OUT THAT ARE. A THREAT.
BUT WE ALSO NEED TO FOCUS ON.
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT LOOK WE
ARE NEVER GOING TO GET OUT OF
THE CYCLE. INTEL WE DO
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT AND DO IT
AGGRESSIVELY AND THAT MEET IN
MY MIND ITS CONTRACTORS.
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS BECAUSE
WE DO NOT HAVE THE WORKFORCE.
WITH STATE EMPLOYEES TO BE ABLE
TO DO THE WORK THAT WE NEED TO
BE THEY NEED TO GET DONE OUT
THERE. AND ON TOP OF THAT WE
NEED TO BE PARTNERING WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. BECAUSE A
LARGE PORTION OF THE LANDS IN
CALIFORNIA OUR- ARE. OWNED BY
THEM AND THEY IN THERE'S A
THERE'S A HUGE NEXUS BETWEEN
WILDLAND FIRE FORCED AND GIVEN
IT OR A SORRY SO IT'S GOTTA BE
A OF A JOINT VENTURE WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. TO MAKE
THIS WORK. WELL WITH THAT WE
WILL HOLD ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN-
WE DO HAVE SIXTEEN AGENCIES OR
DEPARTMENTS OR- ENTITIES THERE
NOW ON ITEM NUMBER TWENTY WE
COULD INVITE THE PRIVATE SECTOR
MAKE IT SEVENTEEN GROUPS BUT
WE'LL JUST. KEEP IT AT THE
SIXTEEN THAT WE HAVE- THIS IS
ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY THIS IS THE
TWENTY MILLION. ACRES THAT ARE.
IN THE THREAT OF FORCE FIRE AND
WE HAVE A PROPOSAL TO TAKE CARE
FOR PORTION OF THOSE SO. WHO IS
GOING TO START OFF WORD. LET'S
HAVE A RESOURCE AGENCY OF MISS
MORSE BURMESTER ON. THE SYSTEM
CASH SECRETARY. IN THE MORNING
AND THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HAVING US TODAY GOOD MORNING
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS AND THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR ALL OF YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON WORKING ON THIS
WILDFIRE CRISIS WHEN ASKED WE
AGREED THAT PREVENTION IS
CRITICAL TO BEING ABLE TO GET
AHEAD OF THE CURVE. OUR WELFARE
CRISIS IN CALIFORNIA IS A MULTI
GENERATIONAL CRISIS IN THE
MAKING AND WE HAVE LESS THAN A
GENERATION TO SOLVE INTEREST
YEARS TO BE ABLE TO GET AHEAD
OF THE CURVE AND GUESTS TO
STATE OF WILDFIRE RESILIENCE IN
CALIFORNIA I'D LIKE TO TAKE A
FEW MINUTES BECAUSE THIS IS
SUCH A LARGE PROPOSAL SHE WILL
GIVE US A LITTLE BIT OF A
FOUNDATION IN- WE'RE WE STAND
RIGHT NOW AS A STATE IN THE
FIRE CRISIS. YOU TALK ABOUT THE
STRATEGIC FRAMEWORK FOR WHICH
WE ARE DECIDING WHAT TO FIND
HOW TO FIND IT AND MOVE FORWARD
TO ACHIEVE HIGHER RESILIENCE IN
CALIFORNIA AND THEN REALLY
DIVING IN ON THE ISSUES WITH IN
THIS BUDGET THAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT TO BE ABLE TO RAMP UP AND
SCALE UP OUR AFFECTED NETWORKS-
ON A WILD. RESILIENCE SO I
HAVE- SOME SLIDES AND I'M GONNA
pLIKE I CAN'T SO I WILL JUST-
TALK THROUGH AT LEAST AT
CHALLENGES SO THIS LAST YEAR IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE FIVE OF THE
SIX LARGEST FIRES IN THE STATE
BURNING SIMULTANEOUSLY AND-
AND- WE HAD TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE DISPLACED WE
HAD TOXIC SMOKE- ACROSS
CALIFORNIA FOR WEEKS IMPACTING.
PEOPLE'S HEALTH. AND THIS IS A-
INCREASE FROM WE'VE SEEN IN
PREVIOUS. HE QUICKLY SEGMENT IN
TWENTY. PREDICTED THAT WE WOULD
SEE 18% 77% INCREASE IN
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRE- BY THE
END OFTHE CENTURY 77% INCREASE
IN ANNUAL ACRES BURNED. THIS
LAST YEAR WE HAD FOUR POINT TWO
MILLION ACRES BURNED IN TWENTY
NINETEEN WE HAD TWO HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SEVEN. THOUSAND ACRES
BURN THAT'S A 15100% INCREASE
IN ONE FIRE SEASON ALONE AT
FOUR FOLD INCREASE OVER OUR
ANNUAL AVERAGE OUT BEFORE THIS
YEAR. AND SO WHAT WE'RE SEEING
IS THAT THE PREDICTIONS OF THE
CRIME AB PLANET REDUCTIONS THAT
WE ANTICIPATED AT THE END OF
THE CENTURY OUR RIGHTS EIGHTY
YEARS EARLY. WHICH MEANS OUR
ACTION HAS TO BE FAST. SWIFT
AND STRATEGIC. WE KNOW THAT CAL.
HAS HAD TYPICALLY H. ED IN MOST
OF CALIFORNIA IS A FIRE ADAPTED
A COLICKY TRIBES MANAGED AB
CHOIR THROUGHOUT THE STATE FOR
MILLENNIA. I'M COLONIZATION
SUPPRESS THOSE PRACTICES GOLD
RUSH ERA CLEAR CUTTING REMOVED
ABOUT 97% OF THE OLD GROWTH ARE
FORCED HER BACK OVERLY DENSE.
THE POLITICS OF THE EARLY TURN
OF THE CENTURY FORCED THE
CONSERVATION MOVEMENT TO
PRESENT THE U. S. FOREST
SERVICE AT THE FIRE SUPPRESSION
ENTITY. SETTING UP TO REMOVE
THE NATURAL OF FIRE ON
CALIFORNIA'S ECOLOGY AND WHAT'S
HAPPENED IS THAT NOW WE HAVE
OUR NATURAL FIRE RETURN
INTERVALS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
ARE OFF. SO BAD NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND STOP FIRED AFTER
THE COLLEGES WHICH LIKE TO SEE
FIRE EVERY FIFTEEN. TO TWENTY
YEARS ARE GETTING FIRES- EVERY
HUNDRED YEARS CREATING
INCREDIBLY HIGH SEVERITY BURN
DEVASTATING ECOSYSTEMS AND
WILDLIFE. I'M CENTER CAP OR A
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA CHAPARRAL
ECOSYSTEMS FOR EXAMPLE PREFERS
THE FIRE EVERY SIXTY FIVE TWO
HUNDRED YEARS NURSING EVERY
FIFTEEN YEARS WHAT THIS IS
LEADING TO ITS VEGETATION TYPE
CONVERSION. WE ARE LOSING OUR
CHAPARRAL ECOSYSTEMS TO
INVASIVE GRASSES WE'RE LOSING
CONNOR FOR FORCED YOU CHAPARRAL
AND SO WE ARE SEEING A SHIFT.
THIS IS NOT ONLY A LOSS OF
HABITAT AND BIODIVERSITY IT'S
CAUSING CASCADING CLIMATE
IMPACTS- WE ARE LOSING OUR
WATERSHED. WE ARE SEEING
CATASTROPHIC MUDSLIDES OFTEN
THESE FIRES AND WHAT'S
pTHESE FIRES ARE PART OF
CASCADING CLIMATE EVENTS
THEMSELVES. FOR EXAMPLE WE HAD
A ONE THOUSAND YEAR DROUGHTS
FROM TWENTY TWELVE TO TWENTY
FIFTEEN IN CALIFORNIA THAT
STRESS THESE OVERLY DENSE
FOREST AND EDUCATION WRIT
LARGE. LEADING TO INTENSE OF
TREE MORTALITY HUNDRED SIXTY
SEVEN MILLION TREES DIED
DROUGHT- THE STATE DURING THIS
EPISODE OF TREE MORTALITY THOSE
TREES HAD BEEN STANDING. THERE
NOW ON THE GROUNDS AND THEY ARE
CREATING THE FUEL LOAD- FOR US
ROUTE THE STATE. AND SO THESE
FIRE THAT HAPPENED WE FIRE
PREDICTIVE MODEL THAT INTO%
ABOUT THREE INCH DIAMETER WERE.
TRAINING IF YOU'LL DRIVEN FIRE
INDUSTRY OR TELL AREA. HERE NOW
HAVE THIRTY DI<c.cyan> WOULD. THESE</c>
FIRES WHICH IS. HI WHAT PRINT
THROUGHOUT THE FLIGHT CLOSING
WHY EVENTS FROM THE SPY LED TO
CREEK FOR. CREATED A YOU CLOUD
THAT WOULD. I WASN'T INTO THE
APPS. WHICH COLOR ON. PUTTING
HURRICANE WIND. OUT IN EVERY
DIRECTION ON THAT FIRE RATHER
THAN JUST HAVING ONE WIND
DRIVEN FRONT AND A WHITE IT
CREATES A REALLY DYNAMIC AND
DIFFICULT TO MANAGE AND
MITIGATE FIRES. QUESTION IS HOW
DO WE ARRESTED THESE CASCADING
CLIMATE EVENTS- FROM THE TOXIC
SMOKE THAT'S COMING OUT OF THIS
PROBLEM AND WE- NEED MUDSLIDES
FROM HEAT DAMAGE TO OUR
WATERSHED THE DAMAGED OR
HABITAT AND MOST IMPORTANTLY.
THE DEVASTATION TO OUR
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES. AND
THERE ARE REALLY THREE FRANK Q.
ADDRESSING WILDFIRE RESILIENCE
IN CALIFORNIA AND OFTEN I HEAR
PEOPLE TALKING ABOUT THESE I
STAND ALONE BUT HE REALLY NEEDS
TO BE ADDRESSED IN EVERY
COMMUNITY. ALL THREE OF THESE
FRONTS SIMULTANEOUSLY AT
DIFFERENT RATIOS FOR DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES. THREE FIRE
RESILIENT FRONT- EVEN THEM AS
CAN CIRCLES THEY ARE ON THE
INNERMOST CIRCLE IT WOULD BE
HARD HOMES AND COMMUNITIES THIS
IS THE WORST. YOU HAVE
DEFENSIBLE SPACE AND RETROFITS
ON YOUR HOME SO THAT HOMES AND
COMMUNITIES CAN SURVIVE THE
NEXT AREA WOULD BE THE WILDLAND
URBAN INTERFACE THIS IS WHERE
WE PUT STRATEGIC FUEL BREAKS
AROUND IN COMMUNITIES. TO BE
ABLE TO R. RANCHO WIRE AND
CREATE A STATE ROUTE. FOR THESE
CATASTROPHIC FIRES AND SO THE
STRATEGIC FUEL BREAKS ARE
CRUCIAL TO BEING ABLE TO ENSURE
THAT WE CAN STOP BY YOUR FROM
COMING INTO A COMMUNITY AND
THAT COMMUNITIES CAN ESCAPE- IF
A FIRE IS COMING THROUGH. AND
THE LAST AREA IT'S REALLY THE
ENTIRE WILD PLANTS ENSURING
THAT OUR ECOLOGIES ARE RESTORED
TO THEIR NATURAL GAIL AND
LEVELS OF BUYER THAT'S NEEDED
SO THIS IS RESTORING FORESTED
WATERSHEDS MEANING OUT-
UNDERGROWTH UNDERGROWTH DOING
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT- IT
CHAPARRAL ECOSYSTEM. WHERE
RESTORING CHAPARRAL FROM NATIVE
GRASSES BECAUSE THERE ARE MORE
FIRE RESILIENT THAN THE NATIVE
GRASSES AND THEY NEED MASON
GRASSES EXCUSE ME AND SO AN
INSURING THAT WE HAD A HEALTHY
LANDSCAPES THAT ARE HAVING
THEIR WARM FIRE INTENSITY AND
THEIR NORMAL FIRE. RETURN
INTERVALS WILL REDUCE THE
INTENSITY OF THE FIRES THAT WE
ARE SEEING YOUR TEACHER YOUR
BRAKES WILL ALLOW FIREFIGHTERS
TO TAKE A STAND AND COMMUNITIES
TO ESCAPE AND HARDEN HOMES WILL
ALLOW COMMUNITIES TO SURVIVE IN
THE WORST. CASE THAT A FIRE
COMES THROUGH. THERE ARE ALSO
WE COURT. YOU KNOW WHEN WE ARE
LOOKING IN OF THE FROM. WE ALSO
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
AT BESTING IN A WAVE EXTRA. AND
IT SOME OF THE BAY AREA THAT
HAVE BEEN IN. OUR CAPACITY TO
SCALE UP BY A RESILIENT IN THE
STATE. CORE PRINCIPLES AND
THREE BARRIERS THAT WE'RE
ADDRESSING THE CORE PRINCIPLES
ARE REALLY FOCUSING ON THE
REGIONAL APPROACH BECAUSE THERE
REALLY ARE SOME FIRE RESILIENCE
ARE GONNA REQUIRE DIFFERENT
RATIOS IN DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES. BASED ON THE
TOPOGRAPHY THE DENSITY OF HOMES
THE COMMUNITIES SURROUNDING
ECOLOGY AND SO WE'RE REALLY
ZEROING IN ON ENSURING THAT OUR
RESOURCES ARE BEING DRIVEN AND
DESIGNED. BY WHAT COMMUNITIES
NEED AND THAT THEY HAVE THE
TOOLS TO BE ABLE TO CREATE
REGIONAL DESIGN PROGRAMS AND
THAT ARE GRANT CAN ACTUALLY
COME INTO YOU AND DELIVER. FOR
THOSE COMMUNITIES A COLLECTIVE
VISION THAT IS BASED ON LOCAL
SCIENCE. THE OTHER PRINCIPAL
WAS REALLY ENSURING THAT WE ARE
BASING THIS ON ADAPTIVE
MANAGEMENT AND SCIENCE SCIENCE
BASED MANAGEMENT. TO ENSURE
THAT. WE ARE HAVING- A AT THE
END THAT WE ARE. UNDER AND
ADAPTING THE RE. OF THE SHIPS
AND CLIMATE CHANGE FOR EXAMPLE
YOU KNOW INTERESTING REQUIRE. A
PREDICTIVE MODELS YOU TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THESE STANDING DEAD
TREES- ON THE GROUNDS AND
UPDATE THOSE YOUR MODELS BUT
THAT REQUIRES RESEARCH DATA
ANALYTICS AND ADAPTIVE
MANAGEMENT TECHNIQUES AND SO
THAT'S THOROUGHLY INCORPORATED.
INTO THIS FUNDING AS WELL TO
ENSURE THAT THE STEPS WE ARE
TAKING ARE NOT GOING TO HAVE
SECONDARY AN UNFORESEEN
NEGATIVE ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS.
AND THAT WE ARE TAKING STEPS
THAT ARE BUILDING UP TOWARDS
FIRE RESILIENT OR THE NEXT
GENERATIONS TO COME. RATHER
THAN JUST THE IMMEDIATE FIRE
SEASON. IN ADDITION TO BEING
PRICE OR WHAT BE CLEAR AT LEAST
ALL HAVE REALLY TO- AND-
RESULTS. WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
IT'S LASTING AS WELL. WE WERE
GOING TO BE FOCUSING ON AND
INVESTING IN. AREAS THAT WILL
ALLOW US TO SCALE UP MORE
QUICKLY AREAS THAT WE HAVE BEEN
SEEN- GAS SHORTAGES THAT WE CAN
PUT AN INFUSION OF RESOURCES.
TO BE ABLE TO CREATE A STRONGER
FOUNDATION OR SCALING UP OUR
IMPACT SO THE FIRST ONE IS
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT. WE HAVE
BEEN SEEING PEOPLE. COMPETING
FOR THE SAME WORKERS ON THE
GROUND FOR THESE PROJECTS AND
SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
ACROSS THE SECTOR. THAT WE HAVE
A WELL TRAINED AND FUNDED
WORKFORCE READY TO DO THIS WORK
AND GET OUT ON THE GROUND-
ANOTHER AREA IS SMALL BUSINESS
DEVELOPMENT. WE HAVE BEEN
SEEING EVEN HIRING CONTRACTORS
WERE SEEING A LACK OF ACCESS TO
CAPITAL AND CAPITAL EQUIPMENT.
IN THIS SECTOR SO ENSURING THAT
WE HAVE BUSINESSES THAT CAN
STEP IN AND- AND GET. ON THE
GROUND IN MORE TRADITIONAL
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT TOOLS.
ALSO SMALL BUSINESSES STARTING
UP AROUND THE QUESTION OF WHAT
DO YOU DO WITH WHAT HE BY A
MASKED COMING OUT OF THE
SPENDING AND FUEL REDUCTION
PROJECTS. INSURE THAT WE HAVE
TOOLS TO TURN THAT INTO.
GASIFICATION BIO DIESEL
REPLACEMENT THAT WE'RE
INVESTING IN INNOVATION I CAN
ACTUALLY SEE BUSINESSES START
UP AROUND THE SECTOR. AND THEN
THE LAST AREA IS REALLY LOOKING
AT PERMIT AND REGULATORY
EFFICIENCIES. MOST OF THE
PROJECTS THAT WE ARE DOING- IN
THIS SECTOR REALLY HAVE DOUBLE
ECOLOGICAL BENEFITS ON TOP OF
THE PUBLIC SAFETY RETURNS. THAT
THEY GIVE US AND SO MOST OF
THIS IS REALLY POSITIVE. FOR
OUR ECOLOGY AND OUR ENVIRONMENT
AND SO THEREFORE WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THESE ARE DNE.
THAT WISELY BUT THAT WE ARE
REALLY NOT CREATING
BUREAUCRATIC LOADS ON THAT SO
WE'VE ALSO INVESTED IN. HEALING
UP REGULATORY EFFICIENCIES SO
THAT WE CAN GET PEOPLE WORKING
ON THE GROUND TO RESTORE. OUR
ENVIRONMENT FASTER. THE WHAT DO
FOR A FEW MINUTES- WHAT WHAT'S
ACTUALLY N BY AND WHERE WE-
OUT OF THIS STRATEGIC FOR. OF
INVESTING IN COMMUNITY HARD ST
FUEL BREAKS AND ALLOW. AND
THOSE. FOUNDATION AREAS I MEANT
AS WELL. SO THIS BILLION DOLLAR
FRAMEWORK HAS THREE HUNDRED
TWENTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN
EARLY ACTION FUNDING AND THESE
GOES TOWARDS PROGRAMS THAT ARE
READY TO LAUNCH NOW. AND WE'LL
BY ASKING EXTRA SEASON FIRE
PROTECTION SO MOST OF THESE
PROJECTS TAKING HERE SOME
TEACHING OKAY IF WE START IN
THE SPRING. RATHER THAN IN THE
FALL- AS A NORMAL BUDGET CYCLE
WOULD. BY FIRE PROTECTION. IN
IN THE FOLLOWING SPRING WHICH
MEANS WE BUY EXTRA SEASON OF
FIRE PROTECTION OUT OF THOSE
DOLLARS. WANTED SO WE REALLY
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THESE
ARE GOING TOWARDS ACTIVITIES
THAT NEED TO START NOW- AND
THAT WILL ADDRESS SOME OF THE
STRATEGIC BARRIERS AS WELL- THE
REMAINING BUDGET IS IN. BUDGET
YEAR AND WE'VE ANTICIPATED
PUTTING ON WE ARE REQUESTING A
LONGER SPENDING WINDOW ON
THOSE. THAT PROJECTS CAN REALLY
GO START TO FINISH WITH THOSE
DOLLARS- YOU KNOW FOR EXAMPLE
OR SEEN PROJECTS- GET FUNDED IN
PHASES OFTEN MEETINGS THREE
YEARS BETWEEN GRANT. TO BE ABLE
TO GET THE NEXT PHASE OF THE
PROJECT DONE WHICH MEANS WE END
UP WITH THE PATCHWORK ASPIRES
MILLIONS ON THE LANDSCAPE WHICH
CAME INTO PLAY THIS FIRE
SEASON. YOU KNOW SHE FIRE FOR
EXAMPLE THERE'S A PROJECT-
PUNDITS SCARED ABOUT IT
CONSERVANCY IN CALIFORNIA. THAT
HAD AS ONE HAD BEEN COMPLETED
THE ASHY FIREBURNED AN
ECOLOGICAL HEALTHY LEVEL THE
STREETS ARE STANDING THE HOMES
REMAINS- BUT THE AREAS THAT
WORK BASED HUMAN BREAKING- WAS
A CATASTROPHIC FIRE HOMES WERE
LOST AND ECOLOGY. ALSO I'M
DEVASTATED IN THOSE AREAS AND
SO WERE REALLY ONCE YOU. PUT
THESE INVESTMENTS INTO A LONGER
SPENDING WINDOW TO BE ABLE TO
START AND FINISH PROJECTS
COMPLETELY- SHOULD BE ABLE TO
ACHIEVE THAT DEEPER REQUIRE
RESILIENCE. SO IT WHEN MONDAY-
A FIVE HUNDRED TWELVE MILLION
THAT'LL SCALE RESEARCH AREA AND
WE HAVE FUNDING ACROSS STREET
REMEMBER LANDSCAPE WIDELY URBAN
IN AND COMMUNITY HIGH. SO YES
INCLUDE ONE ACROSS OWNERSHIP
BECAUSE OUR ARE NOT AND
JURISTIC BOUNDS AND SO I STRESS
NEED TO IN THAT LAND IS
INCLUDED WE THIS YEAR SIGNED A
SHARED STOREKEEPER GREEN MET
WITH THE U. S. FOREST SERVICE
WHO OWNS 57% OF CALIFORNIANS
FORCED IN WILD LANDS AND WE
WANT TO ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE
COMMITTED TO TREAT FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ACRES A YEAR- AND TO
SCALE UP TO THAT BY TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. WE HAVE ALSO MATCH
THAT COMMITMENT TREATING FIVE
HUNDRED EIGHT THOUSAND ACRES A
YEAR THIS IS A NUMBER THAT
COMES FROM THE POOREST CARBON
PLAN OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN IN THIS
BUDGET WILL ENABLE US TO BE
ABLE TO REACH THAT COLLECTIVE
TARGET- OR TO REACH THE STATE.
I HUNDRED MILLION FIVE THOUSAND
EIGHT. BY- TO TWENTY SO IT
ALLOWS US RESET TO YEARS OR-
AND- WHAT WE'RE SEEING IS-
INVESTMENTS ACROSS LAND
OWNERSHIP TYPES OF STATE ON
LANDS TRIBAL FUNDING AND SMALL
FAMILY LANDOWNERS AND PRIVATE
LANDS. SO THE STATE OWNED LANDS
THAT THE STATE OWNED ABOUT
THREE MILLION ACRES WHICH IS
ABOUT 3% OF. OUR LAND OWNERSHIP
IN THE CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
EIGHTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
PROPOSED IN THIS BUDGET FOR
STATE PARKS TO BE ABLE TO RAMP
UP FROM TREATING. TWO THOUSAND
ACRES HERE TO TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND ACRES YEAR WE HAVE A
FORTY FIVE MINUTE THAT MILLION
DOLLARS IDENTIFIED FOR
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE. SO THEY CAN SCALE UP
TO TREAT ABOUT FIFTEEN THOUSAND
ACRES A YEAR THE PARTS IN
QUESTION WILDLIFE BY THE WAY
THIS YEAR LOST ABOUT A HUNDRED
FORTY THOUSAND ACRES. IN THE
FIRES IN TWENTY TWENTY AND THE
STATE ROOMS ARE SET ASIDE
BECAUSE THEY ARE RARE
ECOSYSTEMS AND SOME CRITICAL
HABITAT AND SO WE WANT TO
ENSURE. THAT WE ARE CURRENTLY
INVESTING IN A FIRE RESILIENCE
ON STATE OWNED LANDS SO THAT
THESE PLANTS CAN'T INDOOR AND
WE ARE ALSO SETTING A HIGH
STANDARD. I'M IN THE STATE ONLY
CATEGORY WERE ALSO INVESTING
TWELVE MILLION DOLLARS-
PROPOSING TWELVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE TAHOE
CONSERVANCY. THEY OWN SIXTY
FIVE HUNDRED PLOTS AROUND THE
TAHOE COMMUNITY AND SOME ANTI
IN NEIGHBORHOODS AND SO WE WANT
TO ENSURE THAT THEY AVE
RESOURCES TO FULLY TREAT- THAT
LANDHOLDING TO BE ABLE TO
ENSURE SAFETY AND- RESILIENCE
AROUND LAKE TAHOE. AND THE
TWELVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
STATE LANDS COMMISSION THOSE
PLANS HAVE BEEN SET ASIDE BUT-
THEY HAVE NOT BEEN ACTIVELY
MANAGED AND SO THIS ALLOWS THE
STATE LANDS COMMISSION TO BUILD
A PROGRAM. THAT WILL START
ACTIVELY MANAGING- OUR STATE
LANDS. WE ALSO ENSURE WE'RE
GIVE FUND TO TRY SOME HAVE.
BEEN FUNDING AND- THROUGH- THE
COR. ARE GRANT AND- WE- BUT
WE'VE BEEN HEARING FEEDBACK
FROM OUR TRAVEL PARTNERS AND
THAT. IT IS DIFFICULT TO ACCESS
THAT- AND THEN THERE ARE SOME
AREAS THAT WE CAN IMPROVE IN
TERMS OF- SOCIAL JUSTICE AND
EQUITY WE HAD OUR TRAVEL
PARTNERS AND SO. WE'VE
IDENTIFIED TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS THAT IS FAIRLY FLEXIBLE
BUT WE ARE ALLOWING TRIBES TO
TELL US. HOW TO BE ABLE TO
INVEST THESE DOLLARS IN A WAY
THAT IS FAIR EQUITABLE AND JUST
AND GIVES THEM TO. RESOURCES
ASSEMBLY MANAGE THEIR LAN
WITHOUT A LOT OF ADMINISTRATIVE
BURDEN FROM THE STATE. WE ALSO
ARE INCORPORATING FUNDING
INCREASING FUNDING FOR SMALL
FAMILY LANDOWNERS THIS IS ABOUT
26% OF THE LAND OWNERSHIP IN
CALIFORNIA. AND MOST OF THESE
LANDOWNERS ARE LAND RICH BUT
CASH POOR AND SO WE'VE INCLUDED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA FORCED TO PROVE THAT
PROGRAM. WHICH GIVES GRANTS TO
SMALL FAMILY LANDOWNERS TO BE
ABLE TO ACTIVELY MANAGE THEIR
LANDS THE ADDED BENEFIT OF THIS
PROGRAM IS THAT WE HAVE SEEN
THAT MANY FAMILY LANDOWNERS.
OFTEN SELL THEIR LAND BECAUSE
THEY CANNOT MAINTAIN THAT SO
GIVEN THE RESOURCES TO CREATE
FIRE RESILIENCE AND ECOLOGICAL
RESILIENCE ON THIS LANDSCAPE.
ALLOWS US TO BE ABLE TO. HELP
PREVENT FAMILY LANDOWNERS FROM
SELLING THEIR LAND AND HOW THEY
GET CONVERTED AWAY FROM FOREST
ECOLOGY. WE'RE ALSO INVEST IN-
INDUSTRIAL LANDOWNER SIDE FOR
THE FOREST LEGACY PROGRAM
PROVIDES- FUNDING FOR LARGER
LANDOWNERS YOU'LL BE ABLE TO
COMMIT TO CREATE CONSERVATION
EASEMENTS TO PREVENT THEIR LAND
FROM GETTING CONVERTED- AND SO
THIS ALLOWS US TO ENSURE THAT
WE ARE SUSTAINING AND RETAIN
RETAINING LARGER SWATCH OF-
ECOSYSTEMS IN THE STATE- AND
THEN WE ALSO ARE CONTINUING ARE
FORCED HEALTH GRANTS A HUNDRED
SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS FOR
FOREST HEALTH GRANTS- WHICH CAN
THEN BE DETERMINED BY REGIONS
AND COMMUNITIES APPLY FOR THOSE
GRANTS AND THEY GET ON THE
LANDSCAPE. AND THEN WE ARE
STARTING TO SHIFT TOWARDS THIS
REGIONAL- FRAMEWORK TO ENSURE
THAT REGIONS ARE IN THE
DRIVER'S SEAT AND THAT WE ARE
THAT GIVING BLOCK GRANTS TO THE
REGIONS TO BE ABLE TO EXECUTE
CONCENTRATIONS ARE- WHAT WE
CALL THEIR PROJECT TYPE PLANS
WHAT WE CALL QUOTE UNQUOTE
SHOVEL READY PROJECTS- AND SO
ONE OF THE FIRST REGION'S WERE
ROLLING OUT WE IS THIS YOUR
NEVADA CONSERVANCY THIS YEAR
NOT THAT REPRESENTS- EIGHT
EIGHT IT. IS HOME 260% OF
CALIFORNIA'S WATER COMES FROM
THIS YEAR NEVADA- AND IT IS 74%
OF THIS YEAR NEVADA IS A HIGH
FIRE RISK ZONE A QUARTER OF
THIS YEAR ABOUT A BIRD LAST
YEAR ON THE CINEMATIC
CONSERVANCY HAS IDENTIFIED OVER
HUNDRED SHOVEL READY PROJECTS
THEY'VE DESIGNED A REGIONAL
STRATEGY AND A REGIONAL PLAN
THAT HAS INCORPORATED REGIONAL
PARTNERS AND SO IDENTIFYING
SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS THIS
YEAR NEVADA CONSERVANCY YOU
START THOSE PROGRAMS. AND TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE A LARGER
COLLECTIVE IMPACT THAT WILL
HELP US NOT ONLY PREVENT
CATASTROPHIC FIRES BUT MITIGATE
THE IMPACTS OF DROUGHT FROM
HAVING THOSE WATERSHEDS LOST-
AND SO THIS IS REALLY. A
CRUCIAL FUNDING AS WELL. WE'RE
ALSO GOING- ST SHE FUEL BREAKS
AND WE- URBAN INTERFACE- PRO.
THIS INCLUDE OUR CALVET- CRUISE
CAL- IS ANTICIPATED INCREASE.
THEIR THEIR AND NOW OF GILBERT
SAID THEY THEM LIKE. YOU ARE-
FORTY FIVE TO SIXTY A YEAR
DEPENDING ON THE SIZE OF THE
PROJECT AND SO THIS ALLOWS THEM
TO SCALE UP AND GET SOME CREWS
TO DO THE JOB. THIS ALSO
INCLUDES A HUNDRED THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR OUR
PROXMIRE PREVENTION GRANT. AND
EASY- THESE GRANTS CAN BE USED
BURKE- FUEL BREAKS AND
HARDENING IT'S REALLY UP TO
COMMUNITIES YOU DECIDE HOW THEY
USE THEM- BUT BY. WE'RE ALSO
INCREASING THE WORKFORCE TO BE
ABLE TO EXECUTE BOTH. THESE
VEGETATION THINNING PROJECTS-
AND- TO BE ABLE TO GET TO A
POINT AND TO BE ABLE TO DO YOUR
FORCED TO WORK SO WE'RE
INCLUDING TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE FORESTRY CORP-
FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS. AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA- HAND CREWS AND TO
BE ABLE TO DO THIS WORK. I AM A
REALLY FOCUSED ON COMMUNITY
HARDENING AND HOME HARDENING
AND WE SEE HOME HARDENING- BUT
WE HAVE. AN ESTIMATED TWO
MILLION HOMES ACCORDING TO THE
CALIFORNIA FIRE SAFE COUNCILS
IN HIGH FIRE RISK ZONES THAT
ARE IN NEED OF HOMES HARDENING
RETROFITS AND DEFENSIBLE SPACE.
TO BE ABLE TO WITHSTAND FIRES
AND ACHIEVE THAT- HOME
HARDENING LEVEL WE'VE TAKEN
SOME STEPS IN THIS DIRECTION IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT THE FIRE
MARSHAL CHANGED. HE WOULD BE
UPDATED BEAT THAT CALIFORNIA
FIRE CODES YOU INCORPORATE HOME
HARDENING STANDARDS AND WE
SIGNED THAT AND PARADISE FOR
EXAMPLE HOMES BUILT WOULD BE
HIGHER UP HIGHER STANDARDS THAT
ANY CLICK ON CORPORATE HOME
GARDENING. A 60% PERCENT
SURVIVAL RATE IN THE CAMPFIRE
VERSUS THE 10% SURVIVAL RATE OF
HOMES BUILT BEFORE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT WITHOUT THOSE STANDARDS.
SO WE'RE SEEING SOME INCREASE
IN SURVIVABILITY AT WITH THESE
NEWER HOMES BUTIT'S REALLY.
IMPORTANT TO BE ABLE TO DO
THOSE RHETORIC THAT I'M HARD WE
CAN H. THROUGH AND OUTREACH TO.
THAT CAN AFFORD TO MAKE THESE
CHANGES WE'VE INCREASED BY FOR
THE- SPACE INSPECT AS YOU JUST
GOT. AND WE'RE ALSO FUND FOR-
OR DO YOU SEE FIVE ADVISOR WHO
ARE CHRIS PARTNER. OR DOING
THAT EDUCATION OUTREACH TO COME.
AND WE'RE AT WE'RE LAUNCHING A
PILOT PROGRAM TO BE ABLE HELP
HOMEOWNERS THAT CAN AFFORD TO
MAKE THESE RICHARD. RECHECK SO
THAT TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT FROM THE STATE WHICH
WILL HELP US LEVERAGE SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FROM FEMA
MITIGATION GRANTS THIS WOULD BE
A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR PILOT
PROJECT TO BE ABLE TO TRULY
LAUNCH- HOME HARDENING EFFORTS
AND FEDERAL COMMITMENTS UNDER
EIGHTY THIRTY EIGHT. SO OUR
GOAL IS TO BE ABLE TO ENSURE
THAT WE ARE WE ARE SO AS YOU
CAN SEE THIS BUDGET WE ARE
STEALING. AREAS THAT WE HAVE
BEEN ALREADY WORKING IN
ACTIVELY AND PROACTIVELY AND WE
ARE LAUNCHING A PILOT FOR HOME
HARDENING WHICH IS A CRUCIAL
PART OF THIS- REQUIRE
RESILIENCE STRATEGY- AND IT
NEEDS TO START AND SO THIS IS
REALLY SCALING IT UP. IN THE
RIGHT WAY AND CREATING A
FOUNDATION. TO SCALE FURTHER.
NOW I'M- BY- COUNTY AREAS- I
MET- OUR REGION SITE BASED
MANAGEMENT REMOVING BARRIERS-
TO BE ABLE TO INCREASE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BUSINESSES. AND AND PERMITTING
REFORM SO THE REGIONAL PART IS
REALLY CRUCIAL FOR EVERYBODY TO
UNDERSTAND BECAUSE THIS IS THE
AREA THAT ALLOWS US TO TAKE.
THE THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN GRANTS ACROSS OUR
FOREST HEALTH AND FIRE
PREVENTION ACTIVITIES PROPOSED
IN THIS BUDGET. AND ENSURE THAT
THEY ARE STRATEGICALLY MEETING
THE GOALS OF THE REGION. SO
THIS INCLUDES EIGHTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
REGIONAL POOREST AND FIRE
CAPACITY PROGRAM WHICH ALLOWS
REGION'S JUNE BRING MULTIPLE
STAKEHOLDERS TO THE TABLE. IT
PROVIDES DOLLARS FOR REGIONAL
PLANNING AND PROJECT
PREPARATION. AND- AND- I WINDS
OF READY REGION TO BE ABLE TO
GET OUT THE DOOR WE HAVE THIS
BE IN. IMPACT PROGRAM ALREADY
FUNDED ACTIVITIES AND REGIONAL
STRATEGIES- NORTH COAST
REGIONAL PARTNERSHIP FOR
EXAMPLE IT'S FUNDING AND- AS
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA OUR
REGIONAL ACTIVITIES BURKE SANTA
MONICA MOUNTAINS CONSERVANCY
AND DOWN IN SAN DIEGO AS WELL
AND- AND IN THIS YEAR AND ABOUT
AS WELL. AND SO THIS EIGHTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR NOT
ONLY ALLOW US TO BUILD ON THE
COLLABORATIVE REGIONAL
STRATEGIES- AND PLANNING THAT
HAS ALREADY BEEN ESTABLISHED
BUT EXPERIENCE YOU FIVE NEW-
SPECIFIC REGIONS INCLUDING
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA LAKE
COUNTY. WHERE YOU'RE SACRAMENTO
REGION NAPA COUNTY AND SHASTA
COUNTY SO THIS WOULD ALLOW US
TO HAVE THEM AND ALL OF THE
FIRE- PRONE REGIONS OF THE
STATE COVERED BY EAST REGIONAL
COLLABORATIVE. AND THIS IS ONE
OF THE BIGGEST CHALLENGES WE
HAVE BEEN HEARING FROM OUR
GRANTEES AND- AND A CONCERN
WE'VE BEEN GETTING FROM REGIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THAT THEY
ARE NOT GETTING THE DOLLARS TO
PLANT THAT ARE GRANT DOLLARS
TEND TO GO TOWARDS AREAS. THAT
AND COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE GRANT
WRITING CAPACITY RATHER THAN
THE LARGEST- FIRED NEEDS AND SO
WHAT THIS IS DOING IS GIVING
THEM THE TOOLS TO DESIGN A
COHESIVE REGIONAL STRATEGIES.
AND SHOULD BE ABLE TO THEN GET
PROJECTS- PIPELINE AND SHOVEL
READY TO BE ABLE TO GET OUT THE
DOOR- AND I'LL JUST MAKE A FEW
MORE MINUTES TO GO TO THE RIGHT
AND THEN I'M GOING TO BE
DELIGHTED TO ANSWER QUESTIONS.
SO WE ALSO WANT TO ENSURE THAT
THIS IS SCIENCE BASED
MANAGEMENT THAT WAS ONE OF OUR
CORE COMMITMENTS WITH THE U. S.
FOREST SERVICE I'M A CORE
PRINCIPLE TO OUR ENTIRE
STRATEGY IS THAT WE ARE
ADAPTING AND ADJUSTING TO. THE
REALITIES OF SCIENCE ON THE
GROUND AND CONSTANTLY STUDYING
AND TRACKING- BE PRACTICES THAT
WE ARE PUTTING FORWARD AND THE
STANDARDS THAT WE'RE SETTING SO
IN THIS ADAPTIVE MANAGEMENT IS
GOING TO BE REALLY. CRUCIAL TO
ACHIEVING- THE GOVERNOR'S
COMMITMENT THIRTY THIRTY. THAT
MORNING SHE THAT NOT ONLY WE H.
FIRE SAFETY BUT I DO SO. WE ARE
DOING IT IN A WAY AND HE HAVE.
THAT IS IMPROVING. AND THAT IS
IN. THAT WERE. OF CALIFORNIA'S
ECOLOGY AND LANDSCAPE. FOR
EXAMPLE I'LL GIVE YOU A COUPLE
EXAMPLES OF THIS IN ACTION- HE
AG CAL FIRE PARTNERED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY
TO DO A STRATEGIC FUEL BREAK.
UP IN COLFAX AND THIS IS A HUGE
PUBLIC SAFETY TOOL. BUT THE
DESIGN IN A WAY THAT BE- THAT
BEING A PRESCRIBED FIRE THAT
CAME ON AFTER NEEDED DEFENDING.
OUT WITH HELPING CHIU GERMINATE
NATIVE PLANTS INCLUDING MORNING
GLORY AND MILKWEED AND SO NOW
I. HAVE MONARCH BUTTERFLIES IN
NEED OF BIRDS WHICH BURNING TO
AN AREA THAT THEY HAD NOT BEEN
IN BEFORE- BECAUSE HE- ASKED
FOR TEACHING FOR BREAKS WERE
DESIGNED IN A WAY. THAT WAS
MORE TO THE ECOLOGY THERE WERE
INCLUDING FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS I'M IN THIS BUDGET
REQUEST OR SPATIAL DATA
ANALYTICS. SO THAT WE CAN GET
ABOUT THAT WOULD GIVE US ABOUT.
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND SQUARE
MILES OF LIDAR AND WE
ANTICIPATE THAT OUR FEDERAL
PARTNERS WILL CO INVEST WITH US
IN THIS THIS ALLOW US TO
LEVERAGE FEDERAL DOLLARS- THIS
ADDED TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
SQUARE MILES WOULD ALLOW US TO
FILL IN THE GAPS. FOR MOST OF
THE FIRE PRONE AREAS IN THE
STATE. AND WE WOULD LEVERAGE
OUR FEATHER FEDERAL PARTNERS TO
BE ABLE TO HELP US COVER NON
FIRE. PRONE AREAS AS WELL TO BE
ABLE TO ENSURE THAT OUR
PREDICTIVE MODELS AND ARE
PLANNING MODELS HAVE THE BEST
STATE ON THE GROUNDS. WE ARE
MATCHING THEIR WIN- GROUND DATA
AS WELL AND- AND FUNDING FOR
RESEARCH SO THAT WE ARE
ENSURING THAT WE ARE DOING THE
BEST TECHNIQUES ON
REFORESTATION. THAT WE ARE
ADAPTING TO YOUR CHAPARRAL
ECOSYSTEMS CORRECTLY THAT ARE-
THAT THAT WE ARE REALLY HAVING.
A LONG RANGE VIEW ON THIS.
FINALLY WE WANT TO SURE THAT WE
ARE IN BARRIERS- WE BEEN HAVE A
HARD FOR- AND COMPETING. A WORK.
SO THE INCLUDES GRANT THAT OUR
MILLION. IN GRANTS FOR
WORKFORCE PROGRAMS THESE ARE
PER. THAT WE HAVE CHIP DRAW FOR
SELF PROGRAMS. AND HAVE BEEN
EFFECTIVE SO THESE ARE PROGRAMS
LIKE HE CALIFORNIA. AND DON'T
SEE I JUST KNOW THE AKRON CHIPS
PROGRAM- THINK THAT IT WAS JUST
SPELL. SO- THE PROGRAM AND-
COUNTY AND- AND THEY ARE NOW
FUNCTIONING THROUGHOUT THIS
YEAR IT'S A PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN- SIERRA COUNTIES AND-
AND LOCAL TRIBES EIGHT TRIBES
ARE NOW INCORPORATED AND IT
HELPS TRAIN THE TRIBES. IN THE
BASIC VEGETATION MANAGEMENT AND
PRESCRIBED FIRE AND NAY THEN
ARE HIRED AS THE WORK FORCE
CREW OR THOSE COUNTIES. WE SAW
IT PERCENT DECREASE IN
UNEMPLOYMENT ON THE RECTORY OF
THE HONDA LEYTE TRIBE IN ALPINE
COUNTY. FROM THIS PROGRAM ALONE
SO THESE PROGRAMS REALLY HAVE A
DRAMATIC IMPACT WE ALSO FUNDED
PROGRAMS AT COMMUNITY COLLEGES
SO THIS WORKFORCE TRAINING
FUNDING WILL FOCUS ON
ACTIVITIES LIKE THE CHIPS
PROGRAM. COMMUNITY COLLEGE
PROGRAMS TO BE ABLE TO ENSURE
THAT WE ARE CHURNING OUT A WORK
FORCE. THAT IS CAPABLE OF
ADDRESSING THESE NEEDS. WE ALSO
HAVE BEEN SEEN A SHORTAGE SMALL
BUSINESS ARE. THE AREAS IT IS
TO. A WITH MASK TO KEEP TO COME
THIS WORK IT IS HOT WE ARE
HAVING TO SHIP- OTHERWISE
LARGER DIAMETER WOULD THAT
COULD BE PUT INTO BUILDING SO
TREES ARE GETTING LANDFILLED OR
BURNED. BECAUSE THERE'S NOT
STOMMEL CAPACITY AND WE ARE
OPEN PILE BURNING- MILLIONS OF
TONS OF SLASH PILES BECAUSE
THERE IS NOT- THERE ARE NOT
THAT GREAT. I RESOURCES TO BE
ABLE TO TAKE TO TAKE THOSE. NON
MARKETABLE PRODUCTS AND TURN IT
INTO- HIGHER INTO BETTER
PRODUCTS SUCH AS- DIESEL GAS
REPLACEMENTS OR BUILDING
MATERIAL AND SO THERE'S A LOT
OF INNOVATION IN THE SECTOR.
AND A LOT OF TECHNOLOGY OUT
THERE ONE OF THE BARRIERS HAS
BEEN ATTRACTING PEOPLE TO THE
CALIFORNIA MARKET AND ANOTHER
VERY ACTOR HAS BEEN GETTING
PEOPLE ACCESS TO. CAPITAL
LOWERS CAPITAL I'M PEOPLE. TO
CREATE. HE WANTS IN THE
FORESTRY SECTOR QUITE. OF
TENSION 4% WILL INTORATES ON
THE LOANS SO THE CLIMATE WAS
ONE THAT WERE PROPOSED FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS. YOU ARE LARGE
THIS WHAT S. WHAT INTEREST
LENDING- AND ZERO INTO LENDING
BE ABLE TO CREATE- CAPITAL AND
SUPPORT SMALL BUSINESSES IN THE
FORESTRY SECTOR SO EVERYTHING
FROM WHAT INNOVATION- AND WOODY
BIOMASS INNOVATION TO MORE
TRADITIONAL MARKETS. TO BE ABLE
TO ALLOW US TO SCALE UP
STRATEGICALLY THIS IS ALSO
PROPOSING THREE MILLION
DOLLARS- OR- PR AND OR- THAT GO
BASED TO BE ABLE TO DO YOU WORK
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE SOMEBODY TO
ATTRACT. LARGER BUSINESSES LIKE
CROSS LAMINATED TIMBER
INDUSTRY- CHIU CALIFORNIA AND
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO DON'T KNOW
CROSS LAMINATED TIMBER IS-
COMPRESSED. SMALLER DIAMETER
WOULD THAT ADD THAT REPLACED A
STEEL AND CONCRETE IN BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION ON CALIFORNIA JUST
UPDATED OUR BUILDING CODES TO
ALLOW UP TO EIGHTEEN STORIES.
IN CROSS LAMINATED TIMBER.
BUILDINGS IN CALIFORNIA THEY
CALL THEM PLACE SCRAPERS SO- WE
NOW HAVE THAT HE AT REGULATORY
ENVIRONMENT TO BE ABLE TO
ATTRACT THESE BUSINESS SAYS. SO
HAVING SOMEONE FULL TIME AND GO
BASS FOCUSED ON BRINGING LARGER
SCALE BUSINESSES Q. CALIFORNIA
TO HELP UTILIZED THE PRODUCTS
COMING OUT OF THE FOREST AND
VEGETATION THINNING PROJECTS.
IT'S GOING TO BE REALLY CRUCIAL
TO ENSURING THAT THOSE PROJECT
THOSE. ARE PROJECTS DON'T JUST
END UP ON AS SMOKE IN THE
ATMOSPHERE. SO THE LAST AREA
AND. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR. AND
WITH ME AS WE GOTTEN THROUGH
THIS REALLY LOOKING- PERMITTING
REFORM AS WELL. BECAUSE WE
DON'T WANT DO TO BE A TO SCALE
THESE AND- ONLY THE PROJECTS IN
YEARS OF IN. REVIEW YOUR OVER.
AND SO WE'RE PROUD OF THE WORK
WE'RE DOING STREAMLINING
OVERSIGHT AND CAL. THIS YEAR WE
LAUNCHED THE CAL B. T. WERE IS
TWENTY MILLION- THREE INQUIRE
REVIEW ON HIGH FIRE RISK NOT.
AREAS IN THE STATE SO THAT MOST
OF THESE PROJECTS THAT WE'RE
FUNDING- WOULD BE TO GET THEIR
SEQUEL AND NOW IS THIS ROUTE
THE QALBI TP PROCESS. WHAT THIS
DOES IS IT TAKES EQUAL TIMELINE
FROM. YEARS TO A COUPLE MONTHS
AND- AND WE ARE REALLY GRATEFUL
FOR THE COLLABORATION FROM OUR
OTHER PARTNERS WHO ARE ALSO
HAVE REGULATORY OVERSIGHT. IN
THE LANDSCAPE SECTOR INCLUDING
WATER BOARDS AND CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
AND THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
INCORPORATED. THERE STANDARDS
INTO THE CAL BTP. ANYONE DOING
A PROJECT UNDER THE COUNTY D.
P. HAS THE MITIGATION TOOLS TO
AVOID THE ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS
THAT COULD TRIGGER HE-
DEPARTMENT FISH AND WILDLIFE-
PERMITS. THAT NO SPECIES TAKE A
TAX PEOPLE THROUGH HOW TO BE
ABLE TO MITIGATE ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT CALIFORNIA WATER BOARD
HAS BEEN REALLY INNOVATIVE IN
PARTNERING WITH US. THEY HAVE
ESTABLISHED A STATEWIDE WATER
PERMIT TO COMPLEMENT THE BTP
AND ARE UTILIZING THE BTP ASK-
THE ENTRY POINT FOR THAT
PERMIT. AND WE ARE ARE
PROVIDING TWO MILLION DOLLARS
IN THIS BUDGET FOR THE WATER
WORKS TO BE ABLE TO STACK. SO
THAT THAT PERMIT IS FREE AND SO
ESSENTIALLY THE COUNTY T. P.
WILL BE NOW A ONE STOP
PERMITTING SHOT- FOR PROJECTS
THAT ARE UNDERGOING THESE
ACTIVITIES AND IT'S REALLY A
GOOD MODEL. CUTTING RETAIN AND
EFFICIENCY AND THEN FINALLY ON.
THIS PERMITTING EFFICIENCY
POINT EIGHT WE ARE- INC. ADD TO
MY DOLLAR FOR THE BOY FORCE. TO
BE TO HELP ROLE OUT THE-
PROJECTS BUT AND NOW. OF COUNTY
TPP. BE ONE THE CALDERON THIS.
THIS ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT-
RECEIVED LOT OF TIME ON THIS
TIME. IT IS A THOUSAND PAGE DOT
THAT IS DIFFICULT FOR ANYONE
GRANT YOU ARE. SO THIS DIRE IS
IT ALLOWS HUGE YOU PROJECTS. IN
OUR ON A FORTY YEAR SO
DIFFERENT PROJECTS MANY OF WILL
BE- THESE GRANTEES ARE FUN-
THROUGHOUT THREE JUST A
PROPOSAL. AND IT WILL ALLOW US
TO THEN HAVE A PROJECTS.
ANALYSIS TEMPLATE- IN IN ANY OF
THESE. HE GOES ON OR BUY OR
VEGETATION TYPES SO THAT WHEN
IN THE NEXT RANDY COMES ALONG
OUR TO DO A PROJECT THEY WILL
KNOW EXACTLY HOW TO HANDLE A
CALIFORNIA CHAPARRAL ECOSYSTEM-
THAT NEED MEDICATIONS ARE
RECOMMENDED IN THE V. T. P. O.
R. ANY PRE IDENTIFIED FOR THEM.
ALL THEY HAVE TO DO IS IDENTIFY
WHAT SPECIES ARE ON THE GROUND
AND- AND THEY'LL HAVE A MUCH
SIMPLER. FORMAT TO USE SO WE'VE
BEEN TRYING TO BE TAKE A REALLY
THOUGHTFUL APPROACH HERE YOU
ARE LISTENING YOU ARE PARTNERS
ON THE GROUND LISTENING TO
COMMUNITIES AND REGIONS. AND
ADJUSTING OUR PROGRAM AND OUR
FUNDING TO BE ABLE TO REFLECT
NOT ONLY A SIGNIFICANT SCALE
OUT IN OUR PIECE OF FIRE
RESILIENCE. BUT ALSO ADDRESSING
THESE UNDERLYING STRUCTURAL
BARRIERS THAT COULD BE
POTENTIAL HURDLES AND SLOW DOWN
PROGRESS AS WE SCALE OUT. SO WE
ARE SO GRATEFUL FOR ALL OF YOUR
PARTNERSHIP AND YOUR
LEADERSHIP. IN THIS EFFORT AND
I'M HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS
DON'T GO ANYWHERE LET'S HEAR
FROM THE ALEJO FIRST AND THEN
WE'LL. GO TO THE DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENTS. HELLO ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR BRIAN BROWN AGAIN WITHOUT
A. L. I TO MAKE THAT ARE OFF
DID PUBLISHED REPORTS INTEREST.
TO THE WELL RESILIENCE PACKAGE
OTHER AVAILABLE OUR WEB. AS
WELL AS BELIEVE THEY'RE LAY ON
THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE. I'M
GONNA SPEAK MOSTLY TO THE FIRST
DOCUMENT WHICH IS KIND OF OUR
OVER ARCHING COMMENTS ON THE
PACKAGE BUT THE SECOND DOCUMENT
HOPEFULLY WILL BE HELPFUL TO
THE COMMITTEE AS WELL WHICH
HAS. A MORE DETAILED
INFORMATION ON EACH OF THE TWO
DOZEN OR SO PROGRAMS THAT ARE
PART OF THE RESILIENCE PACKAGE-
AND LET ME ALSO PREFACE MY
REMARKS BY SAYINGTHAT- THESE
ARE OUR OFFICES INITIAL
COMMENTS ON THE PACKAGE- WITH
THE XCELERATED TIMELINES- FOR
THE SUBCOMMITTEE HEARINGS AND
THEN JUST. THE SCALE OF THIS
PROPOSAL WE'VE HAD- SOME GOOD
INITIAL CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT IN THE MINISTRATION-
BUT SURELY THERE ARE ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS THAT I THINK WE'VE
ASKED THAT- AND I'M SURE
THEY'RE GONNA BE ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE-
THAT YOU'LL WANT ANSWERS TO AND
SO WE'RE COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION- IN THE
COMMITTEE OF COURSE- TO. EXIST
PROPOSAL PROGRESSION. THROUGH
THE LEGISLATURE. SO WITHOUT A
FEW. KEY HIGH LEVEL COMMENTS
FOR YOU FIRST OF ALL. WE THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT KNOWLEDGE THAT
THIS PACKAGE- HAS A LOT. OF
AMERICANS THAT THE FOCUSED ON
PREVENTION AND MITIGATION. IT
WE THINK IT'S VERY MERITED-
THAT GIVEN NOT ONLY THE
SEVEREST OF BUYERS LAST YEAR
THE LAST THREE OF THE LAST FOUR
YEARS HAVE BEEN AMONG THE WORST
IN. RECORDED HISTORY IN THE
LAST TWO DECADES HAVE BEEN A-
SOME OF THE WORST DECADE FOR-
FIRE DAMAGE. IN RECORDED
HISTORY IN THE STATE SO WE
THINK THIS ADDITIONAL FOCUS ON
PREVENTION MITIGATION MAKES
SENSE BUILT ON. THE EFFORTS OF
THE LEGISLATURE IN SB NINE
ALIGN. EVERYTHING ALSO HAVING.
A VARIED MIX OF STRATEGIES
MAKES A LOT OF SENSE- YOU HEARD
MISS MORRIS TALK ABOUT THE
WIDER RANGE OF. RISKS INVOLVED
AND SO WE THINK HAVING A-
HAVING THESE DIFFERENT
STRATEGIES THAT ARE TARGETED
SOME OF THOSE DIFFERENT RISKS-
MAKES A LOT OF SENSE. THAT SAID
IT WOULD CERTAINLY THIS PACKAGE
IS NOT THE ONLY WAY YOU COULD
STRUCTURE OF. RESILIENCE
PACKAGE AND SO WE HAVE A FEW
COMMENTS FOR YOU TO CONSIDER.
AS YOU AS YOU MOVE FORWARD. ONE
IS THAT NOTING THAT ABOUT TWO
THIRDS OF THE PACKAGE WILL BE
FUNDED FROM GENERAL FUND. AND
IT'S ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
SPENDING. FIVE NOW YOU HEARD ME
MENTION EARLIER SOME CONCERNS
AT OUR OFFICE IN FINANCIAL
PROJECTED MULTI YEAR BUDGET
DEFICIT FOR THE GENERAL FUND IN
THE FUTURE SO. I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO YOU KNOW WE
APPRECIATE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS FOCUSING A
ONE TIME SPENDING. GIVEN
WITHOUT YOUR FISCAL CONCERNS.
BUT OF COURSE THIS IS
CHALLENGING BECAUSE THE
WILDFIRE PROBLEM IS NOT A ONE
TIME PROBLEM IN THE SCALE OF
THE PROBLEM. IS SO LARGE IS IT
NOT CAN BE ADDRESSED. BY THIS
PACKAGE ALONE. INTO THAT SIMPLY
TO SUGGEST THAT THE COMMITTEE.
IN THE LEGISLATURE WE THINK
WE'LL WANT TO ENGAGE WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION. I THINK ABOUT
WHAT A LONGER TERM STRATEGY IT
WOULD LOOK LIKE IF THIS MAY BE
THE FIRST STEP OR SOME. SOME
PACKAGE- APPROVE THIS YEAR
COULD BE A FIRST STEP BUT- WE
THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE TO ALSO
THINK ABOUT WHAT WHAT WHAT
BEYOND THIS BOTH PROGRAMMATIC
LEE. AS WELL AS HOW IT WOULD BE
FUNDED- THERE WAS A DISCUSSION
ABOUT THE- ACTION. SO ABOUT
ONE. OF THE FOR. PROPOSED IN
THIS PACKAGE WOULD IS PROPOSED
TO BE FUNDED IN THE CURRENT
YEAR- WE HAVE KIND OF A MIXED
REACTION TO THIS SO. IN GENERAL
OFFICE A LITTLE BIT WARY ABOUT
A FUNNY EARLY ACTION PROPOSALS-
WITHOUT STRONG JUSTIFICATION
FROM THE MINISTRATION OF
PARTLY. BECAUSE WE THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT YOU HAVE THE
FULL. BUDGET SPRING BUDGET
CYCLE TO DELIBERATE ON EACH OF
THE PROPOSALS I MAKE SURE YOU
UNDERSTAND EXACTLY WHAT'S BEING
EMPLOYED BY A PROPOSAL HOW
WOULD BE IMPLEMENTED. IF IT
GRANT PROGRAMS WHAT CRITERIA
WOULD BE USED HOW DOLLARS BE
ALLOCATED ACROSS THE STATE IN
IN. IN PARTICULAR THIS MANY.
PROGRAMS THAT THERE'S ALL THERE
THERE'S A LOT TO WRAP YOUR HEAD
AROUND AND SO- BUT THE OTHER
ISSUE TOO IS TO THE EXTENT THAT
YOU APPROPRIATE THOSE FINES.
EARLY THAT TAKES THEM OFF THE
TABLE. AS YOU'RE DELIBERATING
ON YOUR FULL TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO BUDGET PLAN. AND WE KNOW
THERE A LOT OF PRESSURES ON. ON
ON THE ON THE GENERAL FUND IN
OTHER AREAS OF THE STATE BUDGET
AS WELL. THAT SAID WE DO THINK
THERE A COUPLE AREAS WHERE
EARLY ACTION. COULD REALLY BE
WARRANTED ONE IS WITH RESPECT
TO THE HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
MILLION PROPOSED FROM G. G. R.
AFTER. IN THE CURRENT YEAR- IN
AND CERTAINLY THE LEGISLATURE
UNDER NO OBLIGATION TO APPROVE
A- CURRENT YEAR. AUGMENTATION
TO THE CAP AND TRADE
EXPENDITURE PLAN BUT WE WOULD
KNOW THAT ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE MILLION. ADDED TO THE
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION ALREADY
APPROVED IN THE CURRENT YEAR
BUDGET. WOULD BRING TOTAL
FUNDING FOR FORESTRY AND FIRE
PREVENTION ACTIVITIES TO TWO
HUNDRED MILLION. WHICH IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE- DIRECTION
IN SB NINE OH ONE SO WE THINK
THERE'S- IF THAT OULD BE
REASONABLE. THE OTHER THING TOO
THAT MS MORE TALK ABOUT WAS
THAT- SOME OF THAT EARLY
ACTION. COULD ALLOW PROJECTS TO
BE IN PLACE IN ADVANCE OF
ANOTHER FIRE SEASON WHETHER
THAT. IN SOME CASES THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE FIRE SEASON OR IN
SOME CASES THE IT REALLY.
TRYING TO GET PROJECT TEMPLATE
EVEN BEFORE THE TWENTY TWENTY
TWO FIRE SEASON. EVERYTHING IN
EITHER CASE THAT COULD REALLY
BE WORN DID BUY THAT ACTUALLY.
OF PUBLIC SAFETY- PROTECT FOR.
WHERE THEY HAVE CONSIDER WE
WOULD SIMPLY NOTE THAT- FOR ANY
OF THOSE CASES- WE'D- SUGGEST
THAT THE- COMMITTEE HAVE THE
INVESTIGATION PROVIDE DETAILED
TIMELINES AND- IMPLEMENTATION
PLANS DEMONSTRATE THAT THAT
WOULD. IN FACT BE THE CASE. BUT
MY NEXT COMMENT IS- IN THINKING
ABOUT THE- PACKAGE OF PROGRAMS-
CERTAINLY AS I MENTIONED THIS
IS A WORTHWHILE PACKAGE TO LOOK
AT BUT THERE MAY BE OTHER
OPTIONS THAT YOU WOULD WANT TO
CONSIDER AND WE DON'T HAVE
ESTERLY AND ALTERNATIVE-
PROPOSAL TO PUT IN FRONT OF YOU
BUT WE DO THINK USING THE
SPRING PROCESS TO IDENTIFY
OTHER OPTION BOTH PROGRAMMATIC
AND FUNDING- IT IS MERITED SO
FOR EXAMPLE THE- PACKAGE RELIES
MOSTLY ON EXISTING STATE
PROGRAMS ARE NOT EXCLUSIVELY
BUT PRIMARILY EXISTING STATE
PROGRAMS AND SO MAYBE WORTH
USING THE SPRING PROCESS TO GET
INPUT FROM OTHER STAKEHOLDERS
SUCH AS- LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
HAVE. A LOT OF RESPONSIBILITIES
FOR LAND USE PLANNING FOR LOCAL
TO SPACE AND FOR LOCAL HAS FUEL
REDUCTION PER GETTING INPUT
FROM ALL THE STAKE TO SEE WHAT
OTHER IDEAS ARE MIGHT BE- THAT
YOU COULD EITHER- AUGMENT DE
PLAN OR- FIND IN PLACE OF SOME
OF THE- I AM IN WE THINK- IT
INTO THINK ABOUT A LONGER TERM
ON AS A WITH THE GENERAL BEING
TIME IN NATURE WE THINK IS IT
WORTH ENGAGING WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON WHAT ARE
SOME. LONGER TERM FINDING.
POSSIBILITY TO FIND OUT SOME
YOUR PRIOR ACTIVE. ON AN
ONGOING BASIS AND SO I JUST AS
EXAMPLES- THE OPERATION HAD
BEEN BROUGHT UP ALREADY TODAY
IN A DIFFERENT CONTEXT- THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WAS- I'VE DONE A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO IN PLACE
WITH GIGI R. F. THAT IS
SOMETHING THOUGH IF THEY
HISTORICALLY WAS USED TO FIND
PREVENTION AND MITIGATION.
pOFFICE HAS RECOMMENDED IT IS
THE- IS HAVING WATER AGENCIES
BY FINDING WAYS TO GET THEM- TO
INVEST MORE IN FOREST HEALTH
PROJECTS IN PRIORITY WATERSHEDS
SO- SO. THERE'S A COUPLE OF
EXAMPLES BUT THERE MAY BE A
BROADER ARRAY OF. ADDITIONAL
ONGOING STRATEGIES. THE
LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO
INVESTIGATE. SO OFTEN WAY- AS I
SAID YOU COULD CONSIDER THIS
PACKAGE YOU CAN CONSIDER
MODIFYING THE PACKAGE IN
DIFFERENT WAYS- IN IN IN THE IN
THE PROBABLY KNOW RIGHT MIX OF
PROGRAMS THAT WE CAN OFFER YOU
I THINK IDEALLY. WE WOULD BE
ABLE TO LOOK AT THE RESEARCH
LITERATURE AND TELL YOU WELL
HERE THE DIFFERENT MIX OF
PROGRAMS AND HERE'S THE- COST
EFFECTIVENESS OF EACH ONE- AND
WHILE WE'RE THERE CERTAINLY IS
RESEARCH DEMONSTRATING THAT
MANY OF THE STRATEGIES ARE
EFFECTIVE AT REDUCING WILDFIRE
RISK- WHETHER THAT- FOR
SPENDING ACTIVITY DEFENSIBLE
SPACE HOME HARDENING- FUEL
BREAKS ALL THOSE. I THINK THERE
IS RESEARCH DEMONSTRATING THAT
CAN BE EFFECTIVE WHEN
IMPLEMENTED WELL AND- THE RIGHT
PLACES- IT WE DON'T REALLY HAVE
THAT LEVEL OF DETAIL TO TELL
YOU WHAT WHICH ONE OF THOSE BY
EACH YEAR A DOLLAR SPENT ON
ONE. BUYS YOU MORE PUBLIC
SAFETY OR OTHER BENEFITS THAT
YOU MIGHT CARE ABOUT RELIGION
TO OTHERS. I'M KIND OF
COMPLICATING THIS TOO IS THAT
THERE ARE A FEW SEVERAL THESE
PROGRAMS WERE I THINK WE'RE
STILL LOOKING FOR ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION. WE THINK YOU
SHOULD LOOK FOR ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION FROM THE
MINISTRATION ON. THE JACKET
IMPLEMENTATION PLANS AND ARE
PROJECTED OUTCOMES FROM THE
PROGRAMS AND WE HAVE THAT FOR
SOME OF THE FOR OVER SOME OF
THE PROGRAM BUT NOT OTHERS. AND
SO. IN COMBINATION I IS THE- WE
THINK YOU'RE GOING TO- HAVE TO-
THEY HAVE TO FIND OTHER WAYS TO
BALANCE WHAT YOU THINK IS THE
RIGHT MIX OF PROGRAM BASED ON
YOUR PRIORITIES AND SO THAT MAY
FOR EXAMPLE LOOKING AT OTHER
FACTORS LIKE HOW DO YOU BALANCE
THE DIFFERENT BENEFITS
ASSOCIATED WITH ONE SET OF
PROGRAM FIRST AND ANOTHER SO
FOR EXAMPLE IF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PLAN BUT THE-
SOMEWHAT MORE THAN HALF THE
MONEY. PROPOSED TOWARDS- FORCED
HEALTH ACTIVITIES AND
LANDSCAPE- THERE'S NOTHING
WRONG WITH THAT PER SE BUT- BY
COMPARISON BUT THE MUCH SMALLER
EMPHASIS ON COMMUNITY HARD
MINUTES SO YOU'LL WANT TO THINK
ABOUT EACH OF THOSE DIFFERENT
SETS OF ACTIVITIES COMES WITH A
DIFFERENT SET OF BENEFITS AND
SO YOU'LL WANT. TO THINK ABOUT
WHAT YOUR- PRIORITIES ARE.
ASHLEY WHATEVER PILOT PACKAGE
YOU DO ADOPTED ANY. WE
SUGGESTED THE IMPORTANT TO
INCLUDE REPORTING MEASURES AND
THIS IS PARTLY TO. HOLD THE
ADMINISTRATION ACCOUNTABLE FOR
DELIVERING- WHATEVER OUTCOMES
IT IS SAYS IT'LL BE ABLE TO
DELIVER IT WITH THE FUNDING AND
JUST GIVEN THE- MAGNITUDE OF
FUNDING REQUESTED WE THINK
THAT'S IMPORTANT. BUT EVEN
PROBABLY MORE IMPORTANT AND
THAT IS IF WE HAVE GOOD
REPORTING METRICS IN PLACE THAT
CAN HELP INFORM FUTURE DECISION
MAKING. BOTH HOW TO- HOW TO
PRIORITIZE FUTURE- PROGRAMS HOW
TO HOW TO TARGET DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS THAT WE CAN LEARN.
EVEN MORE ABOUT WHERE WE CAN BE
WHERE PROJECTS ARE MOST
EFFECTIVE- IN ALSO HELP. INFORM
FUTURE- BUDGET DECISIONS YOU
MIGHT. YOU MIGHT HAVE. SO THAT
CONCLUDES MY REMARKS I'M HAPPY
TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
EXCELLENT I'M LIKE I DO WANT TO
FOLLOW ON THE L. A. O.'S. A
COMMENT ABOUT THE- LOCALS- THE-
WORK I KNOW AND I'M PART OF
ALAMEDA AND CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
WHERE THE EAST BAY REGIONAL
PARK THEY MONITOR THEY MANAGE
SOME OF THE- THE STATE PARK
STATE. THEY'RE THEY'RE NEEDING
FUNDS TO DO FEEL MANAGEMENT.
GET THE PERMIT FROM THE AIRPORT
BUT THAT'S A DIFFERENT ISSUE
WILL GET WITH DEAL WITH
HOPEFULLY TO STREAMLINED BUT
THEY'RE ACTUALLY DOING THE WORK
CAN YOU GIVE US SOME IDEA OF
WHERE WE ARE WITH ALL THESE
LOCAL PARTNERS THAT MAY BE
LOOKING. FOR SEVEN CASH FOR
THEIR PROJECTS THAT ARE READY I
KNOW. I'M NOT TO I KNOW THAT
THOUSAND PEOPLE LIVE IN ALPINE
COUNTY IN A TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED
PEOPLE IN SIERRA COUNTY WOULD
LIKE TO WORK WITH THEIR TRIBE
TO GET THEIR PROJECTS THAT I'M
FAMILIAR THANKS TO A TECH
LETTING US KNOW BUT THERE'S A
WHOLE BUNCH OF OTHER. REGIONAL
PARKS OR COUNTY PARKS AT A
ROUTE THAT I. TEND TO OUR LAN-
FAR FIRE LAND WHAT IT WHETHER
THEY- WHAT DO THEY NEED. IT'S A
GREAT QUESTION SENATOR AND- AND
WE'RE REALLY FOCUSED ON MAKING
SURE THAT WE ARE GETTING
DOLLARS DOWN TWO REGIONS ARE. A
REGIONAL FORCE TO FIRE CAPACITY
PROGRAM IS DESIGNED TO BRING
ALL OF THESE DIFFERENT
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING. LOCAL
PARKS AND LOCAL LANDOWNERS TO
THE TABLE WE PARTNER
EXTENSIVELY WAVES THE LANDSCAPE
STEWARDSHIP NETWORK WHICH
REPRESENTS MOST OF THESE- LOCAL
PARKS. TO HELP US- AND HAVE
INCORPORATED FEEDBACK FROM THEM
ABOUT. OUR PROJECT- AND PROGRAM
DESIGN ON THIS TO BE ABLE TO
HELP- LEFT UP LOCAL LANDOWNERS-
AND LOCAL LAND MANAGERS I'M IN
A MORE EFFECTIVE WAY. AND SO-
SO THIS BUDGET INCLUDES- FIVE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN. REGIONAL AND I'VE%
FORCED HEALTH GRANTS WHICH YOU
KNOW IT WAS FORCED TO SORT OF
THE GENERIC TERM WHEN IT COMES
TO THIS. BUDGET IT REALLY CAN
INCORPORATE GRASSLANDS AND
RANGELANDS AND ROLAND OAK
WOODLANDS AND PINE FORESTS AND
CHAPARRAL. AND IT DOES IT HAS
HISTORICALLY BEEN FUNDED ACROSS
BECAUSE OWNS. SO SO ABSOLUTELY
WE'RE- PARTNERING WITH LOCAL
PARTNERS AND- AND THEY ARE PART
OF THESE COLLABORATIONS. AND
ONE OF THE GOALS OF ENSURING
THAT WE HAVE- REGIONAL PLANNING
DOLLARS IS THAT YOU CAN
IDENTIFY STRATEGIES FOR EACH OF
THESE LANDOWNERS. THAT YOU HAVE
A STRATEGY ACROSS AN ENTIRE
WATERSHED. YOU BRING ALL THE
LANDOWNERS AND STAKEHOLDERS TO
THE TABLE. TO HELP DESIGN- AND
THAT- AND VISION FOR THE
REGION. WHITE I CAN'T SPEAK FOR
EVERY MEMBER OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE BUT SINCE WE PUT
REGIONAL PLANNING DOLLARS IN
THE LAST THREE BUDGETS AND NOW.
THE ADMINISTRATION'S COMING
FORWARD TO PROGRAM IT WARMS ALL
OUR HEARTS TO SEE THAT MONEY IN
THERE. WE'LL LOOK. AT THAT THAT
PHILOSOPHICALLY. YOU GOT ONE
TIME PRO PRIVATE. ARE PROGRAM
HERE AT THE L. A. OF HIS TALK
ABOUT A LONG TERM. AND WE'RE
COMBINING GENERAL FUND MONIES
WHAT. GREENHOUSE GAS MONEY
SOMEONE THE THINGS WE'VE THE
BELLY OF THIS POINT OUT IS THAT
YOU KNOW SOME OF THESE
GREENHOUSE GAS MONEY. ARE
CONTINUING. FIVE A SOURCES OF
FUNDS THAT WE CAN DO THAT
CONTINUE TO ADDRESS THE PROBLEM
AND IN REDUCING THE CARBON IN
OUR ENVIRONMENT WE'VE DONE A
LOT OF WORK ON THESE DIFFERENT
PROGRAMS EACH YEAR WE SEE WE
SCRUB THEM. SO SOME OF THOSE.
PROGRAMS WE'RE FAMILIAR WITH
THEM WE KNOW WE'RE ADVOCATE SIR
WE'VE GOT DATA ON IT THAT WE
THINK THIS IS A GOOD PROGRAM.
PROBLEM OF TAKING THIS BILLION
DOLLARS ANDUSING ALL GENERAL
FUNDS TO DO THAT. AND ALLOWING
THE LEGISLATURE WITH THE
DISCRETIONARY MONEY THAT WE
HAVE TO CONTINUE TO DO THE WORK
SO YOU HAVE THIS IN FUSION OF
MONEY THAT GOES IN THERE TO
ADDRESS. THE FOREST LANDSCAPES
BUT THEN IN THE OUT YEARS WITH
THE FUNDS THAT WE HEAR FROM CAP
AND TRADETHEN WE CONTINUE IT'S
NOT ONE AND DONE WE CONTINUE TO
FUND THAT WHAT'S WRONG WITH
THAT PHILOSOPHY. WE DEFER TO MY
COLLEAGUE HAD SAID BERMAN
FINANCE. YOU WORRY STEVEN
BENSON DEPARTMENT OF. ONE IS
THAT IT. THIS ORDER AT EIGHT SO
I THINK. OF OUR PROPOSAL DOES
STRIKE TRENDS SO I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT THAT CAN
HIGHLIGHT THAT WHILE THE G. G.
R. WELL THE GENERAL FUND
INVESTMENTS ARE BEING PROVIDED
IN A ONE TIME BASIS THEY'VE
BEEN PROVIDED NO WAY THAT IT
MAKES THE FUNDING AVAILABLE FOR
FORTY FIVE YEARS WHICH IS KIND
OF A TYPICAL BUDGET WINDOW THAT
WE INVEST IN AND ALLOWS FOR
THESE PROJECTS TO KIND OF- TO
START AND IT ALWAYS TO
COMPLETION PROVIDE THEIR-
BENEFITS THAT WAY. AND IT'S
REALLY KIND OF ME LIKE ALL
BUDGETS BUT IT'S A BALANCING
ACT OF TRYING TO TAKE WHAT'S
AVAILABLE IN TERMS OF RESOURCES
TO INVEST. AND THE NEEDS THAT
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED IN THIS
PARTICULAR. GOVERNOR INSTANCE
YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT'S AVAILABLE
IS. LARGELY ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND INTO OUR OUR PERSPECTIVE
ON IT WAS IF WE- INVEST THIS IN
ONE HUNDRED OFTEN WE HAVE NOW
BUT PROVIDED IN THE WAY THAT IT
HAS AN AMOUNT AND AVAILABILITY.
THAT LETS THESE PROJECTS YOU
TAKE PLACE OVER FOUR FIVE YEARS
AGO IT STILL GIVES US. THE SAME
KIND OF BENEFITS IS IF WE DID
SMALLER INVESTMENTS- EACH YEAR
BUT THE THING AND THEN I ALSO
JUST WANNA. FINANCING SO WHAT'S
YOUR POINT THAT. THE G. WHAT
PART OF THE PUZZLE IS MAKING
THE- SB NINE OH ONE TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR. GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION REDUCTION FUND.
INVESTMENT FOR THE NATIONAL
FIVE YEARS THAT'S KIND OF AN
ONGOING COMPONENT AS WELL. AND
I THINK WELL NOT PART OF THIS
PARTICULAR PROPOSAL WE JUST
TALKED ABOUT CAN THE THAT
CALIFORNIA AND CCC CREW-
PROPOSAL WHICH IS REALLY PART
OF. THE ADMINISTRATION'S
OVERALL STRATEGY AND I THINK
FITS IN THIS CALL WILDLIFE.
MANAGEMENT WILDLIFE RESILIENCY.
POLICY AREA BECAUSE YOU KNOW
AND THAT'S ALSO AN ONGOING
GENERAL FUND INVESTMENTS I
THINK THAT REALLY WHEN. YOU
WHEN YOU STEP BACK AND TAKE A
LOOK AT THE VERY. HOLES
TOGETHER THERE'S A SIGN OF
TRYING BALANCE. BOTH ONGOING
AND ONE TIME TO KIND OF HIT ON
ALL OF THOSE AND MORE FOR. WAYS
THAT IS MORRIS TALKED ABOUT IN
TERMS OF HOW WE NEED TO ADDRESS
THE OVERALL ISSUE. MISTER
BENSON WE CERTAINLY APPRECIATE
THAT ADDRESSES. I KNOW YOU WERE
THERE DURING OUR CONVERSATIONS-
THE OF THIS SUBCOMMITTEE.
CREATED THE FOR THE DAY A
COMMITMENT TO TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS BEFORE S. B.
NINE OH ONE DECIDED TO DO A FOR
FIVE YEARS SO WE'RE- WE'RE-
WE'RE PART OF THE ARCHITECTURE
THAT SAID THAT THIS IS WHAT.
THIS IS OUR- OUR GOALS BECAUSE-
THE- POINT AND WE'LL BE TALKING
ABOUT THIS IS JUST IS SAID IF
WE GET THIS INFUSION. WE HAVE
LOTS OF PROGRAMS TO REDUCE
CARBON. THIS IS WHAT THE
GREENHOUSE GAS FUND THIS IS THE
FIRE PORTION IS A PORTION OF
IT. AND WE REALIZE THAT WE'VE
GOT A LONG TERM COMMITMENT THAT
WE HAVE TO DO SO. I JUST RESET.
I GOT A LOT OF DISCUSSIONS WITH
YOUR FROM OUR VICE CHAIR.
CENTER DOLLY FIRST AND SENATE
MCGUIRE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
I JUST WANT TO DO- FOR I JUST
WANTED TO COMMENT. SO I'VE BEEN
HERE EIGHT YEARS. AND I WAS
TALKING ABOUT FIRE BEFORE WE
HAD THE GIANT FIRES. AND I'M
ALSO SOMEBODY WHO LIVES IN THE
FOREST AND I OWN FOR CIVILIANS
AND I ALSO SEE MY COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE- THE ONLY TALK ABOUT
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR MEN AND I
WANNA TALK ABOUT LONG TERM HOW
WE REALLY SOLVE THESE PROBLEMS
BECAUSE THERE'S- PIECES OF IT
IN. IN JESSICA OR MISS
MORRIS'S- THE PRESENTATION THAT
I REALLY LIKE BUT YOUR- FIRST
OF ALL NUMBER ONE. WE HAVE THE
REASON YOU DON'T SEE PRIVATE
INVESTMENT WHICH IS WHAT WE
DESPERATELY NEED. SO WE HAVE
INFRASTRUCTURE AVAILABLE TO
TAKE ALL THESE PRODUCTS TO
THERE'S VALUE IN SOME OF THE
INS IN MOST OF THE STUFF THERE
IS SOME VALUE. BUT IT DEPENDS
ON. HOW FAR YOU ARE FROM. THE
INFRASTRUCTURE. TO MAKE IT
WORK. SO WE NEED TO PLACE
INFRASTRUCTURE. IN THE AREAS
WHERE WE KNOW WE HAVE A LONG
TERM COMMITMENT. PRIVATE MONEY
WILL COME IN AND PRIVATE
BUSINESS PEOPLE WILL COME IN.
AND BUILD FACILITIES. WITH NEW
TECHNOLOGIES TO SUPPLY US WITH
CROSS LAMINATED. WOOD PELLETS
ALL THESE OTHER THINGS THAT ARE
OUT THERE BUT THEY CANNOT DO
THAT BECAUSE THEIR BUSINESS
PEOPLE AND THEY HAVE TO HAVE A
RETURN ON THEIR INVESTMENT. THE
REASON YOU DON'T GET RETURNS
BECAUSE YOU DON'T HAVE A LONG
TERM SUPPLY. YOU HAVE SHORT
TERM SUPPLY YOU HAVE WE'RE
GONNA DO THIS PROJECT WE'RE
GOING TO DO THIS WE WE'RE GONNA
CHECK THIS STUFF OUT. AND WE
VOTE ON THE GROUND NOW BECAUSE
YOU CAN'T HOLD THREE HUNDRED
MILES TO FACILITY DOESN'T WORK
DOESN'T PAY COSTA. THE COST IS
A- WE NEED TO BE A PARTNER WITH
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT I KEEP
GOING BACK TO THIS INTEL WE-
GET STEWARDSHIP CONTRACTS. REAL
ONES THAT ALLOW US TO DO TWENTY
YEARS SO SOMEBODY WILL COME AND
INVEST A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN A PLAN. SO THEY CAN
READ SO THEY CAN PAY OFF THE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS BECAUSE
OF A LONG TERM SUPPLY. I FOR
THE LIFE OF ME I SIT ON EQ. I
SAID I SAID ON- WHAT PART OF MY
LIFE IN THIS IN THE AND I HEAR
I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW MANY BILLS
I'VE HEARD WERE OUR GONNA SAVE.
I MEAN WITH A SENATOR WIENER
JUST HAD A BARE SPOT BERANI WE
KILLED MORE WILDLIFE IN FOUR
MILLION ACRES OF WILDFIRES YOU
WILL EVER DO HUNTING OR-
FISHING OR WHATEVER AND WE
WE'VE GROWN MORE HABITAT. IN
THIS STATE. THAT IS DESTROYING
THE WATER SAYS THAT ALL THE
PEOPLE IN THE URBAN AREAS NEED
TO DRINK AND WE NEED FOR FARMS
SO IT'S EMOTIONAL. IT'S
FRUSTRATING. IN OUR I'M I'M NOT
BEATING ANYBODY UP HERE BUT I'M
WE ARE WE ARE DOING IT THE
WRONG WAY INTEL WE- LOOK AT
LONG TERM. IF A STRUCTURE IN A
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. WE'RE SPINNING OUR
WHEELS WE'RE GONNA SPEND MONEY
AND WE I AGREE WITH MIKE. MY
COLLEAGUE WAS REQUIRED THAT WE
NEED TO ATTACK THE FIRE BUT WE
ALSO NEED TO LOOK AT THE
VEGETATION. OF BTP VEGETATION
ARMOR STANDS FOR- VEGETATION
TREATMENT PLANT. WE NEED TO
PARTNER WITH FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
WE NEED BILL GIVES OF A
STRUCTURE HERE AND WE NEED TO
BE ABLE TO LONG TERM PLAN IF WE
DON'T DO THAT. I DON'T CARE. I
GOT FOUR MORE YEARS AND I TELL
YOU IN FORMER YEARS WILL BE
SITTING HERE TALKING ABOUT THE
SAME THING WILL BE. WE'LL
PROBABLY HAVE A DOWNTURN IN THE
BUDGET WE DID BLESSED. IN EIGHT
YEARS I'VE BEEN HERE THAT WE'VE
ACTUALLY HAD MONEY TO SPEND. SO
I WOULD I WOULD LOVE TO WORK
WITH I KNOW MISS MORRIS AND I
PERSONALLY KNOW HER I KNOW
SHE'S VERY WICKED SMART IN THIS
AREA I MEAN WE NEED TO SIT DOWN
AS A AS A AS BIPARTISAN GROUP
AND FIGURE OUT HOW WE GO TO
WASHINGTON AND WE GET THOSE
GUYS BACK THERE TO PARTNER WITH
US ON OUR ON OUR HABITAT OR
WITH A WALL IT'S JUST
FRUSTRATING TO WATCH THIS WHOLE
THING HAPPENED SO. WE NEED TO
TALK TO BUSINESS PEOPLE NOT NOT
GOVERNMENT DOES NOT CREATE JOBS
A CURATE GOVERNMENT JOBS NOT
PRIVATE ISSUE JOBS WHICH WE
NEED AND THEN UNDERSTAND THAT
YOU CAN'T HAVE A PROJECT HERE
AND THEN ONE THREE MILES AWAY
AND EXPECT SOMEBODY BILL FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE SOMEWHERE. IT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN. SO I JUST WANT
TO VENT BECAUSE I'M SO
FRUSTRATED. AND IT'S NOT A LACK
OF MONEY THERE'S TWENTY MINUTES
IT'S A COMBINATION OF THINGS
IT'S PART OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT YES STREAMLINING
PERMITTING PROCESSES. YOU KNOW
WE TALK ABOUT AIR QUALITY WE
DID SB NINE ONE AND I EXTENDED
THAT WE EXTENDED US TOGETHER.
THE CONTRACTS ON BUY MISMAS AND
ENVIRONMENT GROUPS ARE
SCREAMING OUT UNTIL YOU WE MADE
IT MORE CARBON IN THE LAST YEAR
THAN WILL EVER. ADMIT IN IN IN
IN A BIOMASS PLANT SO IT'S LIKE
COMMONSENSE I'M A FARMER. I
PLOW IN. MY LAN BEFORE HER
PLANET BECAUSE IF YOU DON'T YOU
DON'T GET A RETURN ON IT THIS
NO DIFFERENT THAN HERE WE NEED
TO LOOK AT THINGS. IN A COMMON
SENSE APPROACH. AND THEN. PUT
IT TO WORK ON THE GROUND I
OFTEN. FEEL LIKE I'M JUST.
BEYOND FRUSTRATED AND I DON'T
HAVE MUCH TIME LEFT AND I WANT
TO STAY IN CALIFORNIA FOR A
WATERSHED INNER. CRITTERS AND
EVERY EVERYTHING TO WORK LIKE
IT'S SUPPOSED TO WE HAVE A
HUNDRED YEARS OF FIRE
SUPPRESSION THAT'S BECAUSE OF
FROM ANY OF CLIMATE CHANGE. TWO
THINGS ARE HAPPENING. THE ONE
THING WE CAN CONTROL. THERE'S
ONE THING WE CAN'T CONTROL
OXYGEN WHAT IT TAKES TO MAKE A
FIRE AND SPARK BUT WE CAN
CONTROL THE FUEL. THAT'S THE
ONE THING WE CAN DO. WE NEED TO
DO THAT. SORRY CHOIR MEMBERS
THANK. THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER
JENNER QUESTIONER YES
ABSOLUTELY JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO MISS MORSE AND
TICKET CRAWFORD FIRST AND
FOREMOST ON THE TWENTY MILLION-
FOR THE- PARTICIPATION WITH
TRIBES AT THIS IS BEEN A TWENTY
FOUR MONTHS IN THE MAKING VERY
GRATEFUL THE ADMINISTRATION FOR
ENGAGING ON THAT. ISSUE ON I
HAVE A SPECIFIC QUESTION FOR
THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCE
BOARD MY UNDERSTANDING WE HAVE
MR CHANG AND MR EDWARDS ON THE
LINE. HI THIS IS AJ. DON'T MISS
CHANG I APOLOGIZE. I DO
MATCHING IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU
MORNING IT'S GOOD TO ZERO SORRY
THAT WE CAN'T BE THERE WITH YOU
I'M WITH YOU- IT TOO MUCH OF
TWENTY TWENTY IS BLIGHTED
TWENTY TWENTY ONE SO THERE WE
GO- HE- IS SOME QUICK QUESTIONS.
I'M A FIRM BELIEVER THAT WE
NEED TO BE ABLE TO STREAMLINE.
THE PRESCRIBED BURNING APPROVAL
PROCESS. IN RIGHT NOW- THE
APPROVAL PROCESS IS BASED OFF
OF INDIVIDUAL AIR DISTRICTS IN
THEIR BOARDS. IN APPROVAL THOSE
PERMITS BOTH WITH THEIR LOCAL
STAFF AS WELL AS THE BOARD'S-
IN SO I HAVE SOME VERY SPECIFIC
QUESTIONS- THREE QUICK ONES.
HOW MANY DAYS THIS WINTER HAS A
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
CERTIFIED THAT IT'S BAD AT THE
IT IS SAFE TO BURN ACROSS THIS
YEAR AS- AND- AND- COASTAL
RANGE. DO YOU HAVE THAT OF TOP
YOUR HEAD SO I PROBABLY GONNA
TAKE A ESTIMATE ON THIS PLEASE
BUT I'M GENERALLY FROM ABOUT
NOVEMBER TO JULY. ABOUT 97% OF
THE DAYS OUR BIRTHDAYS. SO THE
VAST MAJORITY OF DAYS ARE
CONSIDERED FOR DAYS AND THEN IT
JUST I THINK- SENATOR YOU KNOW
THIS BUT JUST YOU KNOW FOR KIND
OF THAT EDUCATION OF OTHERS.
HAVE A TWO PHASE PROCESS- CARD
DOES BURN CALLS IF THEY WE HAVE
A TEAM OF METEOROLOGISTS THAT
ARE AT. THEY'RE ACTUALLY
WORKING THEY WORK TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN AND THEY MAKE A BIRD
CALLS EVERY DAY AND THEN AS YOU
NOTED THE LOCAL AIR DISTRICTS
SO LOCAL AND AGENCIES THAT HAVE
SORT OF MORE. ON THE GROUND
INFORMATION THEY'RE CLOSER TO
WHAT'S ACTUALLY HAPPENING IN
THEIR LOCAL AREAS ARE THE ONES
THAT ACTUALLY. AUTHORIZED THE
BIRDS. YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT
NOT. THAT THANK YOU SO MUCH-
THE OTHER QUESTION I HAVE IS.
DO YOU KNOW HOW MANY ACRES HAVE
BEEN TREATED WITH PRESCRIBED
BURNS IN THE LAST YEAR IN OVER
THE LAST TWENTY FOUR MONTHS. SO
AND THERE'S THIS IS DATA SAID
THAT AND SOME OF IT IS REPORTED
INTO A SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE
WHICH IS CALLED PEEPERS WHICH
I'M NOT EVEN GONNA TRY TO
REMEMBER WHAT THE ACRONYM
STANDS FOR. SO AND LET ME SEE
IF I ACTUALLY. I OF COURSE
DON'T HAVE THAT INFORMATION AT
THE TOUCH THE TIP OF MY- AND- I
THINK THEY MAY HAVE IT. BUT.
THAT WE HAVE THAT DISTRICTS CAN
USE AND LAND MANAGERS CAN USE
TO KIND OF START THE BURN
APPLICATION PROCESS THAT WAS
KIND OF A WAY TO STANDARDIZE
THAT PROCESS- THE FUNDING THAT
IS IN THIS- BUDGET REQUEST
ACTUALLY WILL HELP US CONTINUE
A PROGRAM WHERE WE DO TRAINING
AND OUTREACH. TO LAND MANAGERS
AIR DISTRICTS- TO TRAIN THEM ON
KIND OF YOU KNOW WORKING
TOGETHER AND FOR USING PEEPERS
AS A WAY TO KIND OF. AND
STANDARDIZE THAT PROCESS GOING
FORWARD I'M NOT ALL PRESCRIBED
BURNS ARE REPORTED INTO THE
PEEPERS DISCUSSION AND WE'VE
ACTUALLY BEEN WORKING AT.
WHAT'S REPORTED INTO OUR SYSTEM
WHAT'S REPORTED IN. AND THE
CALIFORNIA SYSTEM TO TRY TO
FIGURE OUT AND YOU KNOW WHAT'S
BEING REPORTED WHERE AND TRY TO
TRACK THAT. SO I DON'T HAVE THE
NUMBER RIGHT OFF THE TOP OF MY
HEAD IN TERMS OF HOW MUCH
BETTER I FIRE WE HAVE REPORTED
TO OUR SYSTEM YEAH I APPRECIATE
THAT THIS FARE OUT WE'D LIKE TO
GET A FOLLOW UP WITH YOU ON
THAT END. I THINK THE CHALLENGE
WITH THAT TOO IS- AND ALL THIS
INTO RIGHT HERE MISTER CHAIR
AND AGAIN MISS CHANG THANK YOU
FOR YOUR. COMMENTS AND ANSWER
THE QUESTIONS. ALL GIVE MY OWN
IT. THERE IS A PATCH WERE OF
POLISH. IN BED WITH EACH YEAR
JUST- AND THEY'RE JUST BOARD
HOW THE APPROVAL. FOR OUT
REGARDING FIRST FIRE. IF WE
KNOW THAT THAT'S ONE OUR GREAT
TOOLS AND WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
UTILIZE THAT CAN STREAMLINE THE
PROCESS TO ENSURE FOLKS ON THE
GROUND- I CAN MOVE FORWARD. AND
I HAVE GREAT CONCERN. THAT IF
WE DO NOT HAVE A STREAMLINED
STATEWIDE PROCESS WE ARE NEVER
GOING TO BE ABLE TO GET TO
WHERE WE WANT TO GO PRESCRIBED
BURNING. AND WE HAVE A WHOLE
NOTHER ISSUE LIABILITY THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT IS GOING TO BE A
LONGER TERM DISCUSSION BUT
LET'S CONTROL WHAT WE CAN AND
THAT'S THE STATE WIDE THE
POTENTIAL STATEWIDE POLICY.
INCONSISTENCY WITHIN THEIR
DISTRICTS AND I KNOW THAT'S
GOING TO CONTINUE CONVERSATION
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. VERY
GOOD- CENTER STERN. IF
QUESTIONS. YEAH THANKS MISTER-
I HAD ONE I I'D. ONE POINT
THOUGH HAD FORGET TO MAKE MAKE
YOUR ISSUE NINE JUST FOR THE-
DID WANT TO RAISE THE ISSUE OF
TO IN A HAN CREWS. PHASING THEM
ON A WE YEAR IS POSTED YOUR
PARENTS I DID WANT TO NOTE MY
AT. MY INCLINATION TO SPEED UP
THE HAND CREATING GRATION IN
AND ALSO ANOTHER ISSUE AROUND-
OUR WORKERS SAFETY WHICH I
DON'T KNOW WHERE THAT. THAT
BELONGS IN THIS DISCUSSION- WE
DIDN'T REALLY GET INTO IT BUT
L. A. TIMES EVEN YESTERDAY-
TALKED ABOUT. THE TOXIC- THE
TOXIC EMISSIONS THAT HAVE BEEN.
IMPACTING THE HEALTH OF OUR
CREWS IN I JUST DIDN'T KNOW IF
THERE WAS ANY MONEY IN. ANY OF
THIS ANY OF THESE POTS FOR
RESPIRATORS- FOR CALIFORNIA
WORKERS- SO JUST WANT TO FLAG
THOSE TWO. FOLKS WANT TO FOLLOW
UP ON THAT BUT DO WE HAVE ANY
MONEY FOR RESPIRATORS FOR
CRUISE AND SPEEDING UP HAMPERS
BUT ON THIS SPECIFIC
RESILIENCE. EXPENDITURE PLAN I
WANTED TO GET A SENSE FROM THE
DEPUTY SECRETARY- HOW DO YOU DO.
RESULT AS A AT AS A- AS AN
ADMIN RIGHT NOW. THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION SENATOR AND- YOU
REALLY I THINK YOU HAVE TO LOOK
AT PROBABLY I MEAN I'M LOOKING
AT IT ACROSS WHAT DOES. HOW DO
WE CREATE A SUSTAINABLE LIFE
WITH FIRE- IN THE LANDSCAPE FOR
THE NEXT HUNDRED YEARS. AND SO
WE RECOGNIZE THAT CLIMATE
CHANGE IS COMING AND IS UPON
US- WE RECOGNIZE THAT OUR FIRE
ECOLOGY IN CALIFORNIA IS OUT OF
BALANCE. AND SO RESILIENCE IS
REALLY GETTING US ONTO A
SUSTAINABLE FOOTING AND SO WHEN
WE'RE LOOKING AT IT IT'S ABOUT
HOW DO YOU YOU KNOW THE LONG
TERM VISION. FOR WHERE WE WANT
TO END UP WITH- WITH OUR FIRED.
RESILIENCE IN CALIFORNIA IS
REALLY THAT WHEN YOU GET. THE
WAVES AND LIGHT STRIKES AND
THEY HIT THE LANDSCAPE PLEASE
DON'T SPIRAL IN. CASTRO FIRES
THAT- AND THAT WE HAVE PLANNED
FOR WORST CASE SCENARIOS- OF
THOSE REALLY HEAVY WIND DRIVEN-
FIRES AND- AND HAVE TOOLS IN
PLACE. TO BE ABLE TO TRY TO
PREVENT TECHNICIANS ON THOSE
RED FLAG WARNING DAY GUEST THAT
WE HAVE. IN PLACE- SAFETY. SO
THAT WHEN A CATASTROPHIC FIRE
DE COME THROUGH- THAT BECAUSE-
IS SURVIVING AND WE RECOGNIZE
THAT YOU KNOW IF ANY TIME A
FIRE COMES THROUGH COMMUNITY
EVEN THE HOMES THAT ARE
STANDING ARE STILL.
SIGNIFICANTLY DAMAGED WITH
SMOKE AND- AND OTHER CHALLENGES
SO RECOVERY IS ROUGH ONCE OF
FIRES- YOU KNOW AT YOUR
DOORSTEP BUT- BUT WE'RE TO GET
TO A POINT. WE ARE PREHEATING
THAT- THAT SENSE OF YOUR LONG
TERM VISION OF WHERE
CALIFORNIANS CAN LIVE WITHIN
THE ECOLOGICAL BOUNDARIES THAT
WE HAD AND THE NEW ECOLOGICAL
NORMS THAT ARE GOING. TO BE
UPON US WITH CLIMATE CHANGE.
YEAH I GUESS I'M FROM FROM
QUALITY BURST THAT MAY SENSE I
JUST TRY TO GET THIS. IF YOU
ALL OF TIME- TRYING TO QUANTIFY
THAT ORDER AS A SOME OF METRICS
YOU TO AVOID- HOW CLOSE WE ARE
TO. RESILIENCE I. WHICH IS A
BRIDGE TO FOR INSTANCE THE ARE
DRIVING- ALLOW OF THE VILLAGE
MANAGEMENT STRATEGY. I'M NOT
CONVINCED THAT ACREAGE ALONE
DEFINES RESILIENCE IF WE
SUDDENLY TREAT A MILLION ACRES-
IT IS THE STATE'S SAFER DEPENDS
DEPENDS WHICH ONES- SO JUST. IT
IT IT SAID IT MAY BE A LONGER
TERM QUESTION OF THE L. A. O.
IS ALSO THOUGHT ABOUT THIS BUT-
TRYING TO GET SOMEWAY TO
QUANTIFY. OUR RESILIENCE
STRATEGY AND THEN TO BE ABLE TO
EVALUATE OURSELVES ALONG THOSE
METRICS TO SEE HOW WE'RE DOING.
YEAR ON YEAR- FOR INSTANCE THE
DEFENSIBLE SPACE INSPECTION
BUDGET HERE AS YOU AS THE
DEPUTY FIRE MARSHAL JUST
POINTED OUT DOESN'T COVER ANY
EXISTING HOMES EXCEPT FOR
PEOPLE ARE SELLING. THAT'S THE
ENTIRE BUDGET FOR DEFENSIBLE
SPACE THAT'S BEEN PUT FORWARD
HERE IS FOR TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND HOMES A YEAR. YOU SAID
THERE'S TWO MILLION PEOPLE
LIVING IN VERY HIGH FIRE
SEVERITY SEN SO WE'RE ABOUT.
99% SHORT- WE'VE COVERED ABOUT
1% THIS FOR. SO THAT DOESN'T
FEEL LIKE THAT IF YOU'D LIKE
YOU KNOW OKAY SO WORK. HOW MANY
BILLION SHORT JUST ON THAT
FIRST CONCENTRIC CIRCLE YOU
MENTION OF PARDONING ALONE I
JUST I NEED IS I NEED WE NEED
SOME METRICS TO BE THE RIGHT
SIZE OUR STRATEGY HERE I'M
JUST. TRYING TO GET THAT SET SO
WE CAN EVALUATE OURSELVES.
ABSOLUTELY I THINK IT'S A
CRITICAL- FOUNDATION AND I CAN
GIVE YOU A LITTLE SENSE OF HOW
OUR LAND USE HOW ARE PLANNING
IS- ADAPTING AND MODERNIZING-
AS OUR TECHNOLOGY AND DATA
ANALYTICS ARE MODERNIZING TO BE
ABLE TO COME UP WITH THESE.
MORE WHAT A RESILIENT
LANDSCAPES- AND RESILIENT
COMMUNITIES LOOK LIKE BECAUSE
IT IS GOING TO BE A FACTOR OF
ALL THREE OF THOSE COMBINATIONS
THAT ONCE THOSE HEALTHIER
LANDSCAPES. YOUR BRAKES TO REST
A FIRE ESCAPE AND- AND SURVIVOR
HARDENED INFRASTRUCTURE IN
COMMUNITIES. AND SO- YOU KNOW
WE HAVE TARGETS THAT MEASURE
OUR WORKFORCE HONEST I HAVE
BEEN LAID OUT SO FOR EXAMPLE
THAT TARGET A FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ACRES A YEAR TREATED
IS BASED ON. THE FORCE CARBON
PLANT WHICH IDENTIFIED ABOUT
FIFTEEN MILLION ACRES NOW THAT
ARE IN NEED OF TREATMENT
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AND WE'VE
GOTTEN OUR FEDERAL PARTNERS TO
COMMIT. TO REACHING THAT LEVEL
BUT A SENATOR DOLLY POINTED
OUT- THEY'RE NOT THERE YET-
THEY'VE BEEN INVESTING ABOUT
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
AND HAZARDOUS FUEL REDUCTION.
AND- WHEREAS THIS BUDGET
PROPOSAL HAS ABOUT- SIX HUNDRED
FORTY FOUR MILLION THAT CAN BE
ACROSS YOU KNOW IN THOSE-
THOSE. SECTORS FOR HAZARDOUS
YOU'LL BY COMPARISON AND SO- IT
JUST IT'S REALLY CRUCIAL THAT
WE ARE HITTING OUR TARGETS THAT
EARLY OUT IN THE FOREST CARBON
PLANNED- AS I MENTIONED TWO
MILLION HOMES IN NEED A
RETROFIT THAT NUMBER COMES FROM
HE CALIFORNIA FIRE STATE
COUNCILS. BUT WHEN YOU'RE
LOOKING AT FIFTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A HOME YOU'RE LOOKING
AT UPWARDS OF TWO HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS TO BE ABLE TO
DO YOU. RETROFIT SO THAT'S WHY
YOU NEED TOOLS LIKE EDUCATION
AND OUTREACH TO BE ABLE TO HELP
HOMEOWNERS THAT CAN AFFORD IT
TO MAKE THOSE DIFFERENCES AND
THEN MY VOICE COMMUNITIES. HERE
BE ABLE TO- TO HELP SUPPORT
MAKE THOSE CHANGES AND SO
THERE'S A LOT THAT WE CAN DO
YOU KNOW LIKE ANY OF THE
CLIMATE CRISIS WE'RE FACING
WHETHER ITS DROUGHT- OR EXTREME
HEAT. THERE'S A LOT OF
EDUCATION THAT CAN ALSO REALLY
HELP CALIFORNIANS- MAKE THE
IMPROVEMENTS AROUND THEIR HOME
AND CAN. THAT CREATE THAT LED-
RECENTLY- BUT- BUT WHEN OF THE
THINGS WE DO YOU DO. ADDED THAT
YOU HEALTH- THERE THAT CAN FIRE
HOW OF THE FRAT PROGRAM. WHICH
IS THEIR ANALYSTS UNIT THE-
LOOK. I AT AT WHERE WE HAVE.
LANDSCAPE AND PRIOR COME. I
DON'T WHERE THE HIGH VIRUS
ZONES ARE RIGHT NOW DEVELOP. A
PRODUCT THAT IS TO BE HELP US.
REALLY RAN. WHO RICH. ME ACROSS
THE ENTIRE WATER. SO THAT LOOKS
NOT JUST AT- FIRE RISK CAN
SAFETY IT ALSO INTO- OTHER DAYS
ANALYTICS AROUND CARDS. IN
WATER HEALTH. AND- AND PART OF
OUR JOB PLANNING YOUR SUPPORT
SERVICE- IS TO BE TO I. WHO'S
DOING WHAT WHERE. I'M ON A MAP
SO THEN WHEN LAYER THAT OVER
THESE- THESE AND TOOLS. THAT
HELP SHE- WHERE THEY ARE- THE
HIGHEST RISK AREAS WHETHER RISK
IN. HABITAT WORK- THEN IT HELPS
DESIGN. THESE PROJECTS BETTER
BE ABLE TO REACH HIM EVERY.
IMPACT BECAUSE WE'RE TO AVOID
OUR WHAT JOKING KALRA ACTS OF.
WHERE ARE GRANT KIND OF GO ALL
OVER THE PLACE AND THEY DON'T
HAVE THE HUMILITY. AND SO WE'RE
TO HAVE A CALL. COOKIE SAID
APPROACH THAT CAN BE CAN I.
FEEL THE IMPACT- AND THE STATE
IMPAIR OF. I'M SORRY I'M SORRY
YOU OFF I JUST I KNOW WE WILL
ABOUT FEW MORE MINUTES LEFT AND
I JUST WANNA GET TO A BY. WHAT
I'M HERE FROM USED A VERY
STRATEGY. BUT WAIT THERE'S NO.
METRICS THIS STRATEGY MENTIONED.
THE CARBON IS AND HOW. SO YOU
THE FORCE CAR PLAN YOU DON'T
YEAH HAVE A PLAN TO HARDEN IT
TO ME HOMES AND WHEN I HEARD IS.
WE'RE LEAVE. WORKING INTO TO
FIVE TO HOME ON DEFENSE SPACE.
I DIDN'T HEAR A NUMBER FOR MANY
FOLKS WE THINK WE'RE HARDEN-
FROM THE SMALL- OF MONEY IN
HERE I THINK TWENTY FIVE. MAY
MAYBE TRYING TO LEVERAGE- BUT
HOW MANY HOMES YOU THINK YOU'RE
GOING TO GET TO. A FROM THIS
PLAN- I APPRECIATE THE WORK
FORCE NUMBERS THAT THAT THAT'S
USEFUL BUT- I GUESS I'M I'M-
YOU KNOW. SHE WE- TO GET TO
RESILIENCE DO YOU KNOW HOW FAR.
IT DO WE HAVE A DELIVERY DOLLAR
ESTIMATE FOR HOW FAR BEHIND WE
ARE TO GET TO RESILIENCE. SO
LIKE I SAID IF YOU'RE GONNA TRY
TO RETROFIT ALL OF THOSE TWO
MILLION HOMES THAT'S TWO
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS ALONE
ON THAT FRONT. RIGHT IT'S THE
LANDSCAPE TO AND IT'S YEAH BYE
SO. ALL IN WHAT ARE WE SHORT
YOU GUYS HAVE A SENSE. I MEAN
YOU'RE LOOKING AT. RIGHT IS SO
IT JUST IT I THINK THE REALITY
IS THAT WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE THESE INVESTMENTS
STRATEGICALLY I MEAN THEY
EXPIRE CRISIS DOESN'T FIT
NEATLY INTO A BUDGET CYCLE. AND
BUT WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO WORK
STRATEGICALLY SO THAT THESE
INVESTMENTS ACTUALLY START
DELIVERING ON PUBLIC SAFETY AND
SECURITY I MEAN WE SAW
STRATEGIC FUEL BREAKS. THIS
LAST YEAR IN THE FACE OF FOUR
MILLION ACRES BURNING WITH OUR
FIRE CREWS COMPLETELY STRETCHED
OUT TO THE MAX AND TO BE ABLE
TO KEEP PACE WITH THESE FIRES-
WE FASTER HE FEEL GREAT STATE.
YOU KNOW WHOLE TOWNS IN THE
FACE OF REALLY INTENSIVE- FIRES
WE SAW THEM SERVICE ESCAPE
ROUTES WE SAW A HARDENED- YOU
KNOW COMMUNITIES WHERE HOMES
HAD BEEN HARD WORK ACTIVELY
REALLY MAKE THOSE IMPACTS. IN
THE END IT'S NOT JUST THE STATE
DOLLARS RATE WE'RE REALLY
GRATEFUL FOR THE PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
THAT WAS ANNOUNCED YESTERDAY.
WHERE AND THEY'RE GOING TO HELP
THE INSURANCE COMPANIES
INCORPORATE SPEED- HARDENING
STANDARDS INTO INSURANCE RISK
MODELS BECAUSE AS INSURANCE
COMPANIES START. ACTUALLY
QUANTIFYING THE RISK REDUCTION
THAT THESE ACTIVITIES ARE K.
ARE ARE IMPACTING THAT WILL
HELP CREATE FURTHER INCENTIVE
SO I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
PARTNERSHIPS. THAT ARE
AVAILABLE TO HELP REACH THESE
GOALS THAT AREN'T JUST DIRECT
STATE DOLLARS ON THE GROUNDS
ENGINE OKAY I'LL I'LL YIELD.
BACK TO THE CHAIR JUST- IN
LIGHT OF THE T. WERE THERE.
TRILLIONS AND THAT WE'RE
LOOKING. JESTER A BILL- I JUST
I'M I'M I'M EXTREMELY CONCERNED
THE SHORT. IN WHO LEFT YOUR
IT'S LIKE WERE FOR OVER PIE
THAT. YOU'LL LIKE A ZERO GAME
BUT- I MEAN I JUST WANT TO NOTE
FOR THE RECORD AND WILL BE WELL
I'M SEEING GAUGING THIS WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION ON THE EARLY
ACTION ITEMS- IN THE BUDGET.
GOING FORWARD AND THROUGH THIS
COMMITTEE- BUT- EVEN THE
HISTORIC TREND HERE EVEN ON THE
FORCED HEALTH PROGRAM AND ON
THE FIRE PREVENTION GRANT
PROGRAM WHICH I APPRECIATE
SEEING IN HERE- AS WELL AS THE
REGIONAL FORCING FIRE CAPACITY
BUT- THE LARGE. LARGE MAJORITY
THAT MONEY HAS BEEN DRIVEN BY A
CARBON METRIC. THAT TENDS TO
FAVOR PROJECTS WHERE THEIR BIG
TREE STANDING- THE VAST
MAJORITY OF PROJECTS HAVE NOT
GONE TO. THE SORT OF MORE
INTIMATE WILDLAND URBAN
INTERFACE AREAS- THAT DIE YOU
KNOW ALAMEDA AND CONTRA COSTA.
INTEREST BERNARDINO RIVERSIDE
IN LOS ANGELES YOU ADD UP ALL
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND HOW
THEY FARED EVEN JUST WITHIN
THIS THOSE TWO PROGRAMS. YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT SOMEWHERE AROUND
6% OF THE FUNDING IS GONE THERE
AT ABOUT TWO HUNDRED TWENTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS. SO YOU KNOW
WE'VE GOT TO DO SOMETHING
DIFFERENT HERE AND THAT
DISPARITY- IT MAY IT MAY HAVE A
GOOD CARBON METRIC ON IT. IMEDI
YOU MAY BE AVOIDED A LOT OF
KARMA YOU HAVEN'T SAVED ENOUGH
HOME SO WE WERE REALLY AYE I'M
HOPING WE CAN GET. SOME MORE
QUANTIFICATION- TO OUR STRATEGY
HERE AND REALLY PUSH FORWARD
HOMES AND PROPERTY SAVING AND
LYFT SAVES AS THE CENTRAL
DRIVING METRIC HERE- AND- YOU
KNOW WE'RE GONNA ONLY TO LIVE
TOGETHER SO PREACHY THE
INNOVATION AND YOU GUYS HAVE
DONE IN. YOUR YOU KNOW THAT THE
NEW PRO GRAMMY LAID OUT HERE IS
ENCOURAGING BUT- WE'RE NOT KEEP
GOING TO THANK YOU ALL MISTER
BENSON. I WANTED DIDN'T THAT I
I'M THEM TO ON AND THE JUST OF
FUNDS TO SETTING- WE HAVE BEEN
SO GREAT FOR. SOUTHERN CAL. WE
GET ABOUT OUR FUNDING IS BAY ON
PARTY LANDSCAPES AND POP- WELL
AS- THOSE REALLY FACTORY. ABOUT
THIRTY ONE PER OF OUR CALL HAS
GONE SEND. THROUGH THOSE HEALTH
PROGRAM- AT ABOUT FORTY FOUR.
TO NORTHERN REGIONS IN- AND
THAT WHERE PREVENTION. IF YOU
HAD HEALTHCARE FIBER YOUR UNDER
7% SIGNING. I THINK WE TO GET
TO YOU ON THOSE. BECAUSE THAT'S-
WILL WILL MAKE SURE THAT WE GET
YOU UPDATED- WE HAVE A AND FOUR
FOUR PROP AT AND THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS HAVE BEEN AWARDED TO
THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA REGION-
AND IT ALSO IS REALLY ONE OF
THE REASONS THAT WE ARE
INVESTING IN THIS REGIONAL
CAPACITY BUILDING. IS BECAUSE-
OUR GRANTS REALLY ARE FAVORING
AREAS THAT ARE WRITING GRANTS.
AND AND SO ABOUT 33% OF OUR
GREAT REQUESTS ARE COMING FROM
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND 31% OF
OUR GRANT AWARDS. ARE GOING
THERE AND SO WE REALLY WANT TO
MAKE SURE PART OF THE REASON WE
ARE INVESTING IN REGIONAL
PARTNERSHIPS IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IS TO BE ABLE TO
HELP INCREASE THAT GRANT
WRITING CAPACITY BECAUSE THIS.
REGION IS CRUCIAL THAT- THAT
DESIGNING FIRE RESILIENCE IS
REALLY- A PRIORITY AND SO I
HOPE YOU SEE THIS BUDGET AS ANY
EVENTS- AND I ALSO WANT CORRECT
THE RECORD ON THE TRILLION WE
CAN GET YOU SOME ACTUAL NUMBERS
ON- IN TERMS OF BY WE CAN PRINT
SOME. IN TERMS OF- HARDENING I.
AS HE THAT FIFTY MILLION EIGHT
OF. WILDLAND THE NEED TO BE
ADJUSTED WHAT THAT PRICE TAG IS
AND I WANTED JUST- ONE LAST
POINT ON THAT IS WELL WHICH IS
THIS STRATEGIC. FRAMEWORK DOES
CREATE A- FOR FED PARTNERS TO
CO IN WITH US- THAT THAT THAT
HOME HARDENING TYLER WE- A VERY
CALM. THAT WE WILL BE ABLE TO
LEVERAGE THOSE BE A MITIGATION
DOLLARS AND ARE DESIGNING A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR PILOT.
SHOULD BE ABLE TO- LUNCH THAT
AND WE ARE. YOU KNOW WORKING
WITH THE BY DEMONSTRATION AND
TALKING WITH THEM ABOUT
PRIORITIZING FUNDING. OR LET'S
GET HEALTH AND WATERSHED HEALTH
AND PARTNERING WITH US ON SOME
OF THESE BETTER DATA ANALYTICS
BECAUSE THERE IS NOT GOING TO
BE ONE METRIC THAT TELLS YOU
CONGRATULATIONS. YOU HAVE
ACHIEVED RECENTLY IT'S- AND SO
IT. A COMBINE LONG MATCH.
ACROSS YEAH RESCUE. TO BE ABLE
TO. MY THAT HELP US BETTER- ARE.
PROJECT PRIORITIZATION AND ARE
PLANNING. MISTER BENSON OF
FINANCE YOU HAD YOU HAD UP OUR-
QUANTITATIVE. MAKE MATRIX. HI I
JUST WANTED TO GO ONE ISSUE
BRIEF AS OR HENRY. STUNNED WILL
SPEND SINCE JUST ONE MAKE SURE
IT'S THAT THE FUNDING WE
DISCUSSED EARLIER THIS FOR
DEFENSE MOST ENGINE AND INSPECT.
IS NOW THE- THIS IS NOT ALL
THAT THERE IS FOR WILL SPACE
INSPECTORS AN AUG RELATED TO-
OF AB THIRTY EIGHT. THERE IS
BASED FUNDING AND AN CAL FIRE
BUDGET FOR DEFENSE SPACE AND- I
DON'T HAVE THAT NUMBER I READ
FEEL TIME AHEAD- YOU WE CAN
LOOK IT UP BUT THAT IS BASS
LINE FUNDING FOR WILL STAY
INSPECT WITH IS NOT. TO THE
PROVIDE MORE FANS WILL SPACES
FOR AND WE CAN THREE. AND.
EIGHTY THIRTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
I THANK YOU EACH EVERYBODY ON
THE PHONE CALL THIS IS BEEN
HELPFUL I. WE HAVE A LOT MORE
TO BE DONE AND I COULD. I WANT
TO TALK ABOUT THE WHIP PROGRAM
WATER IMPROVE. THAT THAT. WE
WOULD ABOUT WELL. INSTEAD OF.
IS THE IS THAT IS PRAGUE IS FAR
I'M- YOU KNOW WE WERE LOOKING
AT HOW THE PROBLEM IS. BUT WE-
HAVE TO STICK TO OUR TIME.
SCHEDULE WE WILL BE STAFF WILL
BE REACHING OUT AS WELL AS
INDIVIDUAL MEMBERS- TO OUR
DIFFERENT PARTNERS THAT ARE
HERE- WE SEE. THE ALLEY-
APPRECIATE THE REPORTER YOU
CAME AND THE STIRS AN
INDICATION OF. THERE MIGHT BE
SOME MORE MONEY SPENT ON SOME
PROGRAMS AND- JUSTIFICATIONS
AND OTHERS BUT I THINK WE'RE
GOING TO. MOVE ON TO. OUR
PUBLIC COMMENT. PERIOD SO THANK
YOU EVERYBODY FOR THE- HOOF
PARTICIPATE SO FAR. AND
REGARDING THIS IS A PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THE GUY THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL AS A
REMINDER TODAY'S- PARTICIPATION
NUMBER IS EIGHT FOUR FOUR. TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR
NEXT SIX CODE IS FOURTEEN
SEVENTEEN SIX OH NINE. AND AS I
INDICATED EARLIER DUE TO TIME
CONSTRAINTS. AND TECNOL
CONSIDERATION BECAUSE PRO- THE
CHEERS LIKE MY- ME INSTITUTE AT
LIMITS SO TODAY I'M TO. ASK
EACH MEMBER- TO TRY TO CONFINE
THEIR COMMENTS AND REMARKS TO
ONE MINUTE LEVELLER AT
BASICALLY AN HOUR WOULD YOU
GIVE US SIXTY PEOPLE YOU CAN.
OBVIOUSLY TAX SEND AN EMAIL TO
THE COMMITTEE- LET'S BEGIN WITH
ANY WITNESSES HERE IN THE-
HEARING ROOM AND- PLEASE COME
FORWARD. MIKE FROM YEAH PLEASE
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MARK SMITH ON BEHALF OF THE
NATIONAL MARINE MANUFACTURERS
ASSOCIATION I'M A TAKE US ALL
THE WAY BACK O THE VERY FIRST
ITEM WE TALKED ABOUT VOTING-
I'M A LITTLE FRUSTRATED ON
BEHALF OF MY CLIENT WITH. THE
PROPOSAL THAT'S BEEN PLACED ON
THE TABLE AND WANT TO ADDRESS
THAT CLEARLY WANNA LET THE
DEPARTMENT KNOW WE APPRECIATE.
THE PROPOSAL WE DO RECOGNIZE
THAT FEEDING CREASES ON VOTERS
PROBABLY NEED TO BE A PART OF
THE CONVERSATION. BUT WE'VE
KNOWN THAT THERE WAS A PROBLEM
FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS NOW. WE
HAVE STAKEHOLDERS AND YOU'LL
HEAR FROM OTHER LOBBYIST LATER.
HAVE ENGAGE WITH THE DEPARTMENT
FOR A COUPLE YEARS BUT NOT
GOTTEN THE ANSWERS THAT WE
WANTED ABOUT THE STATUS OF THE
FUND EXPENDITURES OF THE FUND
REVENUES COMING IN. WE SENT A
LETTER IN MAY OF TWENTY TWENTY
LAST YEAR ASKING FOR ANSWERS TO
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS THAT ARE
ILLUMINATED IN THE STAFF REPORT.
WE GOT A RECEIPT. ALREADY
ANSWER TO THAT LETTER AT TEN OO
THREE PM LAST NIGHT. NINE
MONTHS LATER THAT DOESN'T
REALLY GIVE US A LOT OF TIME TO
PREPARE FOR TODAY'S HEARING- SO.
WE WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT
STAKEHOLDER ENGAGEMENT HERE
SHOULD BE PARAMOUNT- IF YOU'LL
INDULGE ME MISTER CHAIR JUST TO
WALK THROUGH A COUPLE QUICK
THINGS WE DO RECOGNIZE WHAT THE
DEPARTMENT SAYS. RELATIVE TO
THE INVESTMENTS AND BEACH
EROSION AND AQUATIC INVASIVE
SPECIES- SHOULD NOT REST SOLELY
ON THE BACKS OF THE VOTER
FUNDED AT THEIR OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS WHO ARE INTERESTED
IN THOSE PROGRAMS AND SHOULD
TRY TO FUND THEM. THE LOAN
PROGRAM HAS BEEN A STAPLE OF
DEPARTMENT A BODY WATER WAYS
FOR NUMBER OF YEARS THE LAST
FIVE YEARS IT HASN'T BEEN USED
MUCH BECAUSE INTEREST RATES
HAVE BEEN AT NEAR ZERO. SO THE
STATE HASN'T MADE ANY KIND OF
CHANGES TO ITS PROGRAM TO
ACCOMMODATE THAT THE PRESSURES
AND THE COMPETITION FROM THE
PRIVATE MARKET PLACE IT'S NOT
THAT THE PROGRAM IS INVALUABLE
IT'S JUST THE RIGHT NOW IT'S
AND WEIRD CIRCUMSTANCES. THE
BIGGEST THING THOUGH IS THIS
TWENTY NINETEEN SHIFT TO
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS OUT OF
THE FUND YEAH WHERE IS THAT
MONEY GOING AND WHAT DOES THAT
DO TO THE OVERALL AMOUNT SO A
210050% FEE INCREASE. WE CAN
TALK ABOUT IT BUT IT'S NOT OUR
PREFERRED SOLUTION AND WE'D
LIKE TO SEE SOME OF THESE OTHER
THINGS ADDRESSED AS WELL AGAIN
I WANT TO COMPLIMENT THE
DEPARTMENT AND THE DIVISION.
WHAT A COMPLIMENT YOUR STAFFS
FOR THE- THOROUGH ANALYSIS OF
THIS ISSUE WE LOOK FORWARD TO
MORE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THIS
TOPIC THANK YOU VERY MUCH YEAH
THE TRUTH TRIMMING UP OF THE
GAS FUND FOR SIXTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR SORT OF IS. THE
AVALANCHE THAT STARTED THE
WHOLE- ALL RIGHT ANYBODY ELSE
IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM NO THERE
LET'S SEE ARE THERE WITNESSES
IN ROOM FIVE ONE TWELVE WHO
WISH TO FIGHT PUBLIC COMMENT ON
THE SIDE OF THIS. THING NOBODY.
THERE ARE THANK YOU. LET'S MOVE
TO THE WITNESS WAITING PROVIDE.
PUBLIC COMMENT BEING.
TELECONFERENCING SERVICE
MODERATOR. NICK I THINK- IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE PROP PROPERTY
INDIVIDUALS WAITING AND PROVIDE
THE PUBLIC COMIC WE COMMENT WE
WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR TO MAKE A PUBLIC COMMENT
OVER THE PHONE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. AGAIN THAT IS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. PHOTO
TIMELINE NUMBER THIRTY THREE
THREE THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S KATHLEEN
FREEMAN AND I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES REPRESENTING ALL OF
CALIFORNIA'S FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES I WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS HER SUPPORT FROM THE
ITEMS UNDER ITEMS TWENTY THE
WHILE WEARING FORCE RESILIENT
EXPANDED PLAN. IT IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN- MEMBER CAN.
LEADER BEGAN MEETING REGULARLY
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION THROUGH
THE FORCE MANAGEMENT TASK FORCE
PROVIDE INPUT INTO THE STATE'S
PERSON BILLION PLAN AND I'LL BE
PER THE PLAN THE BASIS FOR MANY
OF THE FUNDING. PC TODAY IT'S
ASTRONOMICAL PORT SAID GOVERNOR
PROPOSAL TO TOLERATE RAN INTO
THREE MY DOLLARS FOR WILDFIRE
AND FOREST. NOT ONLY WILL THAT
THE OUR LOCAL AFTER TO REDUCE
CASTRO WILD MUCH REPORT HAD Y.
BUT STATE PLANNING ALSO PROVIDE
US CLASS THEY'LL TO THE FULL
GOVERNMENT HAS STATED MISTER TO
IMPROVE FOR SOMETHING LAND. IN
ADDITION SUPPORTING IMMEDIATE
FUNDING FOR FOREST PLAN. WE'RE
PRETTY PLEASED TO SEE ON FOR
COULD GRAHAM REGIONAL FOR FIRE
HAPPEN AND HOME HARDENING ALL
OUR DIRECT TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
FROM TO BILL THEIR- WE NEED THE
STATE PARKS NEXT. TO BUILD
STRONG AND MORE IS COMMUNITY IN
THE OF CHEN CLIMATE AN EXTRA
FIRES THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
OF THE- THANK YOU MODERATE.
WHAT. THANK YOU ARE COMMENT IS
FROM LINE TWENTY. TWO FOR YOUR
LINES OF. GOOD MORNING FIFTY
FROM THE WORLD COUNTY WERE. OF
REPRESENT THIRTY LAKH STATE WHY.
AND MUCH LIKE MY COLLEAGUES
FEEDBACK I WOULD ALL LIKE TO
OUR R. C. SUPPORT NOT ONLY THE
Y. FOR THROUGH THE STRAIGHT BUT
ALL FOR THE ITEM NUMBER. REGARD
AB EIGHT AT FINDING AND ALL
NUMBER NINE REGARD THE STATE
FIRE CREWS. WHILE WE THERE'S
ROOM FOR. WITHIN EACH THESE.
THAT'S BEEN BEEN THAT.
INCLUDING WHERE THE FUNDS
POSSIBLY COMPANY. WE DON'T FEEL
ANY MORE FOR DELAY OUR OF THESE
FUNDS FURTHER GIVING ME.
SEVERITY OUR STATE CONDITIONS
YEAR. INCLUDING THE VARIANT
EARLY ACTION IN THE WILDFIRE
BEFORE LEGALLY DATA. NEEDS FOR
WAS MORE AS A MY NEEDED CAPITAL
OUTLAY AND ABOUT BASE ALONG
TERM BUT TO AND WE AGREE WITH
SENATOR. THE THAT IS A VICE-
THAT REACHES ALL FIRE PRO AREAS
BEYOND JUST BE A- CAN BE. AND I
LOOK FOR TO COULD WORKING YOU
ON THAT LAW TERM. MIGHT BE BUT
UNTIL THEN THAT WE ARE IN
SUPPORT AND THE- PROPOSED AFTER
MONDAY SOLUTION FOR THIS. THAT
IT ONE TO TWO BUDGET. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HER I
COMMON IN QUESTION JUST
WONDERING. FOLK JUST TO TIMES.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE IN. SPEAK FOR
SIX SECOND WE'RE NOT GOING TO
GO TO OUR- NEXT CALL PLEASE.
THANK YOU LINE TO FIVE THREE
FIVE YEAR LONG IS OPEN. YES SIR
WE CAST IN OF THE MY VALLEY
ABSENT THE BARE ERIC MANAGEMENT
THIS. I'D LIKE TO EXPRESS THE
POOR FOR ONE ITEM I DID MAKE
THE GUY. THE BY AND THAT'S
WILDFIRE RESPONSE CLEAN AIR.
THIS IS THE PROGRAM WAS- BY AB
EIGHT THIRTY AND THOUSAND
NINETEEN EVERYTHING FIVE
MILLION IN LACK- BUDGET BUT DID
NOT RECEIVE FUNDING THIS YEAR
PROVIDES- OF FILTRATION FOR
PUBLIC SPACES TO UP OUT AS A
WILDFIRE RESPONSE MEASURE
PUBLIC HEALTH. AND SECONDLY I'D
LIKE TO EXPRESS US SUPPORT FOR
THE TWO MILLION DOLLARS AND
PRESCRIBED FIRE FUNDING FOR AIR
DISTRICTS STREAMLINING AND I
WOULD ALSO MAKE THE OFFER TO
SENATORS LIKE OUT IN THE CHOIR
TO- TALK WITH THEM FURTHER
ABOUT THE BAY AREA DISTRICTS UP
PRESCRIBED FIRE AND- BURN
PLANNING. AND BRING IN ANY ERA
DISTRICTS APPROPRIATE THANKS.
EXCELLENT THANKS NEXT. WE WILL
APPLY THIRTY EIGHT THREE. IN
LINES OF. A GOOD MORNING GOOD
MORNING CHAIRMAN LIKE HOUSE
AGAIN OF THE MY NAME IS KENDALL
WHATEVER AND GET BY. I DEFENDER
SUPPORT THE- OVERALL Y.
RESILIENCY AND WE URGE ACTS
WHERE THOSE ACTIONS RESULT IN
THAT YOU EXPELLER PRICE OUTCOME.
WE STRONGLY THE INCREASE
ACCIDENT FIRE. CRITICALLY
LANDSCAPER REATTACH INCREASED
FIRE. I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
RESPONDING AREA QUICKLY OF
OFFENDER SUPPORT THE FUNDING
FOR THE ON PARK BETTER MANAGED
ON THEIR- BUT WE ARE CREEK BY
THE FACT THAT THEY- FAILED
INCLUDED FUNDING FOR THE- TRUCK.
THE DEPARTMENT ENVIRONMENTAL.
AND PERMITTING FOUR FOUR FIRE
PROJECT. ON THE COMMITTEE GOING
TO SEE IF. BUDGET ARM THAT AND
IT'S RISKY THE DURING THAT A
PART IN WHICH APART SAYS THAT
THEY HAVE THE CAPACITY CARRY
OUT ONLY 26% WRITTEN BY REVIEW
AND PERMITTING. AND GIVEN THAT
WE BELIEVE THAT THE BUDGET
SHOULD AND FUNDING FOR BACK TO
THE OF THE TO DO THAT. AS
SECOND WE WOULD STRONGLY TO THE
IMPACT BY BASED MANAGEMENT
PARTICULAR ABOUT REMOTE SENSING
AND CAR OVERSEE FOR PERSONAL
BURNS. ENTER AND FINALLY WE
TRONG SUPPORT THE FUNDING FOR
TRAVEL ENGAGED THANK YOU. I DID
HAVE A NOTE- CDF AND I'LL GET
TO PLAY NEXT PLACE. WILL NINE
THIRTY TO THREE TWO LINE OF
OPEN. IT MORE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME INTO EDWARDS ON THE
PRIDE CAL FIRE LOOK TWENTY ONE.
YOUR CAL FIRE STATE FIRE BY.
I'M CALLING IN- READ TO THE
STAFFING AND BUDGET I CARE
MCGUIRE COMMENT STABBING IS NOT
BEING AND OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS WE'VE INTO EVERY SEASON
WHAT ARE IN TIED BEHIND OUR
BACK. IN EACH YEAR IS NOT A THE
PRO. OUR ENGINE ON AND ARE
WARNING FOR NOW THREE TO EIGHT
ACRES. ALL THOSE INJURED ARE
UNDER. EXPAND ON FIELD
REDUCTION WE ARE REQUESTING
THAT MORE BE CONSIDERED IT EACH
YEAR BY REFUSING GET WORSE AND
WORSE AND WE KEEP KICKING THE
CAN DOWN THE ROAD THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU NEXT. LINE
THIRTEEN ONE THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. CHRIS ROSA ON BEHALF OF
HEALTH FOREST BE CALIFORNIA
FORESTRY ASSOCIATION. PART OF
THE ADMINISTRATION'S WILDFIRE
RESILIENCY PACKAGE TO HELP WITH
THE STATE PLANS TO INCREASE THE
PACE AND SCALE OF FOREST
MANAGEMENT AND FIRE RESISTANCE
PLEASE KNOW WE REALLY NEED
INVESTMENT IN INFRASTRUCTURE TO
MEET THESE GOALS OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL DECADES TO MEET TIMBER
HARVEST RULES IN CALIFORNIA THE
REDUCTION AND FEDERAL TIMBER
SALES B. INDUSTRY HAS BEEN
RIGHT FIVE THIS. REDUCED
WORKLOADS FORCED CLOSED A LOT
OF MILK WE WENT FROM OVER ONE
HUNDRED MALES WHO ONLY TWENTY
SIX TODAY PILE BURNING IS NOT A
SMALL PART ALTERNATIVE TEN
BILLS PILE BURNING IS NOT A
SMALL SMART ALTERNATIVE TO BIO
ENERGY WE MUST HAVE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WITHOUT IT
WE WON'T TURN THE CORNER. I'M
ON WORK FORCE DEVELOPMENT RIGHT
NOW THE SHEER VOLUME OF WORK ON
THE GROUND WILL NEED TO BRING
INCREASE FROM OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA- INSTEAD LET. WE
INVEST IN WORK TO AND THIS WILL
HAVE A REAL AND- IMPACT ON
CALIFORNIA'S WORLD ECONOMIES ON
PERMITTED FISHING PIER- PLEASE
SEE THE FEATHER PRIORITY IS
TREMENDOUSLY IMPORTANT WE ARE
ESPECIALLY INTERESTED IN
EFFORTS TO ALLOW FOR
SYNCHRONICITY AND PERMITTING.
AND LASTLY WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THE CLIMATE CATALYST BOND WE
NEED ACCESS TO CAPITAL.
MURSCHEL BONE ARE NOT AVAILABLE
TO US WITHOUT LONG TERM SUPPLY
AND MARKET CONTRACTS IN PLACE
OF THE PROMISE. OF LOW INTEREST
LOANS VIA THE CATALYST FUND IS
SOMETHING THAT WE TRULY NEED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT. NEXT
COMMENT COMES FROM LINE THIRTY
SIX THREE SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SH GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
SENATORS THE CONSTRUCTION MAP
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY AND
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE SOME PUBLIC COMMENTS
THIS MORNING. ASSEMBLY WANT TO
SPEAK TO ISSUE TWENTY
PERTAINING TO THE WILDFIRE AND
FOREST RESILIENCE STRATEGY THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY STRONGLY
SUPPORTS THE GOVERNOR SUPPOSED
TO RETURN TWENTY THREE MILLION
IN EARLY ACTION A CORPORATION
TO WILDFIRE RESILIENCE. THERE
ARE SHOVEL READY PROJECTS
CRITICAL TO ADDRESSING THE
THREAT OF CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRE
HOWEVER MANY OF THESE PROJECTS
AT IDLE SIMPLY WAITING FOR
FUNDING TO IMPLEMENT THEM. THE
PRIMARY REASON FOR DOING IT IS
THE TIMING THE SOONER WE CAN
ALLOCATE FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE FUNDING THE MORE
LIKELY THE PROJECT IN COMPLETED
IN ADVANCE OF THE UPCOMING FIRE
SEASON. YEAH FUNDING PROPOSAL
ALSO AND COMMERCIAL. CLIMB KIND.
TO ADDRESS THE INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDS TO INCREASE PREVENTION
ACROSS THE STATE. THIS FUNDING
IS CRITICAL TO REGIONAL
ECONOMIC RECOVERY WILL
CALIFORNIANS WELL AS FUTURE
CLIMATE. WILDFIRE RESILIENCE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
CENTERS. ON THE ISSUE OF THE
SUPPORT YOUR FRUSTRATION
REGARDING THE SEVERITY OF THE
ISSUE AND HOW THESE PROPOSED
RESOURCES ARE QUOTE A DROP IN
THE BUCKET CONSIDERING THE
IMMENSE AND IMMEDIATE NEEDS.
THAT WE BELIEVE THAT THEY
REPRESENT FAR MORE IN THE
PREVENTION OF MORE CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES. WE RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT- NEXT WE HAVE A COMMON
FROM LINE TWENTY SIX TWO SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SAN MEMBERS
SPEND UNTIL I GOT OUT OF THE
CALIFORNIA AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL OFFICERS ASSOCIATION.
SUPPORT THE TWO MILLION FOR
CONTINUING THE S. B. TWELVE
SIXTY MANDATED LOCAL AIR
DISTRICT PRESCRIBED FIRE
PROGRAM WHICH EXPANDS
PRESCRIBED FIRE BURN PERMITTING
AIR QUALITY MONITORING PUBLIC
OUTREACH AND OTHER RELATED
WORK. WELL THE FUNDING AMOUNT
IS MODEST THIS PROGRAM IS
PROVIDING CRITICAL STATEWIDE.
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY
BENEFITS. YOU CAN MAKE FUNDING
ONGOING AND THE L. A. O. HAS
RECOMMENDED YOU CONSIDER. THE
WASHINGTON CONSIDER INCREASING
FUNDING SO WE CAN DO EVEN MORE.
EXPANDING PRESCRIBED FIRE WHICH
WILL REQUIRE INDUSTRY TO HELP
WILL BE KEY TO MEETING THE GOAL
OF CREATING ONE MILLION ACRES
AND- THE BEGINNING IN TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. AS IDENTIFIED IN
THE RECENTLY SIGNED U. S.
FOREST SERVICE CALIFORNIA AND A
YEAR OKAY. WE WOULD WELCOME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE FURTHER
DISCUSSIONS REGARDING ANY
QUESTIONS THE CHAIR. AND
SENATOR MCGUIRE MAY HAVE ABOUT
IT DISTRICT PRESCRIBED FIRE
BURN PERMITTING AND FINALLY
LASTYEAR'S BUDGET INCLUDING
FIVE POINT FIVE MILLION FOR NEW
INCENTIVE PROGRAM TO ESTABLISH
CLEANER SENATORS. WHICH PROVIDE
SAFE WATER PEACH DURING
WILDFIRE SMOKE ABOUT. THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET DOES NOT INCLUDE
FUNDING AND WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR THIS
WORK WHERE THE EFFORT THANK.
YOU THANK YOU NEXT. NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE. ONE EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BUT YOU'RE A MEMBERS
JERRY DESMOND WITH RECREATIONAL
BOATERS OF CALIFORNIA WITH
BRIEF COMMENTS REGARDING THE
PROPOSED SOLUTION TO THE
HARBORS A WATER WILL CUT CRAP
OF ALREADY FUND DEFICIENCY AT
THIS MOMENT WE JUST RECEIVED A
RESPONSE FROM. THE DIVISION OF
BOATING AND WATERWAYS TO A MAY
OF NEXT UP. TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
BOATING COMMITTEE LETTER
EXPRESSING. WE'RE SEVERAL KINDS
AND REQUESTS ONE OF WHICH IS
FOR ACCURATE DATA ON ALL THE
VOTING REVENUES PAID FOR THE
STATE AND OTHERS FOR A MEETING
DIALOGUE AND ANOTHER IS FOR AN
EVALUATION OF ALTERNATIVES THE
LETTER GIVES THE- BASIC
INFORMATION FOR THE FIRST TIME
THAT WE'RE EVALUATING AT THE
MOMENT. WE'RE NOT IN A POSITION
TO SAY THAT WE SUPPORT THE
210050000% A REGISTRATION FEE
INCREASE THAT FAILED TO TAKE
INTO CONSIDERATION THE
CONSIDERATION OF THE OF THE
FUNDS THAT ARE SPENT FOR NON
VOTING PROGRAMS AND SERVICES IN
THE PROPERTY TAXES THE
SIGNIFICANT PROPERTY TAXES WE
PAY. ANOTHER IS THAT IT
HIGHLIGHTS THAT THERE'S A
HUNDRED AND SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY AND VOTING THE
FUEL TAX DOLLARS ARE COLLECTED
BY THE STATE ONLY FIFTEEN
MILLION PHARMACY BY THE BOX ART
IS A WATERCRAFT- BOBBY FUND AND
THEN. THIRDLY UP AND WE
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS TODAY
BY THE ADMINISTRATION THAT
THERE WILL BE A MEANINGFUL
DIALOGUE WITH STAKEHOLDERS. WE
ENCOURAGE THIS TO START NOW
THAT HASN'T HAPPENED THE
DIFFICULTLY ENOUGH IN THE PAST
AND THAT IS NOT AWAIT THE
INSTITUTION OF THE 210050%
REGISTRATION FEE INCREASE
BEFORE THERE IS A STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS. TO LOOK AT
ALTERNATIVES AND THE CHANGES
AND IMPROVEMENTS THAT COULD BE
MADE. THANK YOU. VERY MUCH. Q.
NEXT. NEXT WE HAVE A CALM FROM
LINE EIGHT LINE EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE-
I'M WINSTON BUMPUS PRESIDENT OF
RECREATIONAL BOATERS OF
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTING THE
ESTIMATED TWO MILLION VOTERS IN
CALIFORNIA. WE BELIEVE THERE
ARE ABOUT EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND REGISTERED BOTH IN
CALIFORNIA AND THIS PROPOSED
210050% INCREASE TO EXTRACT AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS FROM BOATERS WHO MOST
ARE MAKING. UNDER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR AND 95%
OF ALL REGISTERED BOATS WE
BELIEVE OUR UNDER TWENTY TWENTY
SIX FEET. OR UNDER OR SMALLER
WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT ALL OF THE
ACTIVITIESTHAT PEOPLE COULD DO
DURING THE PANDEMIC VOTING WAS
ONE OF THE SAFE OUT OUR OUTDOOR
ACTIVITIES- THAT THEY COULD DO-
AND THEREFORE IT WAS A RECORD
YEAR FOR BOTH SALES AND
REGISTRATION FEES. THE BOTTOM
LINE WE DON'T SUPPORT THE
PROPOSED INCREASE TO THE VOTERS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIANS
REGISTRATION FEES- BUT WE ALSO
RESPECT YOUR WITH US BUT
MEASURE BEFORE SHE THIS LETTER-
FROM THE W. LAST NIGHT IN
RESPONSE TO A LETTER WE- SENT
TO THEM ON MAY TWENTIETH. IT
PROVIDED SOME VERY INTERESTING
INFORMATION FOR THE FIRST TIME
INCLUDED INFORMATION THAT THE
STATE GETS A HUNDRED AND SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN BOATING FUEL
TAX FEES. AND ONLY FIFTEEN
MILLION GOES TO D. B. W. OTHERS
OF THAT GOES TO THE GENERAL
FUND- AND STATE PARKS. AND THIS
DOESN'T INCLUDE ANY OF THE
COUNTY PROPERTY TAXES PAID BY
VOTERS WHICH IS MUCH LARGER
NUMBER. WE'VE ALREADY MADE OUR
CONCERNS KNOWN TO THE DIVISION
OF BOATING AND WATERWAYS AND
STATE PARKS AND PLAN TO VOICE
UP AND DOWN AT THE UPCOMING
BOATING AND WATERWAYS
COMMISSION. ON THE ELEVENTH
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU NEXT. WELCOME LINE FOR
THREE THREE YOU KNOW IS OPEN.
BUT I APOLOGIZE IT LOOKS LIKE
IT'S LINE THIRTY NINE LINE
THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
OKAY I HOPE THIS YEAR WILL
WORK- MY NAME IS RICHARD JENNER
AND I'M REPRESENTING OUR
RICHARD WILSON'S- ORGANIZATION
WIDE FOREST MATTER- I'VE BEEN
AWARE FOR YEARS NOW- BUT A LOT
OF THESE FORESTRY ISSUES IN AND
TAKING PART IN A LOT OF THE
FOREST MANAGEMENT TASK FORCE.
AND OTHER- MEETINGS AND
REGARDING ALL THIS IS AN
INCREDIBLE THING THAT NEEDS TO
BE DONE. GIVEN CALIFORNIA'S
FORTY THOUSAND- INHABITANTS IN
THE CONDITIONS IN THE FOREST I
WILL ONE OF THINGS IS BEING OUR
FIRST ROUND BOUT ISN'T
ACTUALLY GETTING A LONG TERM
PLAN TO ACTUALLY GET HELP THE
POOREST OF LARGER OLDER TREES.
OF ALL THIS EMERGENCY STUFF IS
A VERY IMPORTANT THINGS TO DO
SO WITHOUT REALLY REBUILDING
THE FOREST THERE WERE LIKE- SO
MUCH- BECAUSE AFTER ALL WHO ARE
TRULY AS LAUREN ACT. CRAZY IN
THE SITUATION WE'RE IN NOW AND
IT'S GOING TO TAKE- A REAL.
DEDICATION DIRECTION CHANGES TO
BE MORE. THAN JUST EMERGENCY
NECKS I HAVE A COMMENT FROM
LINE THIRTEEN THREE ZERO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I WANT TO
FIRST THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY THIS
MORNING MY NAME IS BOB SHERMAN
I'M SPEAKING TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE AMERICAN FOREST FOUNDATION.
AN ORGANIZATION THAT DELIVERS
MEANINGFUL CONSERVATION IMPACT
BY EMPOWERING FAMILY FOREST
OWNERS TO TAKE ACTION ON THEIR
LAND. FF WORKS ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
FAMILY FOREST OWNERS. AND THESE
LANDS THAT COMPRISE A THIRD OF
HIGH RISK POOREST AREAS IN THE
STATE MAKING TREATMENT
EVERYONE'S PLANS. A PRIORITY IN
WILDFIRE RISK MITIGATION. OF
THE WILDFIRE AND FOREST
RESILIENCE ACTION PLAN ALSO
STATES. WE INCREASING THE PACE
AND SCALE OF COURSE MANAGEMENT
ACROSS THE STATE CAN ONLY BE
ACHIEVED THEIR SIGNIFICANT
CONTRIBUTIONS FROM SMALL
PRIVATE LANDOWNERS. THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSAL THE
NUMBER OF INCREASED INVESTMENT
IN WILDFIRE AND FOREST
RESILIENCY THAT AFFECT ON OUR
PARTNERS ARE PROUD TO STAND
BEHIND. SHORT AND LONG TERM
INVESTMENTS IN PROGRAMS LIKE
THE POOREST HEALTH PROGRAM AND
SPEAKER IN ADDITION THE
WORKFORCE TRAINING MARKET
DEVELOPMENT AND OTHER
PRIORITIES WILL BE CRITICAL TO
ENSURING FAMILY FOREST OWNERS
CAN CONTINUE TO CONTRIBUTE TO
SOLVING WILDFIRE CREDIT THAT.
PROVIDING CONSISTENT FUNDING TO
PROGRAMS LIKE SEE IF IT IS
NECESSARY BUT NOT SUFFICIENT TO
ADDRESSING THE NEED FOR ITS
PRODUCTION ON FAMILY POOREST
ACRES. BUT HAS BEEN DEBATED
MANY TIMES THIS MORNING BROUGHT
INVESTMENT IS NECESSARY TO
ENSURE THE CALIFORNIA FORESTS
WILL BE PROTECTED FROM THE
INCREASING THREAT CLIMATE
CHANGE. FOR THESE REASONS THE
AMERICAN FOREST FOUNDATION
SUPPORTS THE BILLION DOLLARS
PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR FOR
WILDFIRE AND FOREST RESILIENCE
AS WELL AS THE NEED FOR
INCREASED INVESTMENT. IN SMALL
IN CALIFORNIA'S WILDFIRE AND
FOREST RESILIENCE ACTION PLAN.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF HIS BUDGET
ITEMS AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE ON THE JOURNEY TOWARD
A MORE RESILIENT CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT.
BECAUSE LINE FOUR THREE FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. DO YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN- INSTEAD OF IT
IS THE THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO- TO REPRESENT
THEM PERSPECTIVE FROM MY
RECREATIONAL BOATERS OF
CALIFORNIA. I AM A VOTER IN SAN
DIEGO. AND I HAVE SOME SERIOUS
CONCERNS ABOUT THE PROPOSAL FOR
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
SURGICALLY ON THE PUBLIC BEACH
RESTORATION- THIS- THIS-
PROGRAM HAS BEEN FUNDED BY BOTH
A DOLLARS FOR MANY MANY YEARS
AND THAT HAS CONTRIBUTED TO THE
IMBALANCE OF THE H. W. R. S.
AND- I HAVE SOME SERIOUS
DIFFICULTY. IN UNDERSTANDING
WHY VOTERS ARE BEING ASKED TO
BEAR TWO HUNDRED AND 50% C.
INCREASE TO CORRECT THE
IMBALANCE- ON THE AQUATIC
INVASIVE SPECIES PROGRAM. THERE
ARE A LOT OF OTHER GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES THAT- DERIVE BENEFIT
FROM MATH PROGRAM- BOATING
DOLLARS HAVE BEEN USED FOR MANY
YEARS- TO FUND IT. AND VOTERS
NOW. HAVE AGREAT DEAL OF
DIFFICULTY IN UNDERSTANDING WHY
THEY NEED TO BEAR A 210050% SEE
INCREASED TO CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT. AND KWAGGA AND ZEBRA
MUSSEL INFESTATION. THERE IS
ALREADY A SEPARATE FEE
SURCHARGE IMPOSED ON VOTERS WHO
LAUNCH THEIR BOATS IN FRESH
WATER TO THAT SUPPOSED TO FUND
THIS PROGRAM. WE HAVE A GREAT
DAY THE DIFFICULTY IN
UNDERSTANDING WHY VOTERS SHOULD
BE ASKED TO BEAR TWO HUNDRED
AND 50% FEE INCREASE BEYOND OF
THAT ADDITIONAL STREET. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT.
WELCOME LINE THIRTY ONE THREE
ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LIKE US
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ALL MAY SO THIS IS A CHORUS
TRUST WANT TO SPEAK TO THE
WILDFIRE AND FOREST RESILIENCE
PROPOSAL WHICH WE ARE
ENTHUSIASTICALLY SUPPORT ABOVE
AND URGE THAT YOU IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO MOVE FORWARD ON
FUNDING THE EARLY ACTION ITEMS
WHERE THOSE THE BRING. YOUR
TERM BASKETS AND LET US NOT
LOSE ANOTHER FIRE SEASON
COUPLED ADDITIONAL COMMENTS I'D
THAT ARE GOING TO HAVE ONE
BILLION DOLLARS IS AN EXCITING
START ON THIS CHALLENGE BUT
GIVEN THE SCALE OF OUR TALENT
AROUND. THE STATE THAT REALLY
NEEDS TO BE BUILT. THE LEVEL OF.
COMMIT FROM THE STATE AT A
MINIMUM- THERE IS A NOTABLE IN
THE PACKAGE ON FORCES LANDSCAPE
RESILIENCE WHICH WE THINK IS
REALLY IMPORTANT. ONE REASONS
OF THIS SCALE OF THE FOREST
FIRES WITHIN THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS HAVE REALLY BEEN TRULY
STUNNING BUT ALSO AND I THINK
THE THIRD ONLY MENTION THAT
THESE LANDSCAPES BRING REALLY
BROAD PUBLIC BENEFITS BROWN'S
MOST OBVIOUSLY WATER AS THE
WATER SPURS. FOR SO MUCH OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND YOU
HAVE A CULTURAL REGIONS THESE
HAVE A LOT OF PUBLIC BENEFITS-
WELL TO THE PUBLIC. AND
THEREFORE ARE REALLY
APPROPRIATE. THINGS THE FUN
FROM THE GIRL PLAN. AND FINALLY
TO BE BRIEF HERE ARE THE- WAY
FOR YOU TO THE LETTER THAT WE
SENT A COUPLE DAYS AGO. THE
HIGHLIGHTS YOU OTHER SUGGESTING
THE GROUP LIKE MAKING SURE OF
THE BRAND FROM. ARE ALL WELL
COORDINATE WITH EACH OTHER AND
WITH OTHER STATE. AROUND I
CLIMATE PLANNING BIODIVERSITY.
REALLY GET THE BEST BENEFITS
FOR SOME OF THESE ACTIVITIES.
AND THINKING ABOUT THE-
CHALLENGES OF MEDITATION
MANAGEMENT AND GETTING BACK TO
A RESILIENT CONDITION ON THE
LANDSCAPE. AS A LONG TERM
PROJECTS. ACTIVITIES ARE GONNA
GOOD WILL FIRST BUT NEED TO BE
BEEN MANAGING- PLUMAS MOMENTUM
GOING THANK YOU FOR TIME. IF
NEXT. THANK YOU ORDER ONLINE
SEVENTEEN ONE SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THIS IS MARK
FENSTER MAKER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICT.
TRANSPORT AND ITEM TWENTY ARE
WE SURE THE COMMITTEES
RESTORATION. THERE WAS EXPRESS
BUT WE SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL
THEY BEGIN TO MOVE THE STATE. A
FASTER PACE AND SCALE. I'M
REALLY WANT TO CALL ATTENTION
TO SUPPORTING THE TRIBAL
ENGAGEMENT DOLLARS AS WELL AS
THE FUNDING FOR THE REGIONAL
FORCING FIRE CAPACITY PROGRAM.
RTD'S ACROSS THE STATE FROM THE
CHAIR UP THE NORTH COAST. DOWN
IN THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
RIDER SUB GRANTEES ARE DIRECTLY
IN TEAMS OF THIS PROGRAM
HELPING US TO DEVELOP TAILORED
STRATEGIES FOR EACH REGION
WORKING WITH LANDOWNERS AND
PRIVATE BUSINESSES. AND WORKING
ALONG WATERSHED ZERO POINT
MISTER CHAIR NOT JUST THAT
COUNTY LINES. AND ALSO STARTED
REACHING OUT TO OUR COLLEAGUES
IN AREAS THEY'RE NOT YET HAVE
BEEN REGION SO THAT AS THIS
FUNDING BECOMES AVAILABLE
THEY'RE GONNA BE READY TO GO.
FOR THAT REASON WE SUPPORT THE
EARLY ACTION. FUNDING FOR THIS
PROGRAM THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE FORTY FOUR IF THERE
ARE OTHER PUBLIC COMMENTS ME
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO NINE FOUR
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU KAREN HOW CAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS PRETTY
BAD I THINK WHAT YOU'RE A
BUSINESS COUNCIL AND THE FEAR
CONSORTIUM WE URGE SUPPORT FOR
THE PROPOSED THREE HUNDRED
TWENTY THREE MILLION EARLY
ACTION APPROPRIATION THE
WILDFIRE UNFORTUNATELY AND-
WITH STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
DIRECT FUNDING FOR THE SIERRA
NEVADA CONSERVANCY AND
CALIFORNIA TAHOE CONSERVANCY.
AS WELL AS THE INVESTMENT IN
THE CLINIC CATALYST FUND. THERE
ARE SOME ALREADY WILDFIRE
COMMUNITY PROTECTION IN
LANDSCAPE DESIGN PROJECT
CRITICAL PROGRESS IN THE
BRIGHT. WITHOUT IMMEDIATE
ACTION BE PROJECT WILL CONTINUE
TO SIT IDLE WAITING FOR FUNDING
IMPLEMENT THEM. THE SOONER WE
CAN ALLOCATE EARLY ACTION
FUNDING THE MORE LIKELY THE
PROJECT CAN BE COMPLETED PRIOR
TO THE UPCOMING. FIRE THAT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
BELIEVE THAT THAT. COMPLETES
THE QUEUE OF PEOPLE OTHER
MODERATOR THERE ANY OTHER
INDIVIDUALS WILLING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. TWO ADDITIONAL
HAVE STEPPED UP LET'S HEAR FROM
THEM. THANK YOU LINE FORTY TWO
FOUR TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING SALARY NARAL FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
THE CHAMBER IS IN SUPPORT OF
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET
THAT ALLOCATES A BILLION
DOLLARS FOR FOREST MANAGEMENT
AND THEREFORE SUPPORT THOSE
ITEMS. IN THE FORESTRY AREA
THAT WE TALKED ABOUT THIS
MORNING THANK YOU. NEXT.
BORDERLINE FORTY ONE FOUR ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING I DO HAVE A GENERAL
QUESTION MY NAME IS DONNA
BENNETT A RESIDENT OF THAT IN
CALIFORNIA YEAH MY QUESTION IS
THAT HOW HAS. THE EPT BROUGHT
IMPACTED THE STATE BUDGET AND
NOW HAS THEY ADDRESSED
RESTITUTION OF BILLS DOLLARS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THE
DIFFERENT DIFFERENT ENDING ALL
RIGHT ARE WE WILL CLOSE THE
PUBLIC HEARING BRING AFFECTED
THE DAY S. THANK YOU EVERYBODY
WHO PARTICIPATED- CENTER DOLLY
SENATE MCGUIRE CENTER STERN
LAST QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY
HAVE FOR COMMENTS. I THINK WE
HEARD A LOT FROM FOLKS THAT
THERE MAY BE OPPORTUNITIES TO
DO MORE EARLY MONEY TO HELP OUT
AND DIFFERENT DIFFERENT AREAS
THERE'S AREAS THAT HAVE BEEN
FUNDED OBVIOUSLY WE HAVE
JURISDICTION OVER CAP AND TRADE
AND HOW THAT BALANCES ONE TIME
MONEY VERSUS CONTINUAL MONEY.
WE WANT TO. MAKE SURE WE GET
THE BIGGEST BANG FOR THE BUCK-
I SET THE TONE THERE'S NO MORE
OKAY SO LET'S LET'S GO TO OUR
PHOTO NICK ONLY CALENDAR IS
EIGHT INDICATED EARLIER THE
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT HAS BEEN
REMOVED FOR WAITING FOR A
REPORT THERE- WHAT'S THROUGH
THIS IN TWO BATCHES AND I'LL
CONSIDER A MOTION ON ISSUE
NUMBER ONE ISSUES THREE FOUR
AND FIVE ISSUE SEVEN ISSUES
NINE TEN ELEVEN AND ISSUES
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN FIFTEEN IS
ADMIT MOTION I SEE FOR YOU
MISTER DALI. YES THERE'S A
MOTION BY MISTER DOLLY- PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. WHY CASKEY HI MY
CASKEY I DOLLY. FINALLY I
REQUIRE MCGUIRE DURING. THE
TONIGHT STERN HI. CLOSE ROLE
TALLY THE VOTES THE FOUR ZERO
THE I. SEVEN FOUR ZERO THOSE-
ITEMS ARE PROVED THIS TO IN THE
SECOND- BATCH OF ISSUES ISSUES
NUMBER TWO NUMBER SIX AND
NUMBER TWELVE IS THAT EMOTIONS
CENTER REQUIRE TO MOVE HERE'S
MY QUESTION BY SEN ACQUIRE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. WHY
CASKEY HI WIECKOWSKI AYE DOLLY
DELANO MCGUIRE RIGHT MCGUIRE
AYE STERN. NINE STERN HI THREE
ONE CLOSE ROLE TALLY THE VOTE
THE AYES HAVE IT THREE ONE
THOSE MOTIONS- ARE APPROVED.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL BE BACK HERE
NEXT TUESDAY AT EIGHT O'CLOCK
PURCHASE. LET EVERYBODY KNOW
THAT IS A THREE DAY WEEKEND
EVERYBODY HERE IN THE PAST SO
WE WILL BE HERE ON THAT TUESDAY
AFTER THE THREE DAY OF MONDAY
WEEKEND THANK YOU FOR ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED.
IN THE TEST MY TO GATE TODAY IF
YOU WEREN'T ABLE TO TESTIFY
WE'VE KEPT THESE MATTERS OPEN
WE'RE INTERESTED IN YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS.
PLEASE WRITE TO THE BUDGET IN
FISCAL REVIEW COMMITTEE VISIT
OUR WEBSITES YOUR COMMENTS ARE
IMPORTANT IT GIVES US
OPPORTUNITIES TO- PUSH THE
DIFFERENT DEPARTMENTS AND AGAIN
THANK YOU EVERYBODY FOR YOUR
PATIENCE IN CORPORATIONS WITH
CONCLUDED THE JENNIFER TODAY'S
HEARING. AND THE SENATE BUDGET
AND FISCAL REVIEW SEPARATED TO
IS HER.